foreign
looking clean
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
thank you
say hi everyone we're here well number
five Hikaru Nakamura will take on world
number seven Fabiano caruana in the big
winner final but before that in just a
few moments four players will enter the
play zone to fight for survival among
them Wesley saw and Magnus Carlsen we
are so excited this is day three of the
adjustable Masters
how on Earth are we save this position
well Magnus just widening his eyes
they're shocked by this last decision
more than five minutes wow he's showing
no fear whatsoever is inching up this is
Checkmate incoming and then King goes to
A6 and there are no checks on the boys
into the white side holding on here for
dear life look at that celebration
you see the bar go back to equal oh my
gosh it is beautiful tattoo awareness
over we have a winner
hello and welcome everyone we've had
knee inviting action so far we started
with eight players we're down to six
things are heating up in the chessable
Masters and to guide us through the
action in the studio got Master David
Howell bday Master James Canty let's go
and Grandmaster Robert Hess
we had two epic armageddons David what
was the highlight for you on day two so
many armageddons so many highlights I
should have said we saw Magnus squeeze
through but also that match between
Fabiano caruana and vladislav artemia it
was really really close in the end but
Fabiano when it mattered came up with
those incredible moves yeah so much
action on day two James what was your
big takeaway Fabiano Queen f8 and we
great it was all over the Internet it
was ridiculous yeah yeah what a move by
Fabi you found in seconds that one is
going to go down in history books and
that has been so exciting Robert to see
the players play with barely anytime on
the clock now traditionally we've seen
the armageddon's but here it is the
bidding Armageddon do you enjoy that
twist oh who doesn't enjoy it because
you pick your own time so if you bid too
low that could be a problem for you
we've seen that in the past matches and
for five minute Corona it worked out
yesterday but today's a new day and he
faced off in Sakara Nakamura yeah big
matches coming up today let's take a
look at our bracket this is where we
stand going into day three wow I look at
that loser's quarterfinals and it just
seems you know what you lose one game
you have a tough day and that's the mix
you land up in that right there is a
nightmare David we're going to focus a
little bit on that
who in that bracket whose chest has
impressed you the most well you would
expect me to say maybe Magnus Carlson
but actually I'm going to say vladislava
Artemis in the lower half of that loses
quarterfinal he was really unlucky to
actually have to drop down to this
bracket yesterday he was very close
against Fabiano caruana and uh live on
Iranian will have his handful dealing
with him
you see in our time you have play God
lava chess with just seconds on the
clock but James he's got to be careful
to not go so low on the clock today in
fact I mean artemia is just you know a
different kind of Grisha you know they
say they they have to be related the way
that they played his chest right they
get lower on time and they play better
chess they got to be related somehow but
of course if our team gets low on time
he gets stronger right so I think it's
the other way around yeah
that is well that are Italian style is
so much like Christian he comes into
these time scrambles but then just plays
Incredible chess Robert do you agree of
course how could you not
the Siberian elephant is over 3 100 in
bullet on chess.com he's one of the very
best and we saw it yesterday we saw it
the day before he continues to impress
with mere seconds on the clock yeah I
love it we've been enjoying the play but
our time is in the losers bracket today
and now this is such an exciting time
for the Chess World Chess has never been
bigger and the tour has played a big
role in evolving it into the East boy
now take a look at the road map of the
biggest ever season of the Champions
chest star
the 2023 Champions chess tour is the
biggest tour yet with a thrilling brand
new format and two million dollars in
prizes it's the richest online
tournament of all time
the tour begins with six elite events
taking place between February and
September
each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
plans locking in 56 players to the main
events
there players are a group into three
divisions and compete for 235 thousand
dollars in prizes each time
victory in division one in any of the
six events secures a spot directly to
the eight player Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate toward
leaderboard points across the six events
competing for another one hundred
thousand dollars in prize money and the
unsecured playoff spots will go directly
to the top leaderboard finishers at the
end of the year we have two weeks of
incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs from which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals to a single elimination bracket
which will ultimately determine our
champion
together the playoffs and finals feature
a whopping 500 thousand dollars in
prizes
there could only be one
in December of 2023 an Undisputed tour
Champion will be crowned
let the games begin
our action will be on division one of
the 235 thousand dollar adjustable
Masters but of course action is on in
division two and three as well Robert it
is so critical it is also the path to
division one for the next event yeah the
winner of division two gets automatic
placement in division one you get that
prize money and those tour points and we
know how important that is yeah and you
got some really big names fighting there
as well uh yes we do indeed you have
former world champions no matter where
you look in the winners bracket of
division two right now it is super
exciting take a look at that just the
sheer strength of division two and in
the winner semi-final Robert I see a
clash of teenagers there nodded back up
to such off taking on Dennis lazovic
what do you expect from that it's one of
the former world champions the world
rapid Champion a few years ago notary
record he leads he is let his country
Uzbek sent to a gold medal in the
Olympiad and Maxine vashilagrove a
former world Blitz Champion he is
leading the 14th World Champion Vladimir
krummick right now but their second game
is underway and it's super exciting yeah
the Frenchman with three names taking on
the 14 World Champion we saw that
Vladimir kramnik is on the back foot
there what does he need to do against
the player like mvl to strike back uh
you see this your Peak rating and your
Peak ranking and you beat Gary Kasparov
to become the world champion that's the
form that he needs to refine here and
he's doing that in game two he is really
inspired in his second game the white
side of the Sassoon uh Vladimir crowd
playing E4 maybe it is best by test
after all I love it he is one of the 14
players to have ever broken into 2800
rating in the history of the game the
14th World Champion Robert as just as
getting younger especially in this
format we see that it is kramnik who's
holding the flag for the old God how
does he do it it's not just Vlad it's
also Rich for nothing on it a lot of
these players they may hear all those
calls oh they can't play the youngsters
anymore they certainly can he played on
the internet chess club way back in the
day he's played a lot of Blitz in his
life in fact yesterday he was playing
Armageddon blitz so he is fresh he is
ready and he's inspired I love it we'd
love to see Vladimir crime rate in
division one in the speed chess format
well there is also action on in division
three let's bring up our bracket and
look at that we've got Amin tabatabai
versus now walk it up had a brilliant
performance in the Olympiad what are you
expecting in this one Robert yeah that's
one that's hard to call because these
two players they go under the radar
because they're not at that super GM
2700 level but I see in the
quarterfinals in the losers bracket
Alexis Serrano he was in division one of
the air things Masters he already takes
out wagyi and the FFL gotta comp key
he's still afloat down there he's taking
on one of the quarterfinals of the
official random World Championship in
Matthias bluebound yeah absolutely so
much action on in the chessable Masters
there is prize money at stake there's
store points and the golden ticket to
the tour final with all that online
action is heating up on day three of the
adjustable Masters but first before we
get to it let's take a look at day two
a decision has been made by Wesley to
retreat with the Knight and Robert I see
that expression you are surprised it's
not just another blunder in one by
Wesley dropping upon David yes simply
he's forgotten that Knight takes D4 is
not available now
is paralyzed could barely move uh look
at this poor White Knight it's stuck
defending the A2 Square the White Queen
is stuck defending that night and uh I
think it's good night here for Wesley so
three queens on the board but the queen
can always fall back and no Perpetual
there and with that we see Hikaru he
knows he's done it
Rook is dived in jumped in both sides
creating threats here on every turn oh
that black king is in big big trouble
and six seconds on the clock Wesley if
he can land check mate with two seconds
left he's gonna be happy but it's gonna
be so hard to navigate this one if we
can just quickly get an update on that
one
what is happening look F7 is a maiden
one let's stay right here I think you
can just take the bishop he knows that
he's calculating but he knows he's done
it
what what what
because the black Rook can drop down
with a check and go behind save
oh these players are so good I've got to
say drop that Rook down Hikaru and you
will not lose this game and it is
official
has drawn his game against Wesley which
means Wesley moves on to the losers
bracket
oh my gosh that Bishop State hits the
queen and the rook in a row but also it
goes through the F2 Pawn so it's kind of
a double threat what a move from Fabiano
a world-class move from fabianos this is
a game-ending move double attack if he
finds it he wins on the spot look at
that the engine
he finds it and leans back he knows this
is a big moment has missed it and our
Tamia realizes this is busted for white
a big day of Chess coming up with a big
All-American Clash there in the winners
final as Fabiano caruana takes on Hikaru
Nakamura in division one we will talk
about that match really quickly but
before that Robert we've got a huge
update coming in from division two we
have a heartbreaking update because
Vladimir kramnik has Mouse slipped and
blundered his Queen in a strong position
against Maxine vasilograph he's now down
two games to none
yeah tough moment there for the world
champion Mouse lips these are this is
the curse of online rapid play it just
happens but it is part of the skill set
as well yeah there's no one better at it
than Hikaru Nakamura he's won all these
major speed test events and he does not
Mouse up pretty much ever yeah I've
never seen that happen well he's got a
big match ahead of him James Hikaru
versus Fabi what's your take on that
okay that's fabulous Fabi Flex a lot
Fabi in the gym now you know trying to
do his thing he's doing good in chess
obviously but then you got your car
Nakamura who's a man a myth a legend
everything else we have man we don't
know the rest right that man is very
strong and Fabio is going to be up
against some very strong opposition
today so you have to really bring his
best yeah so I've played some great
chess yesterday against our time I mean
that queen of Fate move I know we've
been speaking about it but we can't stop
talking about that it really was one of
the big moments in the chessable Masters
we will get to that Winners final but
before that there is action in the
elimination bracket with Wesley so
taking on Magnus and our tummyb against
Levon David is there a heavy favorite in
this one I'm going to say no Tanya I've
already praised artemia's play he's been
fantastic so far one of the dark courses
for the event but live on a Rooney if he
does bring his best maybe his ceiling is
a bit higher maybe at his best he uh
will be able to push Artemis into tough
Corners push him off the board so if
Artemis isn't able to combat 11 Orion in
those difficult Dynamic positions then
he might struggle but uh yeah it's gonna
be a close one that's for sure really
close live on irony and one of the most
creative players has been showing
fantastic chess in the chessable Masters
our Tamia has to keep control on the
clock they this is our other big big
classic matchup in the Chess World with
a Wesley store taking on Magnus Carlsen
Robert what's going to be the key area
in this matchup I have to say I'm
shocked by that graphic and it's not
because of all the draws it's about the
fact that Magnus 23 wins but Wesley has
19 in Rapid chess we usually Magnus have
25 and then everyone else have five so
the fact that they're that close they're
that neck and neck it's shocking to see
but it shows that Wesley can hang with
him
James 19 wins for Wesley does that
surprise you as much I mean yes it does
but I did not have to remember oh it's
flexly so oh okay he wanted to flex on
everybody just now to let you know I can
hey with Magnus 19 wins of course now
when the time gets faster obviously
Magnus is winning there but in Rapid
chess Even In classical he's like yeah I
can swing with you big fella I know
you're World Champ but guess what I'm
coming at you man it's so close they
played 74 rapid games against each other
the scores are almost balanced we
mentioned the other matches would be
close this one Anything could happen
it's only two games in this match we
might well see a close Armageddon as
well oh my God a bidding Armageddon on
this that's going to be fun let's take a
look at the format it's not a far way
off because the players play a best of
two match first and if that is a tie
then we will have the better Armageddon
they start with 15 minutes on the clock
with a three second increment it is
going to be all about nerves and keeping
them in control on those time scrambles
Wesley so one of the toughest players to
beat in Elite chess he just knows when
he gets those opportunities to strike at
them keeps everything under control
plays fast what is Robert according to
you Wesley's biggest strength that makes
him such a beast in these formats he is
ultra precise he doesn't take many risks
that's been a criticism we've had and
many have had about his style because it
may prevent him against the absolute top
as world champion but he beat Magnus
Carlson in a Fisher random World
Championship in 2019. he just beat him
he crushed him he made Magnus look like
an amateur in that match and pretty much
nobody on the planet can do that so I
think Wesley's precise style the fact
that he is stoic he plays the board at
all times I think that actually benefits
him in a match against the world
champion yeah and we just saw the world
champion open the window he's gonna need
all the fresh air that he can get in
this match we will get the update on the
air condition in his playing side with
our air tanks device but action is off
we've got we've got a sicilian on the
board yeah Sicilian and this is magnus's
world Championship repertoire from 2018
against Fabiano caruana this last move
though E5 it's really trendy at the
moment Magnus has popularized it uh it's
been played by all the top players I've
even seen Hikaru recently play this
against Wesley so himself uh Wesley now
pausing maybe he's just gonna Castle his
King this tends to end up in a very
maneuvering battle reminiscent of the
Spanish opening Black Sea points on a
different square but uh everything else
there uh very very similar so
interesting start both players choosing
I think their ultimate repertoire their
their best openings and this bishop move
still standard stuff so far absolutely
yeah the stand-up it looks weird James
it is weird in fact I mean there are
some chessable courses on this if you
want to go first Camille plishka
actually has it with his uh lifetime
repertoire of accelerated Dragon here
where he actually goes into with a nice
C6 line and then he goes with his Bishop
D6 stuff against russellimo there's also
another one by Pepe Quinta who just
dropped the uh clashnikov one who
actually covers obviously this Knight C6
move order with Bishop D6 in here so
it's very fun it's actually some type of
uh you look at it like Danny kopeck
system in a way in Reverse when you put
the bishop back on C7 You'll Play D5 you
play Knight G to E7 right and you'll
play D5 and you you just want to
actually open up the game the bishop is
very strange here don't try this at home
if you don't know what you're doing
because the bishop shouldn't be on D6
but it's for a reason B4 that ain't in
the book
notebook right there that's off the head
my guy that's a pawn sacrifice he just
gives up a pawn in the center of the
board and Magnus takes it and Wesley's
thinking against her David I've seen
this before in magnus's own games but
surprise me that you'd give up a pawn
and then start thinking yeah really
surprising either you've done your
homework or you haven't and then you
play a quieter line but what could the
idea be here Magnus after grabbing this
Pawn with his Knight he's saying to
Wesley okay if you take me back I might
even take this way I'm gonna say with
the E Pawn first opening up the black
Bishop but surely the idea at some point
will be to throw a pawn forward try to
open up lines further while the black
king is still stuck in the center there
is a pin on this file and I think white
will win the pawn back in the short term
however perhaps Wesley's thinking of
something else this move dropping the
bishop back is the top recommendation as
far as I can see from the engine maybe
targeting a loose Pawn on the F7 Square
this is really complicated stuff I've
got to say yes you're a pawn down but
Black's Bishop is a Target on the D file
blacks pieces us are asleep this one
still struggling stuck at home and of
course the black king big big Target
what do we think uh surprising to see
Wesley think as you mentioned but
looking uh looking promising I'm shocked
by that though he just gave up a pawn
and it's a very important Pawn it's one
in the center and now Wesley is thinking
well these two of course levana Ronin
blast over time they're about to get
underway but I just still can't believe
the fact that Wesley would volunteer
upon and then start thinking after it
yeah and Wesley has just moved in that
game but here we see the other uh game
the other clash in the losers bracket
yeah we see lavender moving his camera
just adjusting to get ready to make sure
that he's comfortable to start his game
against vladislava time you have it is a
best of two all right will he start with
one E4 or 1d4 we saw both of them by him
yesterday and Knight F3 number one
Knight F3 definitely going with the
Knight of three I think our Timmy has to
just play his game right Knight of three
and just play his game against uh Lebron
aronia here LeBron is very ferocious
right you know this all right while we
wait for them to get things started we
already have action on this one I have
to say Wesley's sacrificing a pawn so
early on in the opening it's not
something that we get to see every day
he usually plays a lot more solid keeps
everything under control David are you
surprised with how aggressive Wesley is
I'm slightly surprised but I'm also very
pleased it's refreshing to see Wesley
just throw things at his opponent we saw
yesterday against Hikaru it nearly paid
off Wesley was taking more risks he was
in a must-win situation and that style
of play really suited him he nearly took
down Hikaru there but I I think the plus
side for hit for Wesley is that the pawn
sacrifice is just temporary most likely
he's going to regain the pawn in the
center of the board so it always helps
taking risks when you know there's a
backup plan there's a safety net and
Magnus meanwhile snacking he snacked on
one Pawn on the board now he's snacking
on there is that a sandwich as well
should I says burritos burritos Jazz
yeah burritos burritos this man is
always eating Magnus just going crazy on
the fool here and on the board as well I
mean it's almost like he just doesn't
care right I'm eating I'm relaxed it's
kind of hard to do that when you have to
calculate in such a intense match I
don't have any appetite when I'm like
playing because I'm really focused right
about you remember yeah I don't really
like to eat when I'm playing either in
fact I you know I'm just too nervous to
focus on ending but the chest I'm just
trying to be as focused as possible but
for Magnus I mean we saw this yesterday
he doesn't mind playing The Lunchbox
Gambit he gives away a minute on the
clock here and there and he's just
trying to be as well nourished as
possible do you think that's mind games
from Magnus a little bit just eating in
front of his opponent well I don't know
if Wesley's got his eyes on the camera
or not of it he hasn't made a move is
that stuff that soft psychologically a
little disturbing for Wesley uh it could
be disturbing but it could also boost
Wesley's confidence the fact that Magnus
is tanking right now thinking clearly
Wesley with that uh porn sacrifice
earlier he surprised himself but he's
also surprised Magnus and uh I think
that's one of the differences between
online chess and over the board chess if
it's over the board I will tell my
opponent off if they're eating I will
tell them to get away move off stop
disturbing me stop dropping crumbs on
the board but
yeah this is one of the perks of online
chess you can kind of do what you want
in your own home and I thought you were
a nice guy wow so I know if we play I
I'm gonna eat at the board on purpose
now just to bother you the gloves come
off from it once I sit down at the
chessboard
no prisoners wow wow so you're only a Mr
Nice Guy off the board that's the thing
about chess players right they could be
the most humble the kindest the nicest
people off the board but absolute beast
on the board and that's what we've been
seeing from vladislav our tummy up
throughout this event while he's playing
against Levon the game is underway let's
get a quick opening update on that one
as the two players make their first
moves yeah and we mentioned one E4 one
D4 one Knight F3 of course vladislava
team didn't choose any of those he chose
one C for the English opening and this
is the result it looks like a Sicilian
Defense just with reversed colors it
looks like a sicilian Dragon white has
been cut with his bishop and other than
that everything balanced what do you
think of this uh opening James I really
like it oh there is accessible course in
fact on these um you actually have few a
few English courses you have uh the ones
from Christoph selecki who has a part
one and part two and you also have Simon
Williams who has the bobbin in English
but this is not the buffing English at
all in fact you need pawns on C4 E4 and
D3 so this is a little bit different you
actually can face this a lot from uh the
Christoph selecki covers a little bit of
this but this actually is a reverse
Sicilian so of course a lot of the ideas
are the same Knight A4 Knight to C5
right the long the longer diagonal
Bishop on G2 which is really strong now
of course it's not uh you don't have the
the dragon type aggression here but you
do have the dragon type bishop and you
have a lot of Queen side play for white
yep just uh I really like that maneuver
you mentioned bringing the White Knight
into the black cough and uh maybe going
for the bishop hat trying to force black
to trade off long term white does have a
small Advantage strategically just
because you have one extra Central Pawn
and the semi-open C file but early days
in this one Robert yeah I'd like when
you just pointed out the semi-open file
because the pawn structure is not
symmetrical white has the C file black
has the D file but the D file doesn't
amount to much of anything because a
Pawn's best friend is another pawn and
we just saw the Knight hop to E4 same
idea is hopping A4 it's trying to go
into C5 to win the bishop pair if the
Knight hops into C5 you probably have to
take it as black and then once that's
captured The Rook gets in the game white
has a pair of Bishops white has that
strong Bishop run G2 and has really good
access down the C line yep looking very
promising that meanwhile uh level and
running just gained space on the queen
side maybe hinting that he'll push this
Pawn even further forward he's
activating his Rook without moving it
really nice strategy there so a clash of
styles Clash of ideas and very
imbalanced uh meanwhile flag just love
our time we have we saw it yesterday
that was the theme of the day him
tanking he's spending loads of time on
the clock and I wouldn't be surprised if
uh okay I was gonna say if he spent a
long time there uh wondering what to do
but he immediately goes for the plan
that we highlighted he's got the Bishops
and long term white is doing very well
short term however black is very active
nicely centralized and that compensates
for the bishop
we've been talking about this Apon
Advance by 11 aronian is it dangerous
for our tamiyev if left decides to push
it one square further and actually
Target those Queen side pawns is A3
something that Robert or Tamia needs to
watch out for absolutely because what
that move does is it challenges white
setup on the queen side you're putting
Pawns in Target with one another so
there could be a pawn capture white does
not want to exchange pawns that Rook on
8 it's undeveloped for the moment but as
soon as that pawn gets out the way then
that Rook is active but the alternative
doesn't look that much prettier for
white because while the A2 Pawn will be
safe and sound for the time being
playing B3 that's a cemented weakness
and a knight will jump in Target that
pawn on A2 and it could be a big issue
yeah massive issue long term you might
have to tie down your queen or a very
strong kind of heavy piece just to
defend this loon uh this loan weakness
on A2 but okay he doesn't rush into this
level of ronin he keeps his options open
first kicking away the white Rook maybe
asking it to step back and then he might
I go for this plan that we highlighted
still very similar very thematic from
the Sicilian Defense of course both of
these players play that opening too so
they'll be using their pattern pattern
recognition using some of the ideas
borrowing them for this middle game okay
the White Queen slides across looks like
he's superficial I actually like it's a
fancy move there is that if when A3
happens we can actually take on A3 now
of course and you can't take back and
I'm just going to say okay cool yeah I
have the double Pawn here I know it's
weak but it is a pawn right now a pawn
is a pawn right as yasu says you know uh
the president of the president of the
pond Grabbers Club you know like he
likes to have that extra Pawn so I can't
take it and hold it there and the queen
is doing a great job of defending the
rook and actually stopping in a
potential A3 for the time being yeah
actually the more I look at it the more
I like it a multi-purpose move as you
mentioned that James and uh still
difficult for level and if he can't push
his a pawn forward to come up with the
plan
um okay wow talking of a plan he moves
his Rook I said the last move was
superficial for white the White Queen
looks odd there but the black looks uh
black Rook looks even odder on the F7
Square what do we think of this one I
think he's just defending along the
seventh rank so that now his Knight is
more free to move both Knights are
actually capable of jumping and I just
want to give a quick shout out to Maxine
brochure lagrav he actually threw his
third game he lost on purpose because
Vladimir kramick Mouse slipped in a
great position so Maxine decided to
return the favor and give him the third
game so it is two to one in Maxim's
favor but that is a really great gesture
of sportsmanship so shout out to the
friendship with three names for giving
chromic that game back yeah wow we don't
see that happen so often but when it
does it really is amazing Maxine washer
legraff throws the third game because
Vladimir kramnik had a big mouth slip
losing the game losing his Queen in that
one so Robert that's really nice yeah
and we've seen this from dingley Wren
and Magus Carlson so in this online play
and I think Vladimir crime is also
playing on his phone because he had some
PC issues so that's when Mouse tips are
even more likely so I gotta give a shout
out to both of those players in
particular Maxine bushila Grove it's
really great Sportsman I think it was
nehal Serene as well everybody at this
point yeah wow all right well so that
match still continues as does this one
and we see with that last move no more
ideas of Levon advancing with that a
pawn it has been stopped by vladislav
our time yeah I'm just happy that latest
love our time we have doesn't have two
minutes on the clock right now not yet
Tanya he has fixed this structure on
that Queen side we've been talking about
black pushing his apron forward he's
prevented that forever but that does
come at the cost of holes and if you
look on that left side of the board the
Queen side there all of the light
squares belong to Black I'm really
liking how levon's just retreated his
Knight Black's light Square Bishop
actually exerts influence on both sides
of the board and white lacks Pawn breaks
uh Roberts mentioned it in previous days
Pawn breaks are the essence of nearly
every middle game position if you have
access to pawn breaks if you can change
the nature of the position open things
up for example for white Bishops here
then you will have an advantage but
white is a bit stuck if you can't push
pawns forward then you're purely
maneuvering with pieces and that can be
uh fought against here I don't see what
how you can maneuver those white pieces
effectively it just feels good stuck it
feels pretty gross actually I mean the
queen on C1 like it feels okay with the
queen on C1 maybe we just need to Triple
everything on on the C file at Queen C2
and Bishop E3 so you want the bishop E3
route maybe he wants to reroute with
Knight D2 and we already have a move
from Lavon there playing Knight F5 I'm
hitting the bishop there yeah this is
already looking kind of great for black
not gonna lie here yeah this does not
look very pleasant for artemio I think
something has gone wrong Lavon is
playing quickly and confidently and I
want to make mention of artemi of time
usage I think he knows that Lavon will
punish him unlike Fabiano who struggled
in some of the scrambles that they had
when they did not have much time Lavon
he plays very quickly throughout the
entire game and so I think he has a
totally different match strategy against
Levon it's only a two-game match before
you get a potential Armageddon with
bidding and I love the way that Lavon is
handling game one he's just getting
active he gave up the bishop pair but
that night hop into F5 saying I might
just get the bishop pair right back yeah
100 that last move by left retreating
the night was only retreated to go
forward anyway so very surprising
decision by our time you have moving the
bishop one step ahead head provoking
asking love to do exactly what he wanted
and now that night can actually go
further on to the center of the board on
that D4 square at the right moment as
well and we see our tamiyev going into
the think tank things have gone wrong
for white in the opening that's quite
clear James in this one absolutely it's
definitely wrong here so you may have to
make uh you know make it Dynamic of
course that just actually in terms of
speaking of chessboard just bought this
year off book today so I'm deaf and I
went through like the first three
chapters so I'm already feeling sure off
like I'm just feeling aggressive and
dynamic like we do every day but
definitely more today with uh something
like Knight to D2 yeah okay whatever you
get the bishop here but after I take
back on E3 now you can't put anything on
D4 my knight can actually swing into E4
and my light Square Bishop is super
strong look at the bishop now I'm
hitting C6 and I can go into E4 maybe I
go Queen C2 or C3 and then and then put
the Rook on the uh on the uh the C file
as well so you know I got some plans
here but definitely something
um for our team here to think about yeah
an interesting move he's just so is Rook
across I like those ideas James I
preferred that one but okay simple
threat attacking a pawn he's trying to
loosen up that long diagonal that we
pointed out if for example black played
a careless move like pushing his Pawn
forward there will be tricks along this
diagonal suddenly this Black Knight on
C6 is loose so it's just uh he's just
asking a question he's just saying okay
how are you going to deal with that one
mate and uh it's not clear left on a
running of course solid position we like
Black's chances but a big threat to deal
with and uh we'll let him make that
decision meanwhile the game between
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson looks like
it's heating up some strange stuff going
on in that one very creative play by
Wesley so he's actually sacrificed a
second Pawn white is two pawns down for
the moment and okay three minutes at the
moment and Wagner got a Pawn on C3 the
king is still in the center but this
looks like very materialistic play by
Magnus Carlsen and it could be very
dangerous for him right now it could be
but he's still munching away on his food
munching away on those pawns and he's
munching away on the clock as well yes
Wesley's the one munching away on the
clock really behind here five minutes
and it's only one move 14 here Wesley
needs to compensate for those two pawns
and black is only one move away from
castling if Magnus gets one more move
gets that black king to safety he's
gonna happily enjoy his material
advantage yeah this is a big problem for
Wesley so because sometimes when you
Gambit a couple pawns you get a quick
attack you get some checks against the
king that King is about to Castle and
White's Rook Pawn is also under attack
black has two pieces staring right at
that pawn so you know if you think oh
I'll just bring my knight backwards for
white take this Pawn on C3 You're Gonna
Lose That Rook Pawn as well and black
will be two pawns to the good this is
not looking good for Wesley so and you
know I keep shouting them out but I want
to give one more shout out to Vladimir
kramnik now because on the first move of
his game he pushes Pawn one square and
when uh maximum responded he then pushed
his Pawn the second Square so he
essentially gave the color back to
Maxine Russell
players are just the tip top in terms of
being General in the game wow some
amazing stuff going on in division two
and in this position as well you've been
mentioning about giving a check on D6 we
see that the black Bishop is the one
that is defending that square James can
Wesley be thinking about trying to trade
those Bishops by bringing it forward to
that E3 square and maybe if you take it
just put an intermediate check on D6
that's exactly what I was thinking about
in fact Bishop E3 I'm not sure why he
didn't play it as fast as I was thinking
it Bishop E3 is just like the automatic
move if Queen E7 we have Knight C7 there
right so Bishop E3 is really strong it
actually hits the bishop or of course
the engine's like nope not a move but of
course he's down material too as well
probably materialistic but Bishop E3 is
a really strong move here I think I mean
there's lots of even tricks even if you
play D6 Pawn D6 it loses to Bishop C5 or
maybe not loses but after takes I can
play Knight to D6 maybe oh I can't play
it yet pinky seven afterwards wow lots
of tactics yeah Queen takes check King
E7 gross about holding on for black just
about holding on correct but Bishop B3
is very strong here what Magnus is a
calculator he is the World Champ he's
gonna be able to see this so Bishop B3
you got to get your pieces out right
what is Wesley doing
it make a move it went so fast the game
has just started yeah the game has just
started I really like that bishop move
you suggested there and what else I
think that's the question sometimes when
you're getting low on time which I
always do myself you have to just stop
and ask yourself okay I'm gonna be
suffering anyway on the clock so I need
to create some Chaos on the board and
the only way to do that here is to play
Bishop B3 is to do something create a
threat set a trap otherwise you're just
six minutes down on the clock and you're
gonna be a clear Pawn down or two for
nothing so uh Wesley I think he's in his
own head too much just uh kind of
regretting his earlier decisions but he
needs to be in the moment and just uh
try to make the best of this bad
situation
that's yeah struggling here I think we
all sense it right when he gave away a
pawn and then started thinking after
magnus's reply so I think he knew the
idea but not the specifics behind it and
that's a big problem when you're playing
at this highest level and I I want to
give a shout out to Wesley because he
decided to play ambitious chess today uh
but it's not going well and if Magnus
can convert this Advantage win the game
he'll have the white pieces and it's
only a two-game match that's scary so
for for Wesley he's doing what he did
yesterday we all were crediting him for
uh surviving that game against Hikaru he
blundered but he didn't lose that game
he needs to do that here as well well
the good thing is that the last few
moves he's played it quite fast and now
David is he looking at a jump with the
Knight too that really really juicy
Square on D5 yep you called it Tanya
that white knight is looking nice and
pretty in the center of the board that's
what we call an outpost it's cemented
there anchored by a white Pawn as well
we could see a scenario later where
Black's Bishop blacks light Square
Bishop that's still trapped at home uh
comes out and captures that Knight but
then we'll go down to an opposite color
Bishop position where drawing chances
the drawing margin will be very high so
white has one good piece that's a start
uh he needs to back it up however and uh
of course white will be the one on the
defensive because he's simply a pawn
down one strong piece is not enough to
compensate here because Black's dot
Square Bishop is just as strong as that
white knight this looks like a position
we'd get from the special Club opening
for example except there it would be
level material white is just a pawn down
now but active pieces Wesley's done a
good job over the last few moves I
notice how quickly Magnus is playing
James do you think he's playing now on
Wesley's clock he absolutely is he's
like yeah quick moves I mean I can just
make easy moves right improving the
position okay the work is a little bit
better on A7 and it's A8 the reason
being is I can now double put more
pressure on the a pawn if I need to
maybe even play B5 or B6 at some point
right in the Rook can actually be active
on the seventh rank there so of course
Wesley is in time trouble here and he's
down a pawn and he's playing Magnus this
is just lots of things you gotta get
that out of your head like okay I gotta
just play the board here right but of
course Magnus moving very quickly and
confidently here and having a pawn he's
trying to convert yeah and right here
you see the Bishops the black Bishop
staring at the Knight you don't want to
take that if you are Magnus Carlson
because you take this Knight on D5 we
get a position with opposite color
Bishops you see the eval bar reacting
now we're equal because oftentimes with
Bishops of opposite colors even though a
side is down upon the position remains
balanced because you control one color
complex I control the other and that
means that we can't fend off on the
competing Square so I do not think that
Magnus just because he developed that
Bishop he's planning to take he wants to
eventually as James was saying bring
more pieces to the a file attack that
loose Pawn on A5 yeah nice multi-purpose
move that by Magnus Carlson on the last
go and Robert called it the black queen
came out white defended by stepping a
pawn forward holding on to this Central
Pawn and the Black Brook immediately
activated Wesley now uh on under
pressure in trouble actually on the
board and the clock because two of his
pieces will be tied down defending this
Pawn meanwhile black is going to start
earthquake asking questions uh to this
white king look how trapped it is
actually on this light Square on the
dark squares black is going to try and
come forward and break through later you
could definitely imagine this queen at
the right moment trying to dive in
either trading Queens off or going for a
checkmating attack white is a bit stuck
that's the problem it's hard to imagine
maximizing the white pieces even further
whereas blacks pieces uh could certainly
be improved I wouldn't be surprised as
well if the black porn later starts
stepping forward the black queen moves
out the way and it uses itself as a
battering ram to open up this weak white
king so uh yeah Advantage black he's
moved his Queen out the way first going
for that white Pawn in the corner and uh
later we'll see
like H Paul nesting I think start
advancing this feels like a crush in
fact the reason why I say that is even
Wesley said I think in the interview
maybe yesterday or day before but he was
saying um he was like yeah you know I
had like two minutes and like versus 11
and like they I can't win that against
anybody and this is a situation where
he's down a lot of times I mean like
nine minutes almost for Magnus he's
under a minute here Wesley and there's a
lot of pressure on his position the
pieces don't look the greatest A5 is
actually uh attacked many times my
pieces look good I got a great night on
D5 but then what do I do all the pieces
are on the queen side of the board just
holding the pawn here right so we're
hoping for something here and I don't
have enough time says Wesley yeah this
is just very shocking and Magnus is
making it look really easy now we see
three pieces attacking the A5 Pawn only
two pieces for white are defending that
A5 Bond the queen and the Rook Magnus is
thinking about capturing that Bond but
then Wesley will manage to get some Play
Because Westies Rook can jump to the
seventh rank also capture ring magnus's
Pawn on B7 and that's perhaps why he's
taking so much time in the position if
that's not what you go well he does it
he does it yeah the big problem for
white is even if you just say I get my
Pawn back your king is very unsafe back
there in the corner if your Rook ever
leaves the first rank it's not
immediately a back rank Checkmate but
with the dark squares being occupied by
Black's pieces notably that Bishop on C5
we are going to see some issues down on
the first rank yep first he's traded off
a set of Rooks this bishop is pretty
much pinned uh if it ever moves the
Black Rack uh Black Rack
will uh be vulnerable the black Rook
will dot it down and uh this will end in
a checkmating attack so I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus starts using his
Queen again he's kind of yo-yoed back
and forth with that black queen but
imagine her jumping in I could imagine
this queen move coming now massive
thread on the board if white does
nothing if white for example sidesteps
the queen then Rook takes Bishop will be
a threat the queen now distracted and
this will end in Checkmate very typical
meeting a pattern here with the black
queen and this white king so that's the
first move that comes to my mind maybe
there are others I'm sure Magnus will
find just as strong a move as this one
but uh yeah Wesley it's hard to imagine
him defending this one one minute left
and this is such a defenseless King such
a helpless King right now for white yeah
it feels like Magnus is playing all over
the board the king side and the queen
side He's Got The Rook coming into the
attack from the a file the two Bishops
which are targeting White's King and
with the black pieces to get this kind
of a position right out of the opening
where Wesley's down a minute it could
not have gone worse for him yeah just uh
already as Robert mentioned from move
four or five it was a quick downhill
spiral for Wesley so when you get caught
in the opening especially with white it
seems in this tournament uh you do tend
to get punished black scoring extremely
highly in the chessable Masters so far
um all of these top players just so well
prepared it might be a lesson in playing
to your style and James I mean Magnus we
know that he likes to swing Wesley he
usually likes to play Common so you
think he made the wrong choice of course
the game looks bad for him but just
psychologically yeah psychologically I
think he should have just went solid I
mean he actually has an E4 course where
he actually against he plays the solid
stuff in his course but didn't play it
here against Magnus right so that's what
he recommends yeah this queen H4 move is
now on the board I mean I was even
thinking even if you play King H2 here
in this position you might be able to
still play Rook A2 and queen E1 this is
such a very very bad position Bishop H3
might be on top there's King H2 we still
might be able to get away with Rook A2
here but uh is there anything else
stronger I could imagine the black dark
Square Bishop coming in as well just
controlling some squares inching towards
that white king Wesley shaking his head
yeah it's very much about the Styles
here Wesley just feels like he's just
not in the flow today and in this kind
of Sprint towards the Finishing Line
two-game match that is a bad sign Magnus
just ruthless in this game you've got to
say really merciless and will he find
the killer blow he doesn't need to he
takes a timeout himself whites King got
safe the black king got safe and now the
threats will persist you know these are
the most dangerous kind of moves in this
position where you just pass the ball to
your opponent and are already very
difficult position to defend and Wesley
down on Seconds come back comes back
brings The Rook back to the defense is
there an immediate blow because we see
the eval Bar says that this is game over
for white do you guys see an immediate
finish here the thing is you don't need
an immediate finish you're a pawn up
you've got more active pieces your
opponent's got a weaker King the
evaluation bar might reflect that just
the fact that the advantage long term
it's not going away anytime soon you can
cash in whenever you want I'm not sure I
don't see anything immediate do uh do
you James Robert but nothing yet I mean
I like a rook A3 just to put a piece
there and then maybe
um I'm hinting at Bishop H3 things but I
need more wow
[Applause]
sometimes I forget I'm a Jedi
yeah what a nasty looking move James's
points are sometimes there's sacrifices
in this position and The Rook along the
third rank could be problematic as it
slices across the board and Wesley stops
those kind of threats no more sacrifices
available to Black for the time being
but that's not a pretty move to play
look at that Bishop on A2 it's a very
defensive piece and it's looking into
its own Rook yeah you can just run away
Rook a two Queenie one like I just gotta
do it I got the sheer off book fire on
the board it's all chessable okay I just
have to do it I don't have to bro like
how does he defend this now of course
engine defends it oh Rook B1 maybe yeah
just Rook B1 okay just yeah
in this case I'm just like Zach you know
when I fire on the board book definitely
is gonna have you sacking Everything
Chad definitely get its own chest yeah
calculation over everything that's the
first thing he'll be looking for Magnus
Carlson uh he'll be looking at moves
such as Rook takes Bishop he'll figure
out it doesn't quite work the black
checkmating attack isn't quite ready and
then he'll look for options he'll go
back to square one and okay you can
trade Rooks of course but if you want to
keep them on you could just step to any
other square and White's formation is
still looking very very clumsy there we
go he Retreats the whole way back and
Wesley wants to guard his first rank
he's really terrified of that idea you
mentioned James uh he just wants to stop
the black queen from jumping in but how
can Magnus up the pressure is it time to
bring the dark Squad Bishop into the
attack as well bring it to have to bring
it to that G3 Square so many weaknesses
around the white king is it time to
strike with the bishop I love that idea
I really think it's good because that
black queen is kind of a lone attacker
and it can't get it done by itself so
bringing the dark Square Bishop to help
putting in line with the queen on the
same diagonal that will allow black to
deliver some vicious checks and likely
Checkmate in the near future so I
actually don't see very easy moves for
Wesley he might even lose on time just
because of how difficult this is to
defend Yep this looks like a killer
threat I don't really see how to guard
against this for example if white just
moves you can uh for example give that
check and take this Pawn this will end
in Checkmate just to put that on the
board to the white king defenseless
nothing around and okay it's on the
board he has swung its Rook across the
train maybe you've been finding all
these Amazing checkmating Ideas I have
to say have you been doing your puzzle
rush in the morning I actually have but
uh you've been setting me up Tanya
you're giving me the assist and I'm just
putting the ball in the back in the net
and uh here I think this check looks
like the most simple when the king moves
I mean I'm assuming it goes back then
there must be something here it feels
like there's something in the air but uh
what is the killer blow we still need to
find it Wesley defending tenaciously
here but 30 seconds left it must be to
do with some sacrifices on this square
but do you rush it maybe you don't need
to maybe you improve this black Rook
first Wesley's living life on the brink
whoa what a move by uh that's beautiful
stuff yeah that's really nice because if
the Knight captures that Bishop which is
legal Black's not going to recapture the
bishop on A2 is loose so that's why
Wesley slides his Queen over and a queen
trade does not mean the attack is
physical look at this white can hardly
move the bishop is stuck in place the
king will not be able to leave the back
Rank and then black can push those pawns
black is up upon I was saying earlier
opposite colored Bishops often gives
good drunk chances not here an attack
persists yeah that white Bishop okay has
just moved with a check but I was going
to say it's the worst Bishop you'll ever
see it was staring at its own pawns here
Wesley's begging for The Rook exchange
maybe that's still strong for black but
you never ever accept you go for the
Checkmate you go for that white king
even with the absence of Queen sir that
white king is a clear Target and uh one
threatened right now on that back rank
on the first Rank and Wesley has to
block with his Rook he has to just cross
his fingers and hope that he can keep
that black Rook out of the game but
slowly and surely Magnus will infiltrate
he will invade is it time to start
moving those King side pawns F5 E4
create a passer he first starts with the
h-bomb and Wesley getting his King out
of the king of the Kill Zone yeah out of
the Kill Zone for now but uh look at the
black king it's coming into the Kill
Zone it's gonna try and uh trap the
enemy King and black is playing with all
three pieces black is playing with an
extra Pawn of course White's Bishop
sidelined
any saving chances no no nothing yeah
James like let's uh hang our heads for a
moment here but no there's just no
chance Magnus Carlson when he knows the
game is over he is not afraid to
liquidate because he has his vision he
sees that this end game that we have
right here it's not just oh one extra
Pawn should have chances no he's all the
activity in the world white can hardly
move staving off all these threats seems
impossible the black king is entering
along the dark squares and white can't
attack anything the one hope that Wesley
has now is to bring his Bishop all the
way around Loop it to the other side of
the board but Black's pawns are all
defended so this just is unpleasant yeah
amazing play by Madness but I have to
say Wesley really impressive how one he
didn't get checkmated in that position
the game is still on he's been defending
a really difficult position for the last
I don't know how many moves playing on
seconds
yeah but uh unfortunately he hasn't
managed to fight back or turn things
around or cause any complications yes
he's held on he survived but that's all
he's doing and uh it's not fun he's uh
going through hell right now uh trying
to hold on to this game look at that
black pawn in the center it's a past
Pawn I love how Magnus has used his own
King that black king an active attacker
as well and uh once that black porn
continues advancing that white Rook is
going to be stuck forever you're
sexually playing without a piece yeah
well this does look winning for Magnus
and I see our evaluation bar on the
other game says that it is also winning
for Lavon aronian let's take a look at
that one as things are heating up there
Magnus has everything under control is
our time we have in big trouble
feels that way of course
of course but the computer says yes
of winning here but what is The Knockout
blue unlike the other game it's actually
level material so if there are a bunch
of exchanges if the Queens disappear
then I'll tell you can breathe a sigh of
relief he might just be fine so the
stakes are high in this one of course
the stakes are always high on the clock
the hard time we have but uh can't live
on put the boot in can he strike while
that iron is hot nice move hey look in
the White Queen it looks similar I mean
black right now actually isn't up any
material but we are about to see a past
E Pawn so Magnus has one that wants to
go forward Here lavon's pawn can also
push the white king is less safe than
the black king and many of Black's
attackers going in Queen of four he
doesn't have much time played and I
think LeBron can give a check either on
D4 or C5 but that e-pawn is going to
push yeah let's just find out he made
that move with one second on the clock
it's a three second increment
unbelievable our time we have with no
time on the clock manages to do this
that's what they call brinksmanship he's
uh he's always doing it I'll tell you
just how he has control over that extra
one second is incredible but as Robert
says plenty of strong moves here for
black I think the most tempting too are
win checks there we go the queen hits
the white king the white king is going
to be forced into the corner you're
gonna have to relax there my guy Rook F2
that's crazy I mean he already in time
travel and he is in some trouble yeah
this is this is the Rick F2 you had to
go King H1 right yeah it looks like uh
that Rook has walked into a self pin and
I don't think he's lost on time uh
vladislava tell me if that clock will
correct itself there we go and The Rook
is lost
material gain for black here and this
should be decisive
yeah this is this is one-sided right now
because right now a black has a rook for
a knight and a pawn he's just going
right after the Central Pawn if you
protect it with your king the move F6 to
F5 is played just imagine that pawn
going forward it's going to pin so
instead he brings Knight up but now
you're losing a pawn you don't even have
a pawn for the exchange this is quite
straightforward for a player of Levon uh
aronen's caliber yep if there are more
pieces on the board this material
balance you might have some chances you
might have some compensation but a low
night can never fight against a long
range piece like The Rook uh The Rook
especially with pawns on both sides of
the board will be able to play a
multi-purpose role the White Knight is
stuck it's a short range piece can't
wow and as we expected Magnus Carlsen
has won his first game against Wesley so
with the black pieces Wesley in game two
the final game has to win on demand to
level the score that's going to be a
tough task playing black with Magnus
especially psychologically as well with
not just the result but the way Magnus
won the first game it's going to be a
tough one for Wesley and it looks like
it's going to be the same story in this
match it looks likely at this point our
temmiev knows he's going down he's
crashing down to defeat in this game and
he's gonna have to strike with the black
pieces I don't know what's in the air
what's in the water during this
tournament accessible Masters every time
people are winning with black uh if why
is White's opening Advantage it's just
disappeared those chessable courses have
ruined chess for the white players for
those white pieces in fact he does right
Chesterville does make it where even
lower rated players can keep up in
theory but you do have to do the work
and it is intense and you need to do
more than just opening work obviously
work on tactics and in game two as well
which you can find all of this on
chessables what's your favorite
on the middle game that'd be mastering
middle games by panchenko it's uh
actually a very strong book in fact it's
just a book of 2600 level he was like
yeah we had he put 2600s in the room and
they gave him these problems and you had
to solve them in fact it's a very very
good book on mastering middle games yeah
James ask you I saw that you were
studying chessable you had over a 1 000
day streak about three and a half years
every single day every single day in
fact I mean when I was chilling we was
eating I was doing chastible while
before we were on my phone all the time
I do Festival uh 24 hours a day if I
could
and it seems like this end game I don't
think LeBron needs chessball to convert
this he is up a rook for just a night
and black has a pass Pawn on the king
side so if we cut the board in half we
see white with the best don't take them
on knife Forks Knights are very tricky
if you take that pawn you actually
blunder your rook and that's why Lavon
pins it he's still not going to take it
because the night check yeah but you can
just go after the H Pawn the other end
of the board get your king to safety
attacking the a pawn and then you've
always got the option to slide your Rook
to the king side happy camper pick up H2
Queen the pawn it's Pawn quality not
Quan he just pushed them keep pushing
his balls sacrifice one it's captured
sacrifice the other it's captured then
the H3 Pawn very Advanced is going to
become a queen yup and uh with that
knowledge Artemis does resign this game
is over and everyone takes the lead
wow so we've got two wins in game one of
the elimination bracket both with black
pieces that means that the players with
the black pieces have to now play for a
win in the next one impressive play
James there by both aronian and Magnus
what impressed you the most well
absolutely of course what impressed me
the most was Magnus how it was just
domination I mean that's the Magnus that
you see when he just dominates when
Magnus is informed you better watch out
it's scary as nobody touching him he was
eating a burrito chilling yeah yeah you
can bring it yeah okay all right just
making moves not even really paying
attention here it just felt like it was
very nonchalant it was very easy for him
to take down somebody as strong as
Wesley so yeah let's take a look at our
score line the first game is over this
is a best of two which means that Wesley
slow and vladislav or Tamia have to win
on demand to go into a betting
Armageddon it's not gonna be easy
against Magnus and love on our onion who
were on fire in game one we are going to
be back with the action but for now
we're going to take a shot twitch break
[Music]
foreign
I
love how rich and complex she is how
sharp and principled her first steps
how graceful her movement
Paris is a city of love
[Music]
I've come to find my love
for the French defense
[Music]
hello this is Christoph zileki and
welcome
keep it simple 1d4 course
[Music]
it's a special time in the Chess World a
big month for the Chess World as the
world championship starts in just four
days between janapamnushi and dengleren
at the end of the month we will have a
new world champion Magnus Carlsen played
his last classical chess game as world
champion take a look at what he had to
say after that match
[Music]
I guess that concludes it for your
classical career as world champion is
that correct yeah I think so how does
that feel no that's okay most
importantly right now I think draw is a
decent result for our team and it looks
pretty good on the other boards yeah
obviously it's an honor to be part of
History like that but I really wanted to
put more pressure on I wanted to win I
wanted to send him out you know not on a
high so uh yeah kind of mixed feelings
but I can't complain too much
do you feel you've finished off in style
last world champion in classical chess
yeah it's okay
um I scored this weekend was
um was good play wasn't great but I
might become Norwegian Champion for the
first time for for teams so that would
be nice
Magnus Carlson not world champion Magnus
Carlsen is that sort of a different feel
I still have two titles I'm secretly
hoping he's going to come back in like
20 years and show the young things the
lesson and take the title back but uh
but yeah it's very special and um yeah I
just I just hope he enjoyed it as much
as I did
I love that when he says I've still got
two titles and still World rapid and
World Blitz Champion but it does feel
like the end of an era David you and
Magnus are such good friends how was
that did you analyze after that game we
did it was friendly afterwards but
beforehand you know he ghosted me he
didn't talk to me he was uh I think he
was trying to scare me and I was super
nervous I barely slept the night before
I played quite boring chess I've got to
say with white I managed to hold the
drop but uh yeah it was tense and it was
an honor of course to play his last
classical game
to be part of it yeah special moment
there yes it was wow and we do hear the
clock ticking it is special moments here
as well in the adjustable Masters as two
players will be knocked out and we are
about to start a game two off the losers
bracket the elimination bracket Magnus
Carlsen and Levon aronian have won their
first game or tamiab Wesley so have to
win on demand to force an Armageddon are
we expecting a comeback here Robert
I know I'm supposed to say yes but my
answer is no because Magnus and Lavon
get the white pieces they know how to
get the job done they're not going to
play risky chess I just don't see it
happening James when you're in that
situation you're playing against a
player like Magnus against the player
like love with the black pieces where
are your chances well in something an
aggressive opening I mean whatever they
play is going to just take it to them
hey what is the most aggressive that I
can do maybe try to take him out of the
book here but Wesley looks dejected yeah
actually and then he's just sitting back
leaning back maybe listen to some look
at the face there the smirk like all
right let's just make this happen let's
get this over with and we go to Sicilian
yeah this is idiom we saw Wesley have
some success with this against Nakamura
yesterday he didn't quite win the game
but he got a good position and uh Magnus
do we think he's going to play Bishop B5
check just like Nakamura did bringing
out that white light Square Bishop uh
looks like he's pausing Magnus choosing
that strategy to avoid anything too
risky uh at this early stages wow that's
so annoying oh my goodness that is so
annoying I'm telling you there's a lot
of adjustable courses on this right now
too Bishop B5 check is so annoying
because then you have to play Knight D7
and then like you don't get anything
you're like look he's already here today
come on man I saw it yesterday right but
Wesley actually almost beat hikara in
this exact variation so Wesley he should
have some happy memories he almost lost
later in the game but the opening was a
resounding success but I think Magnus he
looked at the game he devours every
single chess game that's played pretty
much he knows what to do he strikes in
Center he's playing a different
variation than the card did yesterday
yeah and uh Magnus he used Bishop B5
track this exact variation all those
years ago in uh in his match against
Anand just when he needed a draw with
the white pieces he was able to lock it
down and it was a very similar variation
to this one so white has just
established that clamp we call it the
mural XI bind with those two white pawns
on e4 and D4 uh E4 and C4 sorry the
White Queen of course sandwiched in
between and it's going to be very hard
for black to break out black is lacking
behind the development and in order to
equalize this game if not nothing more
of course in order to just equalize you
need to be very accurate so uh Wesley
taking a pause here yeah guys while
Wesley is taking a pause we need to
pause for a photograph right now because
there is a big Instagram contest on to
send us your selfies show us how you are
watching the Champions chess store you
gotta send it on Instagram using the
hashtag chess Champs and you could win a
50 router for uh adjustable course so do
it now I'm sending mine you tricked me
you know I don't like content for the
sake of content you know I don't like
posing for Social Media stuff and you
just put your phone there I know to
listen to you so I was like okay okay
I'm doing it you got me you got me if I
told you beforehand you'd never have
agreed zero chance
yeah I know you well well does Lavon
aronia know our tummy are well enough to
decide what opening approach her to take
with the white pieces against a very
aggressive our time you have who has to
win on demand and we see a sicilian
another song
he knows what to do C3 Sicilian for the
Killian that's exactly what I like right
here of course I'm a big fan of this and
of course you can play this very
aggressively but you also can play very
solidly it's a a a very special place in
my heart with the C3 Sicilian guys lots
of chessable courses on this one my
second one on child support will
actually be on the C3 Sicilians just to
let you all know dropping it already
it's already coming out C3 Cecile David
you like this too don't you I do I've
played this opening since I was six
years old and it's still my main answer
to the Sicilian these days I mix things
up a bit but uh yeah I've seen these
chessable courses come out coming up
with these uh new ideas that I hadn't
discovered uh with the eight of engines
of course just refreshing ideas and uh
okay of course it's got a solid
reputation as well which helps when you
only need a draw I've even used this I
think in 2009 to draw against Magnus
myself I just wanted to lock things down
and that's the case for 11 aronian in
his game here a draw is enough so why
not play a solid opening with some
attacking chances James that's how you
play it oh I play with more of a
aggressive intentions here I do play
Knight F3 here most times
um I also Play Bishop C4 mini lines
there's also I mean uh the book right
now on Chesterville with uh what is it
Surya sorry again ghouli I think his
last name is but very very strong he has
a lifetime repertoire for semi-terrash
and the nimso Indiana excellent courses
there but here I mean he actually he has
so many new ideas in the C3 system that
I've never seen so his and great
addition to your C3 Sicilian players out
there to grab that chorus in fact yeah
and Gladys love I'll tell me if he will
not like this he doesn't like it when
his opponents are trying to go for him
trying to be very direct and okay he's
looking off to his left our right on the
screen and that is the face that players
make when they're trying to recall
something trying to remember something
or trying to pull something from the
Deep recesses of their memory and okay
after a while he has brought his Knight
out still Mainline stuff James
absolutely still Mainline Bishop C4
right and we just back up to B3 here and
he can take the second Pawn now if you
take the second Pawn on C3 we actually
go Knight to G5 here very strong play so
D takes C3 then we go Knight to G5
forcing an E6 and then after E6 you can
actually Castle or play moves like Queen
to E2 just very very aggressive now you
don't actually need to play this way
from LeBron because I mean he's already
you know winning he just needs a draw
here so he doesn't have to play this way
but it's very very doable here you can
also take with the Knight on C3 too as
well yeah really aggressive stuff
already threatening Checkmate on this
Square that's the type of way you can
play the C3 Sicilian if you are an
aggressive player like James like Levon
Iranian and uh already vladislava tammyv
he's hesitating the best move the main
move is to push this ball neither one or
two squares but it does lead to very
forcing lines very direct play and when
you need to win at all costs you want to
take your opponent outside their comfort
zone early that's why this is such a
good opening choice I think from Lavon
he's narrowed opponent's path taking
away so many options taking away all the
tension from the opening the last of no
longer playing chess he's playing I need
to win so the objective best move may
not be best for his Overall winning
chances he needs to take risks he did
just push his Pawn the center Levon
immediately takes on Passat no that was
not an illegal move for those who knew
to chess learn on poisson it's your way
you take it as if it moved one square
and so Lavon he doesn't mind trading
pieces he does not mind that liquidation
he only needs a half point and well the
position is quite balanced it's a normal
development white is about to Castle
kingside and I really like the choice
from LeBron Ronin yes Ma hard opening
approach there by love needing only a
draw he decides not to play the open
Sicilian but the very solid alapan
trades we see happen in the center you
have been talking about how white is
looking to trade more pieces off are you
expecting him to recapture the D4 Pawn
with a piece ah and he might isolate his
Pawn I mean play in that old school
style it doesn't matter if your Pawn
structure doesn't look great as long as
you vacate Square for your night because
that see through Pawn is in the night's
path but I just feel like LaVon he's
right at home and his time manager
suggests as much he is more time than he
started with he's playing the moves
instantly I think he should take with
the pawn on D4 then develop his a knight
he could try to trade Queens instead
nobody's trading off everything in the
center but look at artemia he does not
want Simplicity yep he doesn't want
those obvious exchanges he's happy to
bypass that white Pawn he takes it back
with his bishop and now we see what we
call an iqp isolated Queen's Pawn but it
does give white a lot of control you
control these quests pretty much forever
that pawn is only going to be weak in
the same answer if there are a bunch of
exchanges later also the Black Knights
are not ready yet to occupy the square
in front of this Pawn in front of this
Pawn the Black Knights want to blockade
of course but they will struggle to do
so so I've actually had this position
plenty of times myself from the white
side and I really believe in White's
attacking chances often James you'll see
this idea sliding back with the bishop
hitting this weak one and uh checkmating
plans attacking plans all over the shop
100 you have Greek gifts sacrifices here
if you are familiar Bishop to C2 and
then sacking on H7 send them to heaven
after King tc7 Knight to G5 check and
lots of nasty things can happen now of
course you gotta be careful because the
king actually walks out to G6 believe it
or not and if you're not able to
Checkmate the king I mean and then
you're you you sacked for nothing
there's it's it's a lot of play you got
to be very sharp here but it is the fact
that we are aiming at that side of the
board in fact you actually see these
positions a lot in the the uh Carol Khan
the uh pan off pan off variations of the
Carroll Khan you'll see a lot of this
where like we play against the iqp and
white has we play Bishop to C2 Knight to
E4 Rook E1 you can even Rook lift Rook
E4 to H4 very aggressive type of Chess
here and uh ronians definitely going to
find these moves well he is looking at
all these ideas but first he brings the
Knight to the center now we've been
talking about Levon having the isolated
Queen spawn for artemia there are two
strategies right you either block the
isolated Queen's Pawn or you attack it
David that Knight on E7 is it hinting to
go to the F5 Square trying to put
pressure on D4 as well as blocking the
diagonal that you have been mentioning
with the attack for white yeah you're
quite right Tanya that's uh two viable
options or two viable strategies in this
type of position one is the first one
you mentioned actually to try and attack
this Pawn the one downside here is that
you might be allowing either here or on
the next few moves this point a step
forward if you do uh step forward with
this Pawn successfully for white you
just simply trade off all the pieces and
look how symmetrical the pawn structure
is here if you want a draw which level
of ronin would be happy with then you
can go for this option so again it's
Levon bullying or teme if he's saying
yes you can go for this but I will
happily step forward trade everything
off force a draw all the pieces will
come off the board that vacuum Hoover
and uh yeah we'll see equality the other
technique is to blockade but here for
example if you blockade again level
neuronian might be feeling cynical you
can attack you can bring out the White
Queen for example but if you just want a
level position you trade off all the
pieces in the center and you say okay
are you really gonna beat me from this
position symmetrical pawns again I think
the answer is no so ladislava tell me if
the two plans he wants to go for he
can't because of the match situation and
the answer is no it's using both vacuum
and Hoover
okay we're gonna settle this by day five
but I also just want to say that our
team if he wants chaos we're not getting
in this game but we are getting it in
division two in that match between
chromic and Maxine versus in game four
mvl needed to draw to move on he hadn't
even positioned and he disconnected and
lost so we are just here absolute
pandemonium in division two that's going
to Armageddon with bidding I don't know
if Vladimir if his um he's playing on
his phone I don't know if that will hold
up I don't know if Maxine gets
connection back but whatever is
happening in division two has to happen
for Wesley so and vladisal retainment
they need chaos because otherwise they
are going to be sent home wow so much
drama in division two and there is
dramatic action on this board because
once again our Tamia is down on the
clock by almost seven minutes what is
going on here he needs to make a move he
needs to make it fast but he's
struggling to find a way to create
chances in this position James do you
see a way for black to be able to just
create a mess somehow yeah creating a
mess here especially against the C3
Sicilian is very hard it's probably one
of the it's the most annoying thing in
fact even there's a tweet you can
actually find it on Twitter you can
Google it Magnus Carlson C3 Sicilian
Twitter Google it it'll come up there's
a tweet that he has that he says I hate
playing against the elephant and that's
exactly I'm like wow world champion
himself says it so of course it has to
be some Merit to it it's a really
annoying opening to face and I mean
especially when you're trying to play
aggressive you need to play for a win
it's very difficult yeah that's awesome
stock chest Champs show us how you are
watching and following the action on the
Champions chest door it has to be in
landscape mode so don't forget that and
we will feature it on our show
now do you want to know a secret that
game I played against Magnus if he'd
played the Sicilian against me I was
going to play the alapin just because I
knew he hated it
and uh actually that's the main
attraction I think that's a good uh kind
of template for all openings choose
lines that your opponents will hate it
might not need to be the best move might
not be the most uh kind of computer
approved move but if your opponents hate
facing those types of positions then it
will work very effectively and um yeah
some nice photos
coming in
from all over the world watching this is
uh really nice to see places to the
names yeah you've done going loving it
look what you've done look what you've
started
I appreciate I actually do like seeing
people from all over the world watching
chess getting excited by hello everybody
I just you know I personally don't do it
myself but I do appreciate all of you
but I don't think that last number 10
appreciates his current position because
he's just making small moves here and
there and you see the evaluation bar
going up in White's hair there actually
might be sacrifices in the air that
artemium has to watch out for his King
is actually not that safe despite the
fact that pawns are in front of it we
usually like to Castle behind our moat
but that moat can be destroyed with a
couple sacrifices yeah there's
sacrifices to watch out for Robert I'm
not sure whether they work right now but
they're in the air right Knight takes F7
would be really typical really thematic
just wrecking the black porn structure
uh as we mentioned maybe not here but
the computer says yeah it's kind of fine
uh and uh here there would be ideas for
example taking this Pawn with your
Bishop with your queen and this black
king is feeling the heat of course the
game goes on it gets really complicated
he's going to be looking at that but not
maybe right now he will want to build up
first he'll he's only going for that
sacrifice if the circumstances allow
David does his work Knight takes G6 H
takes and then rookie six boom
well getting off the board after Pawn
takes hitting splitting Queen takes and
then when he goes to the corner
hitting with Queen H3 that's for me oh
my goodness but you better be doing your
tactics that's all I'm saying you better
be doing your time gosh yeah this ends
in Checkmate black can throw a queen in
the way but it doesn't change the fact
that uh the king is trapped I think that
there was a hidden idea there a hidden
defensive resource after Rook takes Pawn
black could actually flick his Bishop
back pin and not quite win it's not like
pin and survive oh you play Rook D6 okay
I was like how's the engine not I was
just not just crushing but instead Lev
just keeps it everything under control
because that is the Mad situation he
needs just a draw as does Magnus Carl
soon let's head over to the game Magnus
Carlsen taking on a Wesley saw and wow
this looks interesting but is black the
only one who's in trouble I feel like
Black's down like five Tempe like black
pieces are not moved off the back rank
White's Castle developed all the pieces
Rooks are connected the Queen's in the
center so it feels like black is several
turns behind but if we do some quick
math blocks upon ahead so if you're
Wesley you actually appreciate this type
of position you want chaos you want to
have imbalances and here he has just
that the problem for him is he has not
developed his King is stuck in the
center and for just one Pawn it's well
worth it for white to go for this
initiative so I actually don't see how
black Contigo you want to keep taking
pawns you're opening up files that's the
nature of losing pawns your Rooks get
open lines the D file is open the C file
could be open next and if we swap pawns
on B3 that could be very dangerous yeah
and this is a great lesson for everyone
at home I think just when you are happy
with a draw you shouldn't play Passive
chess you should go for the win anyway
you will get chances later on to trade
off pieces to head into equal positions
head into end games if you really need
to but don't let it affect influence
your decisions early in the game too
much and Magnus here he only needs a
draw but he's playing his best chess
he's playing his open uh World
Championship repertoire and uh he's
going for the kill I'm terrified here if
I'm Wesley so uh six minutes as well on
the clock how is he gonna get those
pieces out you need at least three moves
to Castle White's gonna have something
to say about it in the meantime David
you're saying that Magnus is using his
world championship repertoire I mean
that is scary enough already you don't
want to face that when you need to win
with the black pieces big task ahead of
Wesley but first the big question is how
does he complete his development in this
position
yeah that's you know what's funny there
the thing here is uh the fact that you
know Robert mentioned oh yeah he's up
you know if you do a quick check he's up
a pawn you're like really weird like no
nobody feels that extra Pawn because all
his pieces are on the back rank I mean
you take on B3 I might even have a rook
C1 as an in-between move first and let
you have I don't care you can take
whatever you like you're gonna get mated
in the center of the board here I mean
look at the eval bar go crazy here right
you know I mean what do you even do 97
runs in the Knight D6 Knight F6 damages
the structure Knight H6 oh come on why
is your night on eight six right this is
terrible I mean do you move the bishop
can you move the bishop is the question
Bishop E7 and then hopefully try to get
Knight F6 in Casper yeah it's just
horrible whoops I've jumped to the other
game Sorry that one also interesting but
yeah you're right just look at these
pieces that's all you need to look at in
this position one glance and black is in
trouble maybe the best is to actually
trade off in the center bring the Black
Knight out okay at least you've gained
one move to hit the White Queen but the
problem is after Queen takes porn it's
back to level material White's still
ahead in development Queens might come
off it's an end game you'll not beat
Magnus Carlson in an equal or slightly
worse end game uh here so yeah it's uh
tough times for Wesley so it's a dilemma
and he knows the best move is probably
not going to help him win this one so
again needs to take more risks but where
are they
yeah this is a nightmare and we've been
talking about the trade on e4 also black
has got no option to even develop the
bishop you put that Bishop in front of
the king and suddenly that pawn on F7
might be following there are tactics
everywhere David and it just looks like
this is going to be a nightmare also on
the clock four and a half minutes will
he survive this oh it's all retirement
earlier the objective best move is not
best for the match it's best for the
game and if your best decision is black
is to take the Knight with your bishop
and then develop as David was indicating
that might involve a queen trade and not
only you're not going to beat Magnus in
that position you're going to be
slightly worse and you have no winning
chances you need winning Chancellor you
might have to lose the game in order to
win it that's the nature of being down
and imagine for Wesley he's not castled
he really has very few choices
he landed up in so much trouble out of
the opening that's the same narrative in
this one while Wesley does go for the
decision that David was mentioning with
trying to ease off the pressure but
going into this end game you're not
going to find your winning chances here
James not at all I actually saw a slight
head shake from Wesley before he went
for this line he just you know like he
just kind of composing himself was like
you know hey it is what it is I play
good I'm gonna get some money out of
here but I'm facing elimination I'm
playing Magnus Carlson here I need to
play for a win from this position which
is extremely hard to do and I mean it's
just not going to happen
I'm unlikely to happen and look at what
Magnus is doing he's just removing any
sources of potential counter play he's
traded off his Bishop for that black
knight because maybe the Black Knight
long term would have sat on a nice
pretty Square in the center now if you
compare uh the pieces compare what's
left on the board that white knight is
beautiful it's just a superb piece right
now it is clearly Superior to that black
Bishop where it's Pawn structure also
much better black has a couple of
isolated pawns a set of doubled pawns
blacks Rooks not reaching open lines
this is one-way traffic and I think it's
very minimum here equality for white
well it looks like Magnus Carlson is on
cruise mode in this one let's jump over
to the other game with action still on
in Lavon versus
managed to create some chances in this
position he's done quite well the
problem for him right now is the clock
but the position is good and the reason
I say that we have material imbalances
white has two Bishops black has two
nights but look at that Knight on D5
it's a stallion you can't kick it out of
there it's protected by another Knight
it's protected by pawns it's blocking
that open file for the white Rook
whereas on the other line black has this
open B file The Rook is happily saying
they're keeping the bishop at Bay I
really like the way artemia is playing
this he is trying to pick off those
Advanced White pawns and I feel like it
could be dangerous territory for
levonaronian yeah we often talk about
the bishop pair and here White's Bishops
look like they have great potential but
surprisingly counter-intuitively a pair
of knights actually sometimes fight
quite well against the bishop pair as
long as they protect each other as long
as they're both on stable squares and
here that's very much the case as uh
Robert mentioned I like that term
stallion that Knight of D5 uh real stud
there and uh meanwhile grabbing pawns I
don't see a way white can actually
satisfactorily defend that C5 Pawn the
black queen is simply going to go across
two squares take it off the board You're
Gonna Go material up yes those Bishops
will compensate somewhat but I don't
know if it's enough suddenly Levon
aronian maybe he's been playing a bit
too quickly he's still got more than 10
minutes on the clock but he had more
promising Alternatives earlier on he's
imbalanced it which is the first sin
when you're trying to play uh safe chess
trying to play for a draw and somehow he
has to back it up he has to switch mode
now level on Iranian no more positional
chess he has to play the position played
dynamically and get those Bishops
working
not easy yeah of course with the bishop
here I definitely favor the Bishops I'm
a big fan I mean even they say sometimes
being down a pawn sometimes even two
pawns you have the bishop pair it
depends on the position obviously but
definitely the bishop pair can
compensate for at least a pawn sometimes
so okay we take on C5 when if he gets
this Pawn on C5 we probably have to play
something like Bishop D3 just to deal
with this bishop right now and we want
to keep it on the diagonal what I want
to do is you gotta try to get G4 G5 in
dislodge that Knight make some
weaknesses around his King and then
maybe try to you know put the queen on
e4 if possible but Queen A3 I saw that
but I thought that was pretty gross that
was like disgusting what is he doing to
his pawns James oh my goodness that was
the only move that defended everything
but it's disgusting it's a disgusting
move I was just never gonna play this
bishop I'll just say I'll give you the
pawn but here I mean look at this
there's chances now seriously for
artemia definitely I mean clearly the
best piece in the game is this Knight
it's rock solid it's a statue there in
the center of the board and you're still
going to win a pawn most likely what is
level of Iranian thinking about feels
like he's playing too much for the draw
here and a bit of a Grimace on his face
level neronian on the camera as far as I
can tell look at those pawns horrible
chests you know what he might have been
relying on here is if you play A4 as
white you're trying to defend the C5
Pawn tactically but after Knight takes
C5 Bishop A3 you see if the Knight moves
you lose the Rook behind it the problem
is that black interposed with Knight to
B4 and now it's hitting the bishop on C2
this is a mess and the eval Bar says
that white is hanging right in there
it's a level game but I think for Lavon
he was counting on this tactic to win
him back some material he may just be a
pawn down and equality is not so easy
when you don't have the evaluation bar
at your disposal yeah that position that
you showed at the end there I think from
a human point he looks fantastic for
black so he's unlikely to go for that
and maybe he's only realizing now that
he can't save this Pawn also the black
Rook can start running uh forward this
Pawn is doomed and he needs desperately
now 11 Iranian something to compensate
for his terrible structure
he needs tricks he needs tactics but uh
where are they I don't see it I've got
to say right now for white it's very
rare that when you have two Bishops that
you're like yo this position is terrible
like that's how like it feels like I
mean I have two Bishops and they would
love to have two Bishops in an open
position like this one but this position
feels disgusting I got the double pawns
C5 is hanging yeah okay I have the two
Bishops but I can't even really move
them anywhere the light Square Bishop's
doing well but what is the dark Square
Bishop doing where is it gonna go to be
effective here it actually leaves nice
and a night of stallion as uh Robert has
said is a great piece on D5 there and
the other night is going to take the
pawn on C5 and then we're just up a pawn
all right and the and the double pawns
here it's pretty ugly here for aronia
also remember where do vladislav I'll
tell me have strength Sly mostly in the
end game he's so good at out maneuvering
his opponents we've seen it plenty of
times he took down Magnus Carlson
yesterday against Fabiano often Fabi was
getting into the end game with an
advantage with a clock Advantage as well
and I'll tell him if would outplay him
in that phase of the game and uh okay
white princess ship out a bit of a
mysterious move maybe based on some
tricks but yeah desperate times for
levonaroni and you can tell on the
camera body language not positive
anymore for white C3 Sicilian gone wrong
yeah the c360 can get killed sometimes
but it also is c360 for the kill we play
it and then you know if it's good it's
good if it's not it's definitely not
yeah meanwhile Black's gone up a pawn
and uh level and running at least he's
mobilized his last remaining piece he's
activated his Rooks some tricks in the
air white is threatening right now that
light Square Bishop jumping out the way
maybe going to take a pawn with Trek and
uh opening up a attack against this
loose Black Knight on C5 pushes a pawn
back nice symmetry there with white
Bishops and Rooks nice little bubble of
pieces but uh there we go defending
everything vladislava Pawn up with an
advantage and it looks like a very
healthy Pawn yes Lavon aronian does have
the bishop bear for compensation but
those two knights Activity The Rook on
the open file more activity and it looks
like Artemis has done thinkable by
creating chances in the end game out of
an elephant but I have to ask you guys
is this closer to a draw or an artemia
win I would say practically speaking
it's probably closer to an artemi of
wind the issue is his clock but we've
seen time and time again the way he is
able to fend off those minimal seconds
he's like playing on milliseconds
sometimes gets the increment going he
was able to work it back to 10 seconds
or so so I think that our time is very
likely to win this game especially
reading levon's reactions he is
displeased about what's Trends right
he's trying to play the safest opening
in the book and now all is going wrong
yeah they often say the worst way to
play for a draw is to play for a draw
you gotta stick to your style if you
have the chance to make a position
aggressive you've got to go for it but
it just looks like Levon aronian tried
to play it just a little 2kg a little
too safe given the math situation but
our time yeah once again that clock he's
down to two minutes is that going to
count or the fact that we're in an in
and game it's not going to be a big
factor that's the one potential banana
skin that's the one thing he could trip
up on later I'll tell me but it is uh it
is him after all that's his superpower
balancing surviving with one second two
seconds left on the clock so if anyone
can uh kind of not let it affect their
play the clock then it is him but uh
we'll have to wait and see if uh if he
blows this Advantage now if he does
crash to defeat crash out the tournament
then he will regret his uh time
consumption and that's so frustrating
it's so frustrating for for the opponent
when you see that our time you have in
this case is going down on the clock
playing on seconds but he's still
playing so strong and you're not able to
beat him on the clock James yeah you
know and you know what's funny here I
mean uh or to me is so so strong when he
gets lower in fact it's almost like you
want to have more you want our team to
have more time like you're like hey
albita winning at 10 minutes 12 minutes
13 15 but when he got two in one minute
and then we got 20 seconds that's where
you should fear him right this is the
time where you fear Him the most because
because he's precise I mean it's just
like grishek in a way how like it's just
he's so precise and it's like you're oh
it you almost like play on their clock
and you start moving fast trying to flag
them and then you get crushed or you
lose the game and you blunder something
and he's just you know calm cool and
collected with three seconds on the
clock yeah do you want to know one of my
deepest darker secrets I once fell
asleep during a classical game against
vladislav artemia
it was a 9 A.M start all the other games
previously in the tournament had been
starting at like 2 3 P.M uh so I wasn't
in the right Rhythm I played three
tournaments back to back it was the
final round of the final tournament it
was actually for England against Russia
and then uh it was a Berlin as well
which didn't help yeah and then halfway
through the game it was just a balanced
position something happened and then I
kind of opened my eyes I looked at the
clock I was like whoa I've lost 30
minutes what's happened there and then
my teammate was just looking at me like
shaking his head what are you doing man
what was the result of the game I
managed to draw but uh I think James is
right there on your point just get lower
on the clock than Vlad us laugh he
doesn't know what to do like half an
hour down and he's looking at me like
he started thinking and eventually it
was a mad time scramble and stuff and
he's probably just too nice to disturb
you during your little nap yeah the
worst thing is like afterwards we were
analyzing an office he's like are you
okay were you unwell I saw you closed
your eyes for a long time
bro I was tired and it was a Berlin
I'm tired Berlin was sleep you know what
I mean yeah but uh yeah meanwhile it is
the end game one minute for vladislav
he's handled it so well though I love
his last move I've got to say he's
saying okay we can trade Brooks on the
b-file but it's on my terms if the white
root captures the Black Brook black can
actually reconnect his pawns on the
queen side but uh yeah I don't think
Levon aronian is finding a plan right
now he's the one burning time on the
clock he's not comfortable at all trades
do not help him because black is up a
pawn and I just want to quickly note
that Magus Carlson has moved on in the
losers bracket he took down Wesley so
they drew their second game no surprises
there but I think what is surprising for
levana Ronin is what has happened in
this one I mean you see the position he
is down upon his structure is also worse
he's these doubled isolated pawns on the
left side of the board here this is not
pleasant stuff and he doesn't have a
plan that's the biggest issue is you
typically want to double your Rooks but
where and he makes a rook slide just one
square over doesn't threaten anything at
all so black can start bringing the king
in use the King as a weapon in the end
game bring it towards the center yep we
see seen Magnus Carlson do that use the
king as an uh as a weapon and I think
that's great advice here Robert for
vladislava tell me especially when
you're under one minute you just want to
play kind of useful uh waiting moves
okay wow he slides across with his Rook
pretty much forcing a set of Trades here
Levon he can't really Dodge this tension
any longer and uh okay a set of Trades
set of Rooks off the board maybe closer
to utilizing that extra Pawn Advantage
later in the game vladislav of course up
that pawn for later he's paused is he
actually gonna take this point wow
there's tricks what a move if Rook takes
there it's Bishop A5 I think and Bishop
I didn't go Rook B2 there and then Rook
C6 there's something I thought it was
just Bishop A5 that's why he took with
the pawn he had taken with the Rook
maybe that would have been an annoying
hit on the black rook and this Pawn
would have dropped next but uh in the
game he took with the pawn instead Rook
takes Rook he took the pawn because Rook
takes Pawn would have been met by a
nasty night Fork look how beautiful
these Knights are hitting this rook and
hitting the bishop you can't defend both
you would win material yeah so uh the
game continues we saw Levon throw his a
pawn up the board he pushed this pawn
and vladislava team has captured two
points up temporarily but what is
happening here oh my goodness ran into
it yeah
he wants to trade rookie to save his
light Square Bishop but lose the dark
Square Bishop this is over it's over
look at this a Nightfall hitting the
king hitting the bishop and
takes the win I cannot believe it he is
in shock he just missed that last move
tactic it is Fork it is game over that
is it which means we get an Armageddon
unbelievable he still had five minutes
on his clock left on a ronin when he
made that blunder when he gets lower on
time he gets stronger it's a freaking
superpower right as he gets lower on
time and then he plays stronger it's
insane or Timmy up does it every time
yeah I think that's been the most
impressive thing about the chassisable
Masters so far has been artemiev and his
love story with the clock so much action
so many things to learn from it is time
for our lisoweta learning point
and today's learning point is about not
playing too timidly even if you only
need a draw Levon Orion had a great
start to this game he actually attained
a big Advantage with the white pieces
but maybe due to the match situation the
match being ahead by one point he was
happy to trade off pieces in the end he
made negative decisions especially
trading off the queens and ruining his
own Pawn structure this was the result
black was actually temporarily two pawns
ahead and because he was still stuck in
that georish mindset Levon aronian made
a careless blunder with five minutes on
his clock he simply captured this Pawn
assuming that more trades were in
imminent here black jumped in he had
actually spotted this double attack he
thought he could trade off the Rooks but
he stopped here he didn't look that one
move further after The Rook trade this
night Fork ended the game Levon aronian
not his finest hour and will he recover
now in the Armageddon
shocking moment there a one move blunder
and it was Game Over which leaves us
with this caller in action is still on
in the losers quarter final as we move
on to an Armageddon that Islam our
tamiyev punches back in game two
creating his chances and impressive play
there by him finishing in a blunder by
11 aronian the other one Magnus Carlsen
did make it look very smooth let's bring
him on we've got Mathis joining us
Magnus congratulations
yeah thank you
thank you Magnus I have to ask you
Wesley so he's such a solid player one
of the hardest players in the world to
beat you made it look easy today how did
you do it
well I thought it was plain white in the
first game so I was a little bit
surprised to be playing Black
um
I mean considering that
you know the position I got from the
opening was uh pretty pleasant surprise
I think he just missed some some mixed
something up and then he was sort of
trying to look for compensation but
yeah uh I mean I didn't play Perfect
after but it was really hard to mess
that position up uh and then yeah in the
second second game I think
uh already after
I would say yeah on 94 I moved 12 it was
was it was over so yeah it was was
um clearly my best day so far yeah
it's nice to hear Magnus and you keep
your Victory hopes alive too
bracket how important is this
chassisable Masters for you being your
last event as the classical world
champion
yeah I don't really care about it being
the last event of whatever era but uh
any of these uh these events are are a
bit big to me uh I try to
try to win the mall and I feel like I'm
gaining some Rhythm now so it won't be
easy to
knock me out a second time or at least
not as easy as it was the first
well Magnus as you said you're you're
feeling more in the Rhythm uh tomorrow
you'll face the winner of aronian versus
artemiev would you rather play artemium
and get that Revenge
is that like
I mean I've played a lot against Ari
Tami of Vietnam a bunch beat me a couple
of times as well so like winning one
game would not be revenge over the over
the other
um
that's yeah I wouldn't mind playing
playing either
um but
um
yeah I don't really have I don't really
have a preference
Magnus say good day at the office how
will you celebrate now will you go back
to those slopes for some more skiing or
will you be watching uh the clash
between Fabiano and Hikaru
so the
the slopes are are closed I think uh
but I'll have some dinner and uh enjoy
um watching the other others work
I made so many mistakes like I thought I
thought there would be another match
uh today as well uh
not uh you know I'm clearly not used to
being in the lucious bracket so I need
to need to improve that
Magnus we got to get you a food sponsor
okay everybody was like oh we have
people coming in and they were like oh
man what is Magnus eating now I'm hungry
of course it looked good we got to know
what was on the menu today
yeah it was more or less the same as
yesterday uh except
uh that um
that there were some carrots today as
well which I very much enjoyed
[Music]
um
I don't know if you can see this
okay
okay this is what it says
well I can catch that what does that say
Magnus
yeah it says uh does magnus's free
dinner
[Laughter]
magnet is earlier on in the show we were
showing the video to our chat with you
and David playing uh the classical game
that you did just a couple of weeks ago
and David mentioned that you actually
ghosted him before that match one is
that true and two was that a big moment
for you
no it was the the other other way around
because
um
um at the good nights I mean we weren't
drinking or just hanging out playing a
little Blitz and talking and I I'd like
I told David let's uh do you want to
hang out and uh basically the deal would
be that um we'd go home at the same time
so that we'd get the same amount of
sleep for the the day after and then I
as I remember it was David who didn't
didn't reply so I think he was the one
who was playing mind games to be honest
I was too busy studying the Spanish what
can I say
he's a sneaky guy
thank you so much Magnus for joining us
and all the best for your match tomorrow
thank you
Magnus Carlson there making it look easy
against one of the hardest players to
beat in the Chess World Wesley so goes
down in two games but action is still on
as we will have an Armageddon coming up
between Lavon aronian and our time we
have bids on the other side of this
twitch break
[Music]
open up to you
with nothing more to say
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess Mastery Magnus
Carlson introduces chessable the
definitive solution for studying chess
move trainer uses the science of space
repetition to identify your strengths
and eliminate your weaknesses there's no
need to set up a board remember which
page you're on or keep track of all the
moves you miss get started now join our
growing community of over 100 000 chess
enthusiasts chessable take control of
your journey towards chess Mastery my
name is Sam shackland I was the US
champion in 2018.
goal is to keep things as simple as
possible but no simpler so if I believe
there is an easy solution to Something
I'm giving it no questions asked thanks
so much and I wish you the best for all
your studying
if you want to learn an opening we all
know chessable is the place to go but
what if you want to find out what
openings to learn Jessica is now here
for that too find the openings best
suited for your playstyle using their
new quiz that's fun whether you want to
be a booked up positional grinder or an
unorthodox tactical wizard chessable has
the answers for you go to chessable.com
quiz or use the command quiz in chat to
take the quiz today
wow it is really important to actually
know your playing style before you pick
the openings that you want to go for oh
it absolutely is I think in this day and
age when so many people are learning
after the Queen's Gambit during the
pandemic they were taught a specific
opening from their favorite streamer but
that may not suit your individual style
so I do think that people need to know
what kind of play they like best yeah so
definitely go check out that quiz and
for now check out the Armageddon
regulations a big match coming up either
Vlad Islam or time yeah or lebanaroni
and one of them will be out one of them
will go on in the chessable Masters the
player who bids for the lower time gets
wins the bid and gets the opportunity to
choose the color they usually choose
black because black gets resolved odds
which means if it's a draw black wins
the match white has to win on demand the
player who loses the bid starts with 15
minutes the bidding games are on what
are we expecting and we got the results
oh my God 11 aronians seven and a half
minutes that is is a very low bid to
fight for the black pieces how do we
feel about that James you know what you
need to have lower time than artemia
right to mix it up because he always has
lower time right so when he has lower
time he's in his element but hey
LeBron's like you know what cool we're
gonna play a Blitz game I'm gonna have
lower time and the black pieces right
and got to uh you know when I win I draw
I win so I think it's very smart from
LeBron yeah wow every time you have will
start with the white pieces he will have
15 minutes on the clock 11 are onions
seven and a half minutes
will play with black or Tommy have has
to win the match a draw means Levon goes
through or Tamiya will be knocked out
Robert what's your take on the bid that
we just saw it sounds crazy at first
because he's been half the time of his
opponent or telling about 15 minutes
LeBron or we'll have seven and a half
but I think that considering the match
Dynamic Levon has played the quicker
chess he's not too worried if he can
keep that speed in the opening and David
opening is on and we've seen our time we
have do this before yeah he has done
this before yesterday against Fabiano
caruana and this time it's a different
spin whoa look at this left on Iranian
only needs to draw but he's sacrificed a
pawn he's allowing the White Queen to go
and get greedy to grab that B7 pawn and
why not okay aronian his bluff was not
called or was it a bluff maybe this is
just great opening preparation again the
gift is offered and I'll tell me says No
even in a moss which must win situation
he's preferring to dodge his opponent's
preparation not getting greedy with his
Queen are you surprised here James
Robert I would have grabbed that pawn
I've got to say yeah especially with the
bishop on C1 I mean the bishop C1 it
defends B2 usually when it was back
there you take on B7 and you allow him
to play Rook B8 so you can take the pawn
on B2 but that that wasn't the case so
in fact and he could just see he
probably just played Knight D7 I moved
the queen back you get a little bit
initiative but I'm of a pawn though yeah
now it just looks very very solid for
black gotta say I like the Romantic
style that Lavon was playing with he's
like take my Pawn I will have that
compensation I'll get activity but this
is a different Dynamic I actually think
it's quite smart from artemium because
with the lead on the clock that he has
he wants to keep the game going he does
not want Lavon of any easy solutions and
we see what's the plan for black he's
got his piece in the center everything
looks good but what next that's the big
question yeah what next and uh just to
show what would happen if white
continued uh well actually I'll say
continue but if white did decide to grab
the pawn here and now if he does take
this Pawn with his Queen the black Rook
would simply activate and there's a big
problem on the B2 Square the White Queen
can move actually she might even get
trapped if you're not careful on this
Square Rook takes pawn and uh simply
this Rook too active you cannot consider
it anymore the opportunity is gone but
just the fact that vladise dodged that
capture dodged that pawn uh with his
Queen does mean to me at least that he's
at least speeding up he's uh very aware
of the clock otherwise he would have
spent five minutes calculating that
right he would have uh at least invested
a bit of time instead he's brought his
Rook across and he's playing position he
maybe Amy to open things up with C4
later
I just got the feeling that that bid
that we saw by lava narunion at seven
and a half minutes that has a lot to do
with his opponent our time you have
somewhere Levon feels that artemia will
burn the clock the time will be level so
why not just get the result on is that
the strategy and will that pay off I
prefer it to his strategy yesterday
against uh Fabiano where he was really
tanking and Clocks Were level before you
know it and of course he didn't end up
winning that game but uh yeah he needs
to avoid thinking now vladislava tell me
a fast start great start still got
almost double the time but uh he needs
to keep that edge on the clock we all
know what can happen if it does uh get
balanced later it'll just be a random
scramble so right now he needs to make a
decision what to do next I think his big
decision is whether or not to push his C
Pawn that would allow some trades
they'll open up the position that sounds
good when you need to win the game but
also makes some of lavon's decisions
easier because this is a position with
plans and maneuvering and right now both
sides it's not clear what they they want
but playing that pawn push to C4 that
would make it a bit clearer and that
actually would be good for Lavon yeah
and there we go uh Robert you called it
after a trade of knights first he has
opened things up so easier decisions for
Levon here maybe he'll slide his Rook
across try and trade everything off on
the open file but White's piece is also
more active than they previously were so
uh James you're a very attacking player
this is more of a grindy style but do
you approve I'm halfway asleep here he's
looking at this position now of course
it is very positional here very solid
and this is exactly what Lavon wants
here Lavon just wants to trade things
off hey look you know what if I draw I
win the game that's it right but of
course I mean artemia being a grinder
actually loving in games and very slow
and positional type chess here um but
he's not in his element yet because he
got too much time so he has so much time
right now that you know it's not going
to work he's going to probably take
somewhere in there it's going to get
crazy and artemiev is definitely going
to get a Little Bit Stronger when that
time gets lower here but I mean so far
just very level very level not too much
to say to both sides we're still trying
to figure out plans and improving our
position slowly like the queen is a
little bit better on D7 than it was on
E7 it defends C8 why he's trying to do
his thing as well maybe try to move the
bishop to a better Square maybe you can
play a move like H3 or G3 just to make a
little bit of look for the king very
position maybe A4 stop a potential B5 so
lots of choices for both sides yeah one
of the points you mentioned that James
just pushing a poor near your king to
give your king some breathing space some
Luft some air I think both sides want to
do that quite urgently wow okay
interesting move sliding the White Queen
back trying to conquer the open file but
you say wow Tanya because it's in the
eye line of that black Bishop it's not
the uncomfortable it does feel like the
fight is very important for the only
open file in the position the C file I
think that will be a deciding factor who
can control it if our time we have gets
control which it does look like he's
managed to do that there is a slight
Edge in the position there is a pull in
this position until Lavon is able to
trade Rooks on the C5 I don't think this
position is as simple as it looks guys
not simple at all because right now as
you pointed out that white has control
of the only open file of the board that
means that white controls the action has
all the activity has all the fun and so
if even you play them with Queen to C7
if you bring your queen up offering a
queen trade we typically think Queen
trade that means it's more towards
equality but if black takes that Queen
here comes a rook on the seventh rank
that is very dangerous for black to deal
with it's not that easy to kick that
Rook out of there and it can't be
flushed out that means that black has to
sit and passively defend that's not fun
especially with little time on the clock
yeah I'm finding this very dangerous for
Lavon with five minutes on the clock and
there are no tactics that you're dealing
with yes there isn't an attack that
you're dealing with but very often in
chess especially at this high level
these strategic questions are equally
difficult to answer James I am I think
our time we have should be very happy
with what he's created with the white
pieces and still twice the amount of
time on the clock Robert your move on
the board
beautiful queen C7 I'm very annoyed by
this move I had to play something like
Rooks a d8 I don't even likes is he
trades it wow he just allows it to
happen and he defends upon and says hey
it's whatever maybe bishop C6 98 King f8
is there wow trying to trap the the best
The Rook on C7 you actually have to be
very careful you called it James right
now there's actually a threaten on on
the board it's this hidden one it is
just to retreat this bishop for example
if the white knight steps back I've
already careless move suddenly black
would be winning look at the evaluation
bar the black Bishop drops back and this
Rook caught Behind Enemy Lines no way to
save it simply this Knight is gonna
Retreat next move hitting the Rook only
one safe square and the king is gonna
catch it suddenly black would win
material so huge threat on the board if
Artemis can't deal with this he's going
to be forced to retreat with his head
hanging in shame but what if he doesn't
retrieve it goes forward with the Knight
hopping to G5 instead that hits the
bishop in the center and that pawn on F7
uh The Rook may still get trapped I'm
not sure but that looks like a double
attack it is a double attack Robert
you're right actually how is black gonna
deal with this you can't afford this
bishop to drop off for example you can't
just bring your Rook across and defend
this Pawn because once the bishop
departs from the board The Black Queen
side pawns will start falling like flies
so here black is pretty much committed
to dropping his Bishop back I guess yeah
the best defense is offense Bishop if
Knight F7 98 anyway and have a nice day
right and then King 2 f8 once you get
your Rook to E7 and that Rook is a trap
that's a nice trick James after board
absolutely you know we like those tricks
here but a nice move from artemia Bishop
B5 is stopping all of that he's like you
know what yeah I know what you want to
do not today not today but what is the
reply to this Pawn stepping forward is
he just gonna step back with his Bishop
continue controlling the square that the
black Bishop wants to use this is really
sophisticated stuff really tense stuff
first level on aronian pushes his other
Pawn stopping that night jump we
highlighted this is uh really really
sophisticated classy end game player by
played by both sides I've got to say and
Levon flexing stretching he looks uh
he's comfortable at all here because
black can hardly move you're shuffling
about and it may be objectively an equal
position but look at the clock artemium
still has a four minute lead it started
with seven and a half it has been cut
into and Levon is playing really fast
chess right now but he doesn't have
ideas he's still just trying to defend
against White's threats and so I think
that our team if he decides to speed up
here it's going to be difficult for
Lavon because just start pushing your
pawns for our team maybe your eight Pawn
then your F Pawn start just trying to
strike in the center I don't like this
position for black yeah then again I'll
tell me if they just kind of wipe his
brow he knows that he needs to speed up
you use that phrase Robert but he
doesn't speed up and that could be
costly in an Armageddon like this one
first he has to decide is that white A2
Pawn actually attacked Black's Bishop in
the center attacking that pawn if you
have to take her time out to move it
defend it suddenly Levon will get a very
important Tempo to try and trade off or
try and kick that white Rook out of his
Camp I mean while I'm getting distracted
these are really nice photos
will be playing later on right now it is
all eyes on this one but the winners
final will be following up well I have
to say I still like our time you have
chances here there is a potential strike
in the center with the pawns you can
start advancing the f-bond the E Pawn a
Target that Bishop on D5 right now our
time you have moves back with the bishop
his Rook on C7 looks very active still
up by almost three minutes on the clock
things looking good for our time here
but he has to make sure he keeps that
clock Advantage going yeah it's all
about that white Rook if the Rooks get
traded or if that white Rook is forced
to retreat it's going to be equal it's
most likely going to be a draw uh if we
forget about the clock but uh okay nice
move from our time we have big thread on
the board that white central port now E4
better late than never uh that black
Bishop is almost trapped actually in the
center of the board first a
counter-attack hitting that white Bishop
forcing it away but now there's no way
to trap in cage that white Rook I think
this was an excellent player starting
with King f8 the whole idea here of
course is thinking in plans right he
wanted to go King f8 why because I want
to play B5 kick the bishop away play 98
get the Rook off the seventh rank play
King E7 King D7 and move the Rook to C8
and wait we gotta draw wins the game in
the match for me but the problem with
pushing those Queen side pawns is you
leave squares behind So eventually that
Knight on D2 it's sitting there it's
actually not an active piece you want to
bring it into enemy camp that A5 Square
it looks far away but it's only two
jumps from its current spot so I do feel
like a white should just try to keep the
momentum you know you could play in the
center with Pawn to E4 to kick that
Bishop out of there then bring your
knight forward and I like what our 10
members did nope Bishop trades let's
keep it on the board because E4 is going
to be a shot with Tempo and if Black's
playing 98 now yes you're kicking my
Rook out but I still control the C file
and I can just continue jumping forward
yeah continue jumping forward this is a
really annoying move to have to face
next move next turn and still small
Advantage for white but Levon will be
breathing a sigh of relief I don't like
this I've got to say pushing this Pawn
forward it feels like you're playing on
the wrong flank you should play on the
side you're stronger actually get that
King active as James says but uh Levon
tends to be well it's clearly he's
feeling the nerves now down to four
minutes he's really in a rush yeah and I
like this trade offer by our time we
have the reason for that is that this
would mean the C6 Square would be weak
for The Rook the white Rook to come in
and start attacking those weak Pawns in
chess whenever you make a pawn move you
do create some weaknesses and right now
our time we are trying to get rid of the
strongest piece in Black's position that
Bishop on D5
yeah I have a bad feeling I think Levon
might have been a bit too
bit to not as easy position it's not
going to be the type of position you
just Hoover the Rooks off Hoover the
knights off it's going to go on for a
long long time in four minutes
it's a Race Against Time and he's not
known as being too fast he's not known
as a bullet specialist levonaronian I'll
tell him very good very high bullet
rating as you mentioned Robert
on chess.com I'm going to make a
prediction that the times the clock is
going to level out in the next couple of
moves I don't see our time we have
keeping an advantage on the clock for
too long but yes he will push the
position well I agree that the time may
become equal the position I think will
not and the reason why is LaVon in order
to keep equal time he'll have to play a
series of quick moves the position is
more difficult than initially meets the
eye we have the same material for both
sides only one Pawn is off the board for
both but there's squares Left Behind
even that pawn push to F5 that may make
the E6 Square week later in the game and
I feel like White's Rook controls a lot
of the action here it's the only open
file but or tell me if he needs to play
more quickly that's his biggest problem
right now now just make a decision maybe
centralize the white king bring the
white Rook up to the top of the board
with a check do something trade off the
Bishops but do you have to move it's one
nearly one and a half minutes on this
one turn that's too much in Armageddon
no increment remember
wow I was thinking a couple of moves it
might just be this one it is a minute
and a half ahead yes our time you have
does have a very pleasant end game but
it's still far from a sizable Advantage
he needs to make a move James he needs
to do it now what are the ideas that
come to your mind definitely
centralizing the king king E2 King D3
and playing the pawn to E4 I mean you
just want to use this I also have the
open file right now um I have the only
open file under my control so I
definitely like King E2 and King D3
there he spent nearly two minutes on
this one move there's nothing forcing
going on in the position and look at
Levon he's gaining in confidence now
he needs to make a move the game will be
decided later at the moment it's still
maneuvering just maneuver a piece okay
he decides to trade off and enter with
his Rook but uh same move faster would
have been better of course and uh okay
he was completing this line here it is
and he gave himself an isolated Pawn I
think that was a big decision and maybe
he's just trying to take James advice he
wants a little bit less time and then he
can play his best chance I'm telling you
every time and when he gets under he
like oh I got too much time how much
time he got let me wait let's calculate
right oh I'm under the clock or as soon
as I can get lower on time that's when
I'm gonna play a lot faster Knight F6
it's an adrenaline junkie but this last
move might be a killer for his fun
unless he finds something now the idea
is that if the white knight in the
center goes to take the black Pawn on D6
the black king is going to shuffle
across and that's it maybe you got
trapped maybe you can't hold everything
together there what are we thinking is
this a genius move by levonaroni and the
bar did react I think it is a great idea
but the problem is that our Channel now
is process of elimination he knows he
can't take that pawn with his Knight
which he may swap nights on F6 he just
does that and you have to take with the
pawn and in doing so look at the H6 Pawn
he goes Rook C8 his threat now is Rook
over to h8 he's gonna slide over there
hit this Pawn H6 and also throwing a
skewer along the seventh rank this is
the problem when you're stuck defending
passively now the pawn structure has
changed and white can take advantage
this is this is amazing playback oh tell
me I've just I am so impressed the fact
that he's traded off so many pieces in a
must-win position and happily and just
gone into an end game where he knows
he's got enough chances to get that win
it shows the confidence that he has he's
played flawlessly this Armageddon yeah
nerves of Steel still with an extra
minute and a half as well now level of
rhodium he's realizing that his last
decision was not optimal but again he
needs to hustle Rook end games do have a
very drawish tendency so it's all about
getting that black Rook active I'm not
sure how you achieve that actually
because you do have so many weaknesses
you would be happy you would love to
give up a pawn right now just to get
that black Rook into the game but how do
you achieve it level needs to decide
needs to decide quickly this is really
tell you either go King F7 and this is
when you bring out your devil rescue
in-game manuals chapter uh what is it
it's um actually Four working game
chapters in there all chanceable by the
way four it work in game chapters do you
understand what I'm saying here chat
four rook in game chapters so it's
probably in chapter wherever right it's
just you're just gonna have to go read
it right it's very tough here they
always say rook in games are drawn but
you got to do it you gotta actually do
the work there and this is tough here
maybe you push one of the pawns maybe
you go King F7 to meet Rick ache with
King G6 or G7 in his plate yeah he
played it but after a long think and
look at this I tell me if he knows which
side of the board he's he knows that
long term he's going to create a past
Pawn on that King side so why not start
the race now push upon give the move
back to your opponent and level around
in tanking under two minutes what move
that's the question is if you move your
king too far towards the king side
toward the flank then your central pawns
will be targeted if you move back
towards the center then isolate It Pawn
on H6 will be a victim of White's Rook
so this move actually freezes black in
place it also allows the white king to
step forward maybe Venture through G3 up
the board I feel like LaVon could barely
move right now and he does not have much
time yeah it's almost like forcing left
to create more weaknesses in the
position and that's what love has done
because of lack of options he advances
this Pawn which means we will have more
Thorn islands in the position the one
thing that Artemis has to be careful
about is not giving up control of that C
file not to hurry with attack on those
pawns because then Levon will be looking
for counter play with his own Rook so
he's taking it easy not moving around
with that Rook on C8 but instead brings
the king to the center center of the
board nice move good end game wisdom
active Rook tick active King now tick
and also creating a past Pawn he's
pushing those pawns up the board and
Levon he's had to commit okay so two of
us is one advantage now uh on that right
flank and I have a bad feeling for Levon
aroni one and a half minutes to defend
this difficult end game not gonna be
easy he's gonna get flagged yeah you can
definitely see that flag coming of
course I mean only there's only very few
people on Earth where you know you get
lower on time and you get stronger and
Levon is not one of them here so of
course his lore is when his time gets
lower we've seen with Magnus and even
Wesley so like these strong players you
get long time you mean you're gonna make
blunders though of course is a little
bit different here I also like the king
activity from white I mean a lot of
times an active King and active pieces
as a as a David house said with the
active Rook active King gives you lots
of chances lots of possibilities now
Black's trying to be active here now
though Rook G7 so what do we do about
this yeah let's defend it with the king
I think though maybe it's time to be a
little bit more passive right because
King F4 is the most tempting move going
forward but that gives back E5 with
check so we don't want to give any
checks to Black to get that pawn rolling
so I think artemia was thinking at the
right moment he has that lead on the
clock and now he's using it why is it
because he may just win this on the
board yeah and uh you're right Robert
you got two two squares the white king
can go to you Shuffle across but uh okay
he has picked the uh safer Square this
move does not come with a check and now
White's Rook can start hunting Pawns in
the next move or two there is plenty of
targets on both flanks so many
weaknesses for black White's Rook so
Superior to its counterpart also one
extra minute time Advantage being eaten
away you do feel like I'll tell me if
wants to win this on the wood he's not
even looking at the clock right now and
uh Levon poised you can see Levon he's
itching to play he's probably pre-moved
his next move or two uh he wants a
capture in the center so that his King
can get active the black king can enter
the middle of the board and suddenly get
some chances there so still accuracy
required and or tell me if he can ignore
the tension between the pawns right now
and bring his Rook two squares back
attacking multiple pawns at the same
time in the sixth rank so he gives one
to get two and that will be a pawn
Advantage though that gets tricky
because you do not want to hand Levon a
pass Pawn then you have to start
worrying about that Queen I keep saying
this quality over quantity in The Rook
end games but I do think that our team
will have both yeah look at the clocks
though only 15 seconds in it suddenly
this one is going to be a race to the
Finish Robert's move on the board the
most natural move on the board but it
took him a long time and now the black
king is going to go active nothing for
it gotta forget the material forget the
pawns and Levon is banking everything
gambling everything on his Pawn running
through uh I'll tell me if it's stopped
it but only a one-point Advantage now
yeah but this is just going to come down
to the clock the position might be level
practically still very difficult with
that extra pawn and The Rook activity I
think in a rapid game eight out of 10
times you'd save this but with a minute
on the clock and your opponent out there
to flag you is still Advantage our time
you have I am a little scared as
is Lavon because I mean like well our
team is getting lower on time and you
know what happens when he gets lower on
time it's been proven in every match
he's played that when he gets lower he
gets stronger so it's a little scary
right now and there's no increment right
so he is going to flag him he is up
about half a minute and he's this past
Pawn he can push his Pawn to the board
and just make a ton of other moves and
Lavon I don't know if he's going to be
able to withstand this he is not a
bullet specialist he's quite great at it
actually people underestimate him but
Artemis is better between the two our
time we have has to win this game to
continue his journey in the chassisable
Masters if it ends in a draw Levon
aronian takes the match Lebanon down to
about 53 seconds he has time to make
about 50 moves in the game and that's
kind of easy to squeeze in in this kind
of a rook Pawn ending 40th move you make
another pawn move that's all you need to
do vladislav just has to turn off that
Mr Nice Guy uh Persona that he has he
just needs to flick in a few Rook checks
push upon another few Rook checks push
report exactly do it fast white can
pre-move here white is the one one
checking what's the one pushing
importance black is the one reacting and
it's so much slower to react but he
hasn't played as quickly as he should
have done and suddenly active white is
stuck white has no winning plan the
black Rook is actually going to be the
one checking the white king and start
trying to win over the board Mr Nice Guy
objectively it's fine for black you
probably hold a draw but play the clock
do not have any shame and now he's the
one who's low on the clock it is Levon
who can try and flag him in this one
oh my God levon's moves are simple you
just react to the checks now and uh
suddenly okay we've had this position
before the black Rook the black king can
move why is he not moving too slow oh he
does before yes he goes for it changes
the position now he might just run his
King over and he needs to flag him he
just has to just move very quickly who
cares what the material is but Robert
who was slagging who in this one 21-20
oh my God no increments
something moves are being made they will
come in shortly I think that's what
happens in cluster so don't worry Lavon
is not spending all this time we will
have this up shortly but Levant is
playing quickly he's keeping up on the
clock he is not about to flag
Something's Happened Here the board is
Frozen the clock has frozen too we'll
try and keep you up to date uh this is
the current position we'll watch on the
analysis board here and uh okay the
clocks we're not sure about it's going
to end up King versus King with best
play but it's about the clock of course
dead drone position wow actually black
is winning the British
winning these are the correct times does
have enough time to win or Draw this
game
[Music]
here we go
oh
look at him celebrating oh my God
it was a draw by repetition they
repeated it just in time because Lavon
was actually down on the clock at the
end of the game but he makes a draw
there and what a save
wow love on our onion goes through in to
the next match it is the end of the road
for vladislav our champion it could have
gone either way what an Armageddon this
was
I think we were all catching our breath
the players will be drained as well
and celebrating he's got reasons to be
proud of just keeping control over his
nerves when it mattered the most and
with that let's take a look at our
score line
it's crazy stuff I mean yeah Lavon goes
through he wins it he made it through
that's crazy what a what an army getting
right what an Armageddon and actually
the final position was winning for Levon
so he did it just in time on the board
but also on the clock imagine starting
with half the time and still handling
such a difficult Rook end game just a
show uh near the final stages Levon had
turned it around I'll tell you may have
had taken risks to try and win and here
if he had more time on the clock Levon
would have brought his Rook across to
any safe Square on the fifth Rank and
this Pawn is running through to
promotion you can give and Shaq Force
the black king away but uh for example
here white is simply too slow next move
the black king moves out the way and
black makes a new Queen it will cost
white his Rook Levon doing the business
in this Rook end game and
congratulations to him
for a moment we saw lamonaroni and
celebrate there what a win what a match
this has been let's take a look at the
scoreline of the elimination bracket
today Magnus Carlton has gone further
Wesley so End of the Road vladislav our
time you have unfortunately has been
knocked out he is out of the tournament
Lebanon taking that epic Armageddon win
with the black pieces wow what was that
I'm still reading from it and we've got
the winner of that match who will be
joining us
really soon guys seven and a half
minutes levon's bid but it worked out in
the end wow fortune favors the bold that
was a crazy bid from levana Roan he's
not typically known as a Speedster but
he had the mouse beat when it counted he
was down to his final three seconds he
forced the draw that's all he needed
just like five minute car when it did to
our time of yesterday yeah what an
awesome match and we've got the winner
with us let's bring him on Lavon
congratulations
thank you very much
love the match could have really gone
either way what did it take to win today
uh yeah of course I think it well I I I
think I really cannot live without drama
I I created all of this myself I mean in
the second game uh my position was so
good I could play anything I mean in the
opening and then I just slowly uh played
the worst possible moves and lost the
game and the last game of course I got a
difficult position at some point I
really missed this Knight takes C4 idea
I shouldn't have captured an E4 and
after that it was downhill I was really
lucky to find this idea with uh E5 you
know E5 E4 at least creating some kind
of play otherwise it just look
very loosing uh well so to answer your
question Tanya it took the usual recipe
that I always show the luck
well I love to say you make your own
luck on the chessboard and that's what
we saw today but I want you to take a
look at your reaction actually after
winning the match it was amazing to
watch there some celebration just take
us through this what was going on in
your mind was it relief Joy
well I thought he's going to flag me you
know with the
with the Rook but he
ah he didn't do it you know
so it made me happy you know that I
didn't get flagged
do you think that that is something that
sometimes works against our time you
have he has this psychological battle
perhaps and doesn't feel comfortable in
these Armageddon formats
I think everybody has that problem
generally and that's why I think it's
it's only fair to add uh once I can per
move after move 60 which I think
is is necessary for our Megadons
generally
I love looking forward you will be
playing against Magnus tomorrow
there's going to be an epic Clash uh how
do you feel about that take us through
it
well so far I've been to Survivor so I'm
going to try to do the same you know
just to fight till the last bullet
because I I cannot really say that I
playing well or playing a stable brand
of Chess I'm blundering a lot losing
unnecessary games but uh yeah all it
takes is fighting
we love to see you fighting love and it
has been a fantastic match thank you so
much and we will see you tomorrow all
the best
thank you very much guys
putting it on luck but what fantastic
play by both love and art tamiyev our
time we have dominating in that second
game Lev took the match took the game in
round one and then eventually in the
Armageddon anything could have happened
slagging could have happened but lavon's
the one who prevailed with better
control over the nerves we are going to
go into a shot twitch break and be right
back
[Music]
while the players have been having so
much fun playing chess we also have been
having a lot of fun playing chess in the
city of Oslo and that has been Thanks to
our lifestyle Partners Puma James Canty
took to the streets of Oslo for some
banter Blitz and trash talking was
allowed
here we go guys I am here feeling Master
James Kennedy the third aka the Jedi we
here in Oslo okay Norway is going down
we got some banter Blitz today as you
can see my goal is to mess you up by
talking to you while we playing okay do
you want to play against James I don't
think yeah I'm Daniel James nice to meet
you nice to meet you what's your rating
uh I don't play much but I think a peak
that's about 900 and just okay all right
now honey be careful not to be the
strongest now hiding on the planet will
he quick
100. he ain't no nine nine what maybe
1900. oh there we go I think that
shouldn't be too quick yeah that's okay
for you maybe yeah
I'm just trying to see if I can win
something I don't think so I'm just
trying giving you some pawns yo you
gotta remember for free you gotta relax
bro you don't want to I don't want it
okay do you have something here yes you
do whoa check oh no that man played
excellent
[Applause]
they don't be teaching you that
we got back up bro
yeah you got back up bro
never seen that type of move in my life
let's do the replay on that
I think it's
not with March oh March okay
oh you gonna have to relax my guy
wow
what's this
[Applause]
it's over almost all right James what's
your rating I'm not quite sure I'm not
even slightly sober since last night do
we have to play with increments uh you
want to play without yeah sure sweet one
minute we playing bullet no let's go boy
hey quick okay quick he's actually good
guys
okay it sucks whoa Mama Mia whoa
we're moving it oh no no
no there's one second left and that was
intense dude he at least 2200 bro I
actually think you're high I'm higher
rated than you
that's crazy
[Laughter]
that's not is that covering
is it this way
[Music]
hi my name is Carl Magnuson can we play
chess ah yes
[Music]
this is a queen
yes I heard you were a grand master nice
to meet you yeah nice to meet you
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
[Music]
that was crazy we was out there in the
streets having some fun of course I
played Carl Magnuson over here right it
was it was a lot of fun of course I had
that one second game the guy I played
was actually 2400 feet eh I was like oh
he's a beast right he was a young maker
I don't even know what my rating is but
he was 2400. then we had the guy out
there with the new move oh my goodness
Knight A6 did y'all see that chat Knight
A6 that was crazy I never knew that that
came out in March is what he said the
new move right so it's fun out in the
streets of Oslo it was awesome and I was
in a puma trip you know I still got the
Puma on right now you know what I mean
get the close-up you see the Puma here
yeah shout out to Puma for all the drip
we got like 400 worth of Puma gear it
was amazing chocolate Puma to sponsor
James
you know look at me right you know Puma
all the way down baby love it and a huge
shout out to our lifestyle Partners Puma
for all the giveaways and the fun that
we have with them right now it is fun
with chess as the big final is coming up
Fabiano caruana taking on hikarina
Nakamura Hikaru wall number five Fabi
world number seven the top two players
from the United States very different
styles of play how do you wow we've got
action already the game is on you know I
thought you were about to ask what we
might see and I wasn't expecting this
opening in English from 500 Carolina but
I think that's what he wants to do
against hikar Nakamura he does not want
a car to get that opening preparation to
use it to his full advantage uh but it's
early at this one and we've only had the
trade of knights yeah so it did start as
the English opening the four nights
variation one set of those nights
disappearing and uh Hikaru jumps out
with his Bishop this was actually very
trendy about 10 years ago everyone was
playing in this line for black but
suddenly it disappeared and that must be
for a reason Hikaru bringing it back and
uh Kate Fabby is the first to think just
putting his head down there he knows he
studied this before I've actually seen
both players play this exact line before
but uh can he recall what he wanted to
do why his head in development White
Queen is out White's castled but black
super solid and uh just one more movie
Kara Nakamura if the black king castles
to safety I think it's been a success
his opening uh nothing to complain about
there for Hikaru the players will play a
best of four in the winners final and
there is a lot at stake at this one the
winner goes through to the next
to the next Champions chest or event
they booked their spot in the next
Champions chest story event Robert well
I think their fortunate because both of
them no matter what happens here they
are making their way through the top
division in the third event so that
takes some of the pressure off that's
the good thing but come on we know we
could say everything about the next
event it's about this event when these
two American Superstars go at it because
they have played each other so many
times we saw their head to head and you
know they want to take the other down
wow well that's why Hikaru said that the
main aim is to get to the next one he's
already done it so the pressure is off
but door points are at stake and Hikaru
Nakamura looks extra chill today I have
to say usually we see him leaning in
doing that head Bob nodding his head
Expressions he seems really relaxed is
he very happy with the opening outcome
James absolutely of course even has the
pineapple shirt on so you better be very
careful with the pineapple shirt and the
pineapple behind them sometimes it
raises 100 ELO he already 2800 you don't
want that right so if of course he's
already feeling comfortable here I think
he just needs to develop pieces he
already has restricted a little bit of
White's play now we do have ourselves
like a Catalan Bishop here with the
bishop on G2 in this English here but
very strong Bishop on G2 for foppy so we
can't try to create some chances but
maybe a C5 and even like a rook to B1
fin Kettle the bishop on B3 with B3
Bishop B2 you know very slow play not
something you really see a lot from Fabi
here but definitely a nice position for
both sides I think uh everything's level
so far yeah you're right actually that
last Point's about it not being fabby's
style usually he does prefer to hit his
opponent's strike early go a bit direct
if he can but uh this one is very much
about the slow Maneuvers and Hikaru
looking super chilled and I love his
position actually as black is Fabby
smiling was that a little smile from
Fabi right there he actually is yeah
yeah you are Italian you see it you see
it maybe he heard my comment about
liking her courage position sorry Fabi
but uh yeah meanwhile okay striking now
this started as an English of course it
does look like a bit like a Catalan with
that white Bishop but more of a reverse
Sicilian and uh In the Sicilian you
often want that extra Pawn advantage in
the center and now Fabi saying you can
bypass my Pawn you can step away from
this but then Black's dark Square Bishop
is going to be locked in forever or you
can trade off but then the White Knight
comes in off the edge of the board to a
nicer Square so first real question of
the game for Hikaru and sometimes when a
player starts thinking it means that
their preparation has come to an end all
or perhaps their opponent has played
maybe not the best move or even the
second best move it's catching them by
surprise but this is a standard type of
idea by Fabiano he's pushing his Pawn
forward to blunt the scope of that
Bishop on A7 he wants to get his Knight
into C5 we just saw that in the game
between artemiev and aronian earlier
today and so it's a common idea the
bishop on G2 that light Square Bishop is
in great position staring across the
diagonal black slide score Bishop yet to
be developed I think now might be the
time yep now might be the time what is
that on fabiana's shoulder I've noticed
this uh come into play the last couple
of days he takes it off again oh man
nice might be yeah it might be something
he might have been working out too hard
to tell him what to do you need to get
your your creatine your glutamine right
your glutamine good he'd been in the gym
so he might have hurt himself a little
bit got a stretch before and after some
dynamic stretches I'm gonna hit his line
I got it or maybe this is his workout oh
right he's just trying to get those
heating pads going this chest is his
workout right
exactly right oh man that shoulder might
be hurting a little bit yeah
once again once again asking Hikaru to
take some decisions do you want to trade
do you want to fix the center Hikaru
says no I want to develop my pieces
makes a lot of sense yeah he covered
these days he really values the center
highly he values space very highly for
me this decision would have been really
really hard but he made it within a
minute or so on the clock and uh you
mentioned the center at Tanya I'm also
fixated after uh hikara's last move on
this bishop this bishop on A7 how is it
ever getting back into the game it's
just staring down against a really
strong Pawn here the White Knight kind
of keeps this cage locked protecting
this Pawn if Hikaru ever drops this
bishop back then the white note will be
ready to jump in so uh yes black has a
nice Pawn Center I'm really loving the
space he's established here but the rest
of his position I'm not so sure about
and uh Fabi here he's ready to take a
time out stepping a porn forward is he
perhaps going to at some point just tuck
his King away to safety and start
throwing pawns towards the black king
later I think he's getting ready just in
case the position shuts down white will
lash out now on and switch play to the
king side it's really flexible actually
from Fabiano and Hikaru does answer my
question he drops back with his Bishop
he's happy to allow the White Knight to
jump in and he's saying yes my Rook
might look a bit weird right now but I'm
gonna come for you I'm gonna get rid of
your knight and then the position will
stabilize interesting Clash of ideas
well now there's going to be no King age
too because I Bishop on B8 and then you
can't play you know you'll see this a
lot in the Batman type English setups
it's almost bought for Nick like where
like he just you know pushed the C Pawn
from C4 to C5 and we still have D3 and
E4 that you will see in about phonic
English or in fact a chessable course
for that is the iron English by Simon
Williams but you will play King H1 here
and then usually you play F4 and G4 and
everything four push everything up G5 in
there Rook G1 Bishop F3 right and we're
going for an attack on this side of the
board right so it is very possible to do
so if you put the King on H2 you run
right into the bishop on B8 so this is
uh definitely a nice Bishop that he has
there on B8 but if the king is on H2
it'll be a problem for for five so
taking that one all right you know I
think James wants to play F4 right away
he's like let's go forward why do we
have to move our King first walk into
that Bishop's line of fire so I think F4
is a very nice idea for Fabian I'm not
sure if you throw a knight B6 first or
or play F4 right away but that is going
to be the plan to break open the king
side yeah you just have to time it
correctly just to make sure that the
white king doesn't uh become too open
doesn't suffer from uh lines opening on
that side of the board first he does
flick in this Knight attack and I'm
expecting Hikaru okay he's paused but
I'm expecting him to use this Square for
his Rook at least to put some pressure
on this white knight temporarily a bit
of a standoff between those two pieces
but uh nothing too serious yet that
white knight is not on that square
permanently but uh okay Fabio playing
only on the queen side our eyes were
drifting over to the other flank what do
you think of this James B4 that is I
don't really like it I'm not even gonna
lie I was like okay Fabi uh no I just
don't like it the fact that me it just
opens up I mean if he takes it is there
anything like tricky he's I'm assuming
he's just going to take it back but that
opens The Rook The Rook is now a little
bit better than it was and I mean I can
get this night out of there by Bishop to
C7 and you're gonna have to move the
Knight again and then my Rook has some
Merit maybe I even have Queen A8 or like
just I'm ready to double at some point
um because the rook's already on A6 I
think maybe he should have went for the
F4 plan but he definitely has something
in mind with B4 we just have to see what
it is now it caught with frowning for
the first time in the game surprised I
think just as much as we are here in the
studio by this last move by Fabi uh I
think the idea is to kind of keep that
root cage forever if we have to go in a
few moves then I guess uh just to
investigate what is happening Here pawn
takes Pawn I think the idea is Bishop
takes and you mentioned this one uh
James but the Knight isn't quite
attacked for now you could make an
argument for pushing this Pawn forward
if the Knight is captured suddenly and
discovered attack against the Black
Brook black takes the time out to move
it then you're just in time to close
that cage again around this poor rook
and uh suddenly white has a great
structure everyone has the bishop pair
too so I think this is his idea he wants
to trade off and then push this Pawn
forward as fast as possible sprinted up
the board just to keep things locked up
I like it yeah that's actually a cool
idea he's protecting his Knight on B6
tactically and if you can get that pawn
up to A5 it feels like Black's pieces
are stuck so what is hikaru's plan
that's the big question and even though
the evaluation Bar says it's a level
game I feel like White's next few moves
are quite obvious and how black uh
responsive those is not so clear so I
actually really like this B4 push from
Fabiano yeah B4 and before it's too late
he does ask those questions to Hikaru uh
first real think of the game and uh yeah
I'm really happy with the outcome of
this opening I've got to say I was a bit
worried when uh studying kind of the
head-to-head between these two so many
berlins between them so many really kind
of stodgy games Hikaru often quite
liking this solid start especially with
black against Fabi but uh yeah Fabiano
is known as one of the most ambitious
players on the tour and he's playing
like it yeah he's actually playing like
a squeezer here like more of a you know
a karpovian type you know squeeze here
usually you'll see more aggressive
calculating 5V calculator delay
calculate Prep Prep stack a piece like
you did on mvl after I got a year of
prep right in the candidates so very
strong preparation but also here I mean
you can see saying I have both Styles I
can kind of do whatever in fact he says
there's a quote from cgc we was talking
about you know most most players have
Universal Styles right but the thing
that really uh separates them is the
calculation calculation over everything
he must be a hero for those calculations
so yeah we send him a lot of gear
absolutely yeah and that's on the board
yeah it's on the board and sneaky threat
from Hikaru Nakamura he's actually
threatening right now to take that
strong White Knight with the black rook
and after white recaptures the black
queen and the white dot Squad Bishop a
bit of tension there the white Dart
score Bishop not protected black would
win material so you have to protect that
uh Bishop right now I'm not sure how
Hikaru intends to continue it feels like
a one move threat I don't know if
there's any further substance there we
go most natural move defend that bishop
and uh just centralizes his work I
really like how Hikaru takes a little
think and then just blitzes out okay
moves in a row and that puts so much
pressure on the opponent is that good
strategy for Blitz I think so it
definitely helps to switch off the pace
of the game you kind of keep your
opponent guessing I think not just Blitz
Tanya In classical chess I'm a time
travel addict I'm well known for it but
the one strategy I hate most as a Time
trouble addict is when my opponents stop
they kind of keep me nervous my
adrenaline's pumping and then they just
calm me down and then speed things up
again and uh it's just hard you kind of
want your opponent to Blitz you because
then you can kind of keep going going
you're getting a rhythm but as soon as
they switch things up you lose a bit of
focus and okay Hikaru blocks the
position
and uh still a bad Rook for him but the
rest looks pretty nice for black and now
with the center blocked my Fabi display
on both sides you've got this Pawn on A5
and I start even thinking about the king
side yeah I like the look of this
position for Fabiano me as you're saying
play on the king side what does that
look like white might try struck with F4
not available just yet that black Bishop
is lurking on B8 it's still aiming
towards the white king side and black
may play F5 himself saying I need some
space for my pieces or that Knight this
Knight might Gallop that was on F6 to E8
over to C7 and then even up to B5 so
don't be fooled that Knight is going
backwards so it could take two steps
forwards yeah that's a really nice post
for the Black Knight if it ends up there
can never be challenged and it will lock
down that flank that Queen side so will
we see Fabiano switch Focus we could
well see him just kind of switch his
Rook back and play for the pawn push but
of course that's risky too with the
sniper on B8 peering over in that
direction
yeah I've got to say I don't know who
I'd prefer yeah I like the look of
White's position aesthetically but black
has the space in the center
it's very level very level it's just
going to take a few more minutes here
obviously to see you know who is going
to make a concession who's going to
break first in fact like in that Wesley
and Hikaru game that was just super
crazy where Wesley got low on time and
then he dropped the pawn but then it
still ended in the draw that was a wild
game it reminds me of that type of feel
in this position it's really tight it's
locked down lots of maneuvering Here
pawn breaks of course as Robert says
Whoever has the pawn breaks controls the
game so F4 actually is the pawn break
here and there is an F5 break but that
one maybe not so much that black would
like to do it does weaken the king but
F4 is definitely a nice Palm break to
try to get that five in Rook F1 also as
well as David pointed out we want to
maybe switch sides here and go to the
king side of the board if possible Yeah
you mentioned it's got similarities
really reminiscent of that game between
Wesley and Hikaru that one was a hundred
move grind right are we in for the Long
Haul here should we strap in our seat
belts and dirt just yeah get ready for
all those Maneuvers really hard to pick
a planet that's actually when the
players spend the most time it's not on
calculation because they're so quick
they practice that so much and they're
really Snappy with their calculation
it's when they're planning that the
players burn most of their clock time it
is these critical moments right we talk
about them so many times it's not just
about calculation but finding the right
path looking at trades looking at
changing Bond structures and that last
move by Fabi is hinting at a potential
Pawn storm on the king side and there it
arrives on Hikaru immediately captures
the position was again reminiscent of a
king's Indian type of setup for white
the centers blocked white plays on the
king side and this is one of the uh kind
of recommended antidotes to the king's
Indian
five break here is F4 with colors
reversed a trade of Pawns and yes it
looks a bit odd for black but as soon as
that black knight moves out the way I'm
loving the dark Square Bishop it's ready
uh to exert its influence into the
center but what I'm loving is the open G
file for white to attack on that's a
semi-open line black has a pawn there
white is gonna start putting pieces
there to attack the black king I like to
move F5 to start with let's just cement
that pawn structure in place the bishop
drops back to F7 then maybe bishop F3 my
point is I'm clearing the G file I don't
actually know where the white king will
end up it's not out of the question we
see a Petrosian King march towards the
center and even to the queen side but
we're gonna get a rook on G1 we're gonna
go Rook up the G file second Rook over
there we are going to attack dang Robert
you play the Kings in here before hey
Robert that's oh that's straight out of
the king's Indian book The Colors
reverse literally everything you would
do there wow that's nasty I don't need a
chain to tell me calculation over
everything I'm going for the attack
Robert S no can't do chess without Hess
you know what I'm saying wow the
hessible Masters okay here we go go yeah
that's nice stuff Bishop F3 F5 Queen G2
run the king over I mean all these ideas
are extremely strong for white here the
problem is the dark Square Bishop as
Robert pointed out too as well and David
Howell the good that dark Square Bishop
when you do play F5 you don't have to
worry about those dark squares which are
very very loose here so I mean it's kind
of loose for both sides here I wonder if
you even go F5 yeah I love that idea
Robert but uh I guess Fabiano's decided
to be more flexible not willing to
commit right now that idea is still on
top for later and I'm expecting him to
reroute the White Queen first of all
she's kind of sitting on a nothing
square right now not doing too much I'm
expecting her to swing over and only
when his pieces are in position then
he'll decide which Central Pawn to push
forward he still has options for E5 F5
and of course uh to maybe maneuver a
rook towards that black king a bit later
on on the G file but uh yeah meanwhile
I'm looking for Black's plans and those
are far more mysterious it's definitely
not clear what hikara is doing
especially that Rook on A6 it's uh
basically being canceled out by the
White Knight so the rest of the wood
white is material up and that's why I do
believe in fabiana's chances and wow he
goes for it immediately not maneuvering
any longer E5 and Fabiano going for it
you know what he might want is that
Knight on B6 that's stopping The Rook
over there if black decides to avoid any
kind of Trades he does not want to open
up the position we can understand that
if F5 is to be played then that Knight
might come back to C4 and into D6 and
look at those pawns on C5 and E5 it's a
clamp and that Knight will just sit in
front of all of Black's pieces and let's
just let's put the Knight on D6 and have
black take that Knight somehow oh gosh a
pawn will be passed and protected and
you see the evaluation is already Sky
High it would be a winning position for
white yeah what a pawn that is on D6 you
open up lines as well uh in the meantime
and look at this piece this is a dead
Bishop this is a dead Rook you're
essentially playing two whole pieces up
and uh White spawns swimming all over
the black Army and of course this won't
happen Hikaru won't be so kind of
compliant he won't help Fabiano with
this plan but how does he stop it it's
actually surprisingly difficult if you
do take this Pawn you only open lines up
for the white Rooks uh firstly you can
take this Pawn back same idea that
Robert showed there also very thematic
typical for this type of position you
can throw a pawn forward and block
things up because there you go
yeah I was definitely looking F5 and
then F6 just because I can do it and
then Pawn takes and I don't even know
what I'm doing next maybe Queen F2 Queen
H4 but the open files here let me just
swing the bishop over back to D2 I mean
this is nasty the bishop is the dark
Square Bishop for black is in K it's in
caged by its own pawns here right you
play you can't play I mean you can't
play E4 but that's gonna open up more
lines for me so this F5 move followed by
F6 is there I can even open with a and
I'm going back to the original position
I can do a D
um e e takes F6 here right so he's he's
under something some fire F5 is on the
board yeah I'm actually surprised
looking at the eval bar on our live
board that it isn't giving Fabi a bigger
Advantage because this is such a
difficult position for Hikaru currently
with that Bishop on B8 essentially
playing down a rook down a bishop all
the white spaces looking really good is
the eval bar deceptive in this kind of a
position is it practically more
challenging it definitely is I think
humans look at this position If This
Were a pure Blitz game if we took five
minutes off each of their clocks to say
black can't do anything White's just
gonna maneuver the pieces plant that
night on D6 hopefully and then win the
game but engines they do not have hearts
they do not have emotions they are
objective calm collected calculators and
it says what is White gonna do and
perhaps if white goes too ambitious then
black will be able to counter and that
Knight on B5 that's sitting over there
it can hop forward into the position it
doesn't threaten anything just yet but
you have to look out for some potential
sacrifices where blood opens up the
board unfavorable terms for him
yeah still in the balance and Hikaru
keeping a poker face so maybe he's not
too stressed not too worried either
about his chances uh I'm liking this
maneuver I'm just kind of focused on it
right now I'm not sure what else white
can try other than dropping the Knight
back and into that beautiful D6 square
but neither player kind of too kind of
concerned by that right now what is
Fabby thinking about I guess the other
option alludes to something from earlier
on just shuffled the white king into the
corner Shuffle one of the white Rooks to
the g-file and start attacking that
black king immediately so two types of
uh kind of alternative strategies there
which one will Fabi go for I'm slightly
concerned about the clock time we do
know against Hikaru that can be fatal
being behind on the clock I'll be
looking like the thing oh well he can't
afford to think too much because this is
such a pleasant position he needs to
make a decision he needs to make it fast
the critical moment will arrive later
and you do need time when you're playing
against a resourceful player like Hikaru
Nakamura who sets up those tricky traps
all the time these are two giant turns
of the Chess World the top two players
from the United States World number five
Hikaru world number seven Fabi just
brilliant chess by them on in so many
Elite events but I have to ask you James
in this format when it's about speed
when it is about nerves is Hikaru a
favorite Hikaru is a huge favor here I
mean of course he's one of the strongest
people on the planet he even beat Magnus
in the speed test Championship I mean
magnets don't lose in the speed test
Championship but he does see Carl right
it's almost like you know who do you
pick I'll pick your car I'll pick
magnets you don't really know there and
Hikaru showed that I can hang with the
best I am one of the best I'm a world
champion too as well official random
that is but I mean the man is an
absolute Beast right we always say or at
least I say he's half man in the other
half we don't know yet because he is
very crazy when it comes to this chest
right especially in the faster time
controls here you don't want to get low
on time against uh against Hikaru and
right now fopi is actually doing that
has a better position but he needs to be
able to convert as we saw in the other
matches probably get along time it's not
a good thing yeah we've seen Hikaru
against Wesley in very difficult
position finding all these tricks and
traps and Wesley no time just collapses
I see their rapid ratings there isn't
that much difference 28 25 to Fabi 2839
for Hikaru but it does seem that Hikaru
in these formats just is a stronger
player
and if you do take the averages
throughout the years of rapid and Blitz
chess especially Blitz chess which this
game will soon become then Hikaru does
have an advantage over Fabi so it will
be not right now but maybe later when
it's two minutes each or one minute each
where the nurse kick in and hikara's
experience might tell I just I don't
know how he wins all these title
Tuesdays I've got to say it's so hard to
see the other even get top 50 let alone
to win it every single time that's how
consistent Hikaru is as well and in
order to break that consistency you need
something a bit magic Fabiano looking
for that now
yeah we saw some support there with
let's go Fabi with a selfie keep sending
us your selfies we are loving them show
us how you are watching the Champions
chess store on Instagram remember to use
the landscape mode with hashtag chess
Champs and you could win chessable
credits for your favorite course so keep
them coming
yeah what a price nice price and clearly
it's attracting some of our viewers uh
there with their photos I saw someone
was feeling ill sorry hope you feel
better watching the chess but uh yeah
meanwhile mysterious moves on the board
this Rook Shuffle from uh Fabiano
just biting time maybe yeah so what I
like to say the side that controls the
pawn breaks off in the side of the
adventure there it is I was about to
call for it G5 you saw hikaru's previous
move was putting his own King in the
corner now he says to strike with Pawn
to G5 because white committed his Pawn
structure in the center and now black is
trying to undermine its defense you get
rid of the base Pawn that's the F4 Pawn
the E5 Pawn is next it will be under
attack and when the position opens up
when things start exploding actually
Black's King is quite safe and sound in
the corner yeah it doesn't uh look too
safe but actually it's deceptive you're
right Robert this uh there's simply no
white pieces that can attack this black
king so there's nothing to worry about
and if we do see that trade of Pawns I
think black's actually happily going to
remove even more shelter from his black
king and uh the queen could slide across
with some threats against the enemy King
here it's actually the counterpart
that's more Dane uh that's in more
danger and of course this Pawn feels
like now or never in terms of this
maneuver from Fabi he's resisted so far
but uh either in this position or maybe
after capturing he needs to get this
Knight back into the game he needs to
throw it in to just block up the black
activity on the D6 on the D6 Square to
plug all those holes but uh yeah I just
worry about the momentum of this game it
feels like it's momentum Hikaru right
now Fabi may be playing a bit too
tentatively and uh Missing the
opportunities here Black's pawns now as
well advancing in the near future
looking good for Hikaru yeah also the
time issue the time issue for five I
mean that's a Kryptonite and not just
for Fabi for like really most players
besides grishek and artemia you know
when you get low on time you know it you
it's like a Kryptonite you just you
can't see as much as you would you start
to panic a little bit as he now has you
know under two minutes on the clock
versus Hikaru 649 that's a whole piece
up in a way of course uh if you think
about it that way and he's it's
initiative black now Rook G8 maybe Rook
to G7 Rook H7 right we get the Rook
active and put it on H7 there's gonna be
problems with G4 E5 is hanging right now
I feel like initiative is definitely in
Black's favor yeah he's gonna have one
eye on the clock Fabiano one eye on the
board and you can't split your focus
like that against Hikaru Nakamura and
get away with it and yeah it feels like
an important moment now if Abby doesn't
find something magical over the next
couple of moves he could just get
steamrollered by those black pawns on
the king side the white king definitely
in some trouble it's amazing how this
game has turned because suddenly white
is the one without actual plans we your
plan is to defend your pawns that are
hanging to defend your king but black
has many plans including swinging the
queen over as you mentioned trying to
push those pawns I feel like it's a
problematic position probably and his
time is certainly not helping that's the
17th piece as James likes to say
absolutely yeah 17th and potentially
decisive piece okay the White Queen has
slid back some ideas of going over to H5
checking that black king but that can be
easily guarded against the black queen
can act as a blocker and a potential
attacker Hikaru looking up has he
spotted something concrete is he just
trying to raise up weigh up the pros and
cons of sliding that Queen across looks
like the most natural move for black
right now yeah a minute and 10 seconds
to Fabi and this this looks like the
kind of position that you need a good
offer on the clock to navigate this is
not going to be easy no and you see
hikara purse lips got a finger on them
The pineapple's Shining behind them and
on his shirt but I think right now he's
looking to win this game typically you
go into a match oh I'll draw with black
that's a good result I'll try to win
with the white pieces but he senses the
moment and he does that perhaps better
than anybody he knows when his opponent
is flailing and right now Fabiano
dropping back with his Queen yeah it
threatens the check on H5 he is going to
stop that check for sure and I think
that hikar wants to win this game now
I'm actually surprised by the evaluation
to me it looks much better for black
that's still hovering towards the center
saying it's about level to me it looks
much much better for black simply easier
to play yeah it's insane that even with
the Rook stock on A6 it's been out of
the game for the entirety of the game
and yet hecarus managed to create all
these Chances with his other pawns and
pieces currently leading on the clock by
four minutes I think if Fabi can find a
way to bail out and get out alive of
this game with a draw he will take it
with both hands David yeah I would be
begging for a draw from recovery right
now in this position and the evaluation
bar might say it's roughly level but
that doesn't take into account the
momentum White's position started High
spinning again slower slowly uh worse
and worse and also the clock situation
of course so one minute against five if
Hikaru makes a quick decision here which
I think he will in the next few seconds
then uh yeah Fabi back on the defensive
just slide across that black queen I
don't see why not block your king
protect your king and a queen is a
king's best friend most of the time so
maybe he's contemplating grabbing that
white Pawn in the center that looks too
greedy however surely not it does look
too great it feels like it's loose it
just feels kind of loose I mean I
actually get maybe some initiative back
because I mean I play rookie E1 or even
Rook E2 maybe even start with Queen H5
check first then bring the queen The
Rook over to E2 which is a huge problem
for for black here I mean it's too many
weaknesses I also double the Rooks yeah
this is exactly what Fabi wants as
Bishop takes e there so maybe we're
going to see a G4 or Rook to G8 from
from Hikaru yeah maybe G4 actually you
mentioned James that's a very forcing
move one of the first ones we should
calculate just to block this Queen's
diagonal its path into H5 looks nice if
the pawn captures now suddenly the white
king is very very open vulnerable to
some checks potentially uh this one gets
very complicated hence maybe the time
consumption here from uh Hikaru Nakamura
the other options we mentioned Rook G8
very solid bring the Rook across to the
right side of the board and also Queen
H7 just lining up and stopping any
checks so those uh okay he's finally
gone for that decision he's brought his
Queen across and big threat on the board
potentially firstly Bishop takes Pawn in
some scenarios and also Pawn to G4 uh
Fabi meanwhile shuffling his queen I'm
really not sure what he's trying to
achieve actually with this last one just
waiting holding some key squares maybe
and what's important is that in order
for black to attack your own King
becomes more vulnerable so hikar will
have to push pawns forward and that
means his King is weaker sure and if you
think about it if that pawn on H3 the
pawn in front of the white king is
removed that means there's a rook that
can get on that line and hit the black
king so sometimes you do not want to win
material in fact that could backfire
completely and so Fabi he's relying on
that in many of these variations yeah so
uh Hikaru can pull the trigger can't
throw pawns for it but is it the right
moment will it rebound will it backfire
on him that's the question and he wants
to build up I think it's a good idea as
well when you're up on the clock as we
mentioned just keep the tension but how
does Hikaru do that how does he improve
his pieces before going for that white
king I I'm kind of in James's corner
here just before I couldn't see it he
plays it bring that black Rook across uh
maybe even lift that black Rook down and
across onto the h-file Rook lifts right
right that's right do you even Rook lift
exactly you work live or not bro exactly
I mean so you're doing your work lifts
every day chat every day and it looks
like Fabi is going to go under a minute
very soon here and this isn't going to
be more of a bullet game than it is
anything else and we know who's stronger
in the bullet format there's very few
people that can even keep up and eat
with Hikaru in bullet chess here so we
don't really want it to be in that
territory but we don't have a choice
here and for father we have to make
something happen right now
going in with that Knight to that D6
square that would be a nice post for
this one I see fabi's position and that
Bishop on G2 looks like the big Defender
keeping things together is that
something that black should try and get
rid of with a trade with his own Bishop
getting it to D5
good question uh there Tanya and uh okay
we don't have to answer it yet but I
like this move I like the fact as well
that if there is a trade at some point
maybe not in this exact position but
later on through blackrook might be able
to swing across let's go back to the
game uh after G4 wow this Pawn has
advanced even further and what's
happened there's no Rook H2 a lot of
ideas with Rook H2 was coming after like
his Queen H3 check right and stuff like
that he that's why it works on the
second rank you can cover with Rook H2
but now you can't even play that so
because I took that away now Bishop D5
is a very juicy looking move it's very
strong move from Hikaru there playing uh
G3 that was definitely off the radar are
you shuffling around with the bishop he
run said to the other diagonal you've
been talking about this dark Squad
bishop and David I've got a feeling this
might be the monster eventually in
Black's position yeah this could be a
really nasty threat for Fabi to deal
with but what's better neutralizing an
enemy Bishop than your own bishop and uh
White drops his Bishop back if black
plays Bishop G5 right now the white Rook
will happily step back traits might
actually help white because you do have
this Knight it is a beast long term this
is chaos I kind of forgot that the
knights are staring at each other so
that what that white knight may take the
Black Knight it may take the pawn that
is two squares behind that black knight
like at some point so don't forget that
that Knight is actually attacking things
I thought just sitting there hoping to
be captured no it's actually a weapon
for white and I'm starting to like
Fabiano's position the clock is evening
up Bobby in time trouble of course but I
don't think a car's moves are so easy
and I could see his position collapsing
the G3 push that could be an
overextended Pawn then white may be able
to be able to capture at some point yeah
long term I like white that night just
nice and pretty he might decide the game
what long term are you talking about why
it's got 30 seconds on the clock it's
not going to go on for very long but
Sabi does need to speed up currently
although Hikaru also running low on the
clock coming to about a minute there
coming down to about a minute this one
is just going to be a scramble a hyper
bullet game hyperbole yeah yeah I was
talking long term just because short
term he currently needs something he
needs something now that's why he's
getting excited that's why you can feel
see the tension on his uh on his face
but what is it what can black try you
can try Rook G4 or okay Bishop there and
then you're gonna see a bishop trade now
Bishop traits should help white again
long term end games that's right then
you want to get rid of that light Square
Bishop in these positions so F4 Bon F4
oh nice gamble let's open up three yeah
go for that white king it would be
consistent now hikaru's lower on the
clock for the first time in this game
will we momentum switched momentum has
turned
20 seconds hey Cara Nakamura this is
anybody's game here look at the clock
all of a sudden Fabi is ahead on the
clock so he has good chances in this
position hikar trying to bring more
pieces into the attack but he may need
to defend soon his pawns are
overextended he does not threaten
anything and I mentioned that White
Knight on D6 it can start capturing
pieces yeah you can take a knight you
can take a pawn you can take a bunch of
things here White's night actually is
spoiled for Choice he does go and grab a
pawn this Knight defended by its Rook
has Fabi just won a pawn for free oh
Curry steps back he's lost two moves the
queen just came from the square Fabi
says okay I'll go back and I've nabbed a
pawn for free same position that we had
two moves ago white has an extra Pawn
however 10 seconds for Hikaru
okay that's a big Bond how is that a
blunder there might be a knight F7 check
you bring the knight in with check and
that means the King has to react but
that means you could just take this
bishop on I don't actually take the
bishop of the night so complicated
G2
the king will take the queen will come
down the white king escapes it runs up
the board and there is no Checkmate this
is not King of the Hill but the king is
going to survive I can't play G2 what
black is attacking with Rook G1 oh my
goodness black is just attacking with
the queen that's not enough you need to
add extra ammunition and Hikaru has gone
down to a couple of seconds you made
that move with two seconds left James
has moved there but it just gets blocked
and you're a whole piece down which way
do you go with the white king forward
Brave
goodness
he bunches don't worry buddy when these
moves are happening they come in quickly
and then the clock will catch up oh my
goodness where's that King doing in The
Bishop's line of fire that's a
resignation Queen H5 check whoa it
wasn't a night back with Discovery
checks actually just winning the queen
there's nothing there's nothing he has
nothing that's it
he has nothing he comes back for a
second is he about to make a move that's
it he resigns what a game what a Time
scramble there
takes the lead in his match against
Hikaru not a result that many would have
predicted David big tactical moments
there what got your attention so many
moments but I just want to go through
the end in slow motion to explain the
thought processes uh from each player
here it had already turned against mura
with the black pieces but he did make a
blunder he jumped in took upon what
could be more natural but this did
forefow of a simple check a night check
hitting the black king it's actually the
black king that gets hit first and after
the Knight takes a bishop a free piece
it turned out that the white king could
safely run into the center black simply
doesn't have enough attacking pieces we
saw a couple more moves here another
check forcing the white king to the side
but still no way to attack it no way to
trap this King a knight this time is the
King's best friend keeping the white
king nice and safe and Hikaru resigned a
few moves later the material deficit too
much to handle nice win nurse is still
from Fabiano caruana
very impressive stuff there by Fabi Kate
taking his King up all the way to G4 and
not getting checkmated that really is
something he survives and indeed how it
takes the lead in his match against
Hikaru Nakamura Fabi with that win which
means Hikaru has to at least win one
game two level the score there is more
chess coming up but before that we are
going to head into a twitch break
foreign
[Music]
the partner of the Champions chess tour
and chess.com
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
[Music]
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem so
you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
[Applause]
500 carwana famously had a seven out of
7 start in the 2014 sink Full Cup he
also challenged Magnus Carlson for the
2018 World Chess Championship title how
does a player get there you might ask
for five out of carwana it is feared
opening preparation he is a theoretician
like no other in this 2016 game from the
London chess classic Fabiana Carr want
to demonstrate how deep his opening
preparation can go with the white piece
against Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
sacrifices a knight temporarily with
Knight takes G4 after Fabiano takes this
Knight on G4 with his Bishop hikar looks
to win back the piece with E5 hitting
the queen and the Knight with his Pawn
but Fabiano caruana was a man on a
mission he says you're not going to get
your piece back I'm going to sacrifice
my queen on F6 and after the bishop took
the queen he puts his Knight on D5 the
queen slides back because under attack
as the bishop to d8 and he plays Knight
F5 getting two pieces for the queen but
with a dominant positional Advantage he
went out to win this nice game and just
a great demonstration of his excellent
and deep opening preparation
[Music]
and we are going to reveal the most
played openings of the chasable Masters
and wow no surprises there at the top
Sicilian that is such a classic such an
aggressive opening love it the players
going there for the attack and we've got
Royal Affairs at number two Robert is
there something that surprises you about
this graphic you know it is a bit
surprising to see the Sicilian at the
top because at the highest level it's
not played that frequently at least in
classical chess but when the time
control gets shorter the action heats up
the players they want to strike and
capitalize on tactical chances yeah I
love it I love the Sicilian I love to
see it I love to play a Robert James
take us through how it's done absolutely
well the Sicilian starts with a standard
opening you know the King's Pawn goes
forward E4 is best by test and when that
pawn push is played Black doesn't Strike
Back in the center instead pushing the
Queen's Bishop POG two squares forward
and the point of this is that if white
wants to push in the center black will
be able to capture it with the C5 Palm
we will not get symmetrical structures
and early on In the Sicilian white has a
number of options while Knight F3 is the
main second move you could keep it
closed you could play Knight C3 on move
two and in those lines James I think
he's gonna be a fan of this we can get
some Grand Prix attack and fun closed at
the start but they are going to get
ambitious and open in the future
absolutely I'm a big fan of Cecilia
myself of course if you go to
Chesterville right now my favorite is
actually the Knight or Cecilia in the
night or Sicilians right you have uh so
many variations that you can go with but
one of the biggest courses on chessable
will be Gary's 9 of Sicilian you also
have separin off night or Sicilian which
is a newer one more aggressive you have
Raphael Lido Sicilian adjustable you got
colvic night or phone chestibu you got
all these chestable nightworth Sicilians
right this is the most they call it the
Rolls-Royce of Sicilians it's a really a
nice Sicilian to play lots of tactics
positional and everything that you can
get from a Sicilian Defense I just
learned about every course I'm gonna
have to go get some myself because I
haven't brushed up with a knife in a
while I like to keep things closed so
I'm about to get into those open
positions for sure I'm definitely a big
fan of of course so you guys go get go
to chessable get the free short and
sweets or just buy all the courses go
get all accessible courses especially in
a night or Sicilian or your favorite
Sicilian many different variations and a
lot of fun on all of them
wow love it
that felt like a 101 on Sicilian that
felt like a mini course on the Sicilian
that you and Robert just gave us David
you gotta grade them on that one yeah a
style for presentation guys
but it's amazing that we got to see the
Sicilian I think as commentators we love
it when we see a 1c5 on the board oh we
absolutely do and you know he mentioned
in these gurus of course there's the
most popular course on chesswell he's
still alive in division two by the way
so maybe we'll see some nidor from Geary
oh yeah you've seen Maxine we've seen
Anish come out with those big night owls
but right now of course Hikaru has to
come out with something big as he is
trailing in his match against Fabiano
caruana Fabi takes the lead
is that something that surprise any
surprises any of you absolutely of
course I mean Hikaru just being the
favorite many times in many matches I
mean we start with her to say it was
like yo for the Sea of swinging like he
carves about it on a brink of
elimination and I mean he he was able to
uh to to win that one but with this one
here Fabi starts with a strike there
that's very good especially with the
white pieces that's the way you're
supposed to do it and it was such a
complicated position David it could have
gone either ways yeah for sure just
about 10 15 moves before the end if you
pause there we saw Fabiano with a
slightly worse position and only one
minute on the clock so the fact he
navigated it turned it around and
finished it off very impressive stuff
yeah but now Hikaru starts with the
white pieces that's dangerous Robert
yeah but Fabiana car won extremely well
prepared and with that one game lead yes
hikar is dangerous but I don't even know
what first movie he's gonna play yeah
the bigger question is what is the
festival that black is going to play is
it going to be a sicilian uh definitely
not zero chance coming from assistant no
way so you think he's gonna keep it more
solid well if hikar even plays E4 yes
solidity is the theme of the day and I
think it will serve him well yeah but we
did see Fabi struggled that with the
clock situation he's got to be a little
careful on that yeah if you keep
struggling like that he's going to give
you Carl lots of chances absolutely of
course he was lucky enough that that
position was very tactical he was able
to calculate him for calculation over
everything he's a healing calculator
right he was able to calculate his way
through that with a little bit of time
that he had on the clock here but in
this next one or these next few matches
in these next few games if he's too low
on time and hikar was definitely going
to be able to strike him he had a huge
time engine car what that is and you
cannot give him this every single game
I wanna he needs to score at least one
point to level that score David what's
the strategy in such a situation do you
stop the bleeding or do you take your
chances with white
I think you have to take your chances
you can't just take a time out you can't
just allow your opponent to get one step
closer to that Finishing Line and uh
yeah Hikaru he's gonna go for it here
and now if he can smiling he looks like
he's in a good mood yeah that's not a
that's not a happy that's not that was
more of a I can't believe I messed that
up I'm a when you see Fabiano he's
heating up both on the chessboard and
literally I'm pretty sure that's a heat
pad and I wonder if there's some Mortal
Kombat because he might have taken
artemi of soul and started playing like
him in time travel get over here and you
know Bobby well Robert you know Fabi
well you called it out
to the king spawn opening he starts with
E5 and we have got a Roy Lopez a Spanish
on the board yeah Spanish with an early
D3 so this last Pawn push that white has
made prevents Fabiana from capturing a
pawn in the center of the board going
into very forcing lines Hikaru may be
trying to dodge some early exchanges and
Fabi looked away for a second there he
looked a bit annoyed at himself maybe
he's okay looking down this time maybe
he's just not predicted correctly Hikaru
nakamura's opening strategy but it's
rock solid for black of course you've
got this nice solid structure you can
just get developed get your pieces out
castle that black king and it can't be
too bad white does have nice space now
it's that Phoenix structure you
mentioned earlier James with the white
pawns on e4 D3 uh C4 making that nice
little triangle with that nice little B
there and uh what do you think I think
this is I think this is a new a newer
type of Roy that you will see here you
usually don't see with the C4 I mean
that's just one that is played rarely
but it is it has some Venom to it
because it stops B5 the problem is we
can't actually go D4 the way we want to
because obviously uh the forest is on
clamp right now by uh the black pieces
right so usually I'm actually surprised
by this Choice from 5v2 as well by
playing the D6 is usually uh more of an
aggressive player and with the Roy he
plays more of the Archangel variations
with an early Bishop to she's to C5 has
tons of great games with that so
definitely different here you went for
the more uh slow slightly not passive
but slightly uh worse because of the the
structure here and Etc but I think it's
it's interesting that Hikaru played the
c44 line here trying to maybe take him
out of prep he did look down like Bobby
looked down and was like looked away
like wasn't expecting this one so I
think that's a good choice for me Carl
yeah it feels like Fabius freestyling
slightly I'm pretty sure Fabi would be
happy on the white side of this position
with the black side slightly cramped
maybe less so and uh for Hikaru it's a
win in terms of opening strategy just
because he's kept all the pieces on the
board and that's uh step one if you want
to win a game and while we're deep in
the action here in division one I just
want to give a shout out to Vladimir
Chrome Nook I keep updating you on the
match he had with Maxine and it turns
out after Maxime he lost on time he
disconnected in a drawn position that
would have won in the match Vladimir
Comics said we don't have to go to
Armageddon I concede the match to you
you would have won fair and square so
great sportsmanship by both these two
players and I think they deserve a
tremendous shout out from everybody so
Maxima Sherlock moves on in division two
but both players they are real champions
wow what a guy gave him the match and
just because he did so here you go bro
you take it right I mean it just tells
you the character of these guys right
that's that's fire yeah you can still be
a gentleman even if you're a world
champion and a nice touch there from
Vladimir kramnik uh yeah well played to
both of them and uh degrava does
progress to the final of the winners
bracket in division two meanwhile uh
this one's still a maneuvering phase
last move just defending everything I
think Fabi here would love a trade of at
least one set of minor pieces because
he's a bit cramped uh black lacking
space here so uh any traits would free
up his position somewhat meanwhile
Hikari just ready to kind of improve his
pieces at will every move slightly
improves the scope and eventually we
will see the position open but yeah who
who will take that first step in terms
of clock times very much as expected
Hikaru slightly ahead at this early
stage
quite a closed position right now and
we've been talking about breaks while
one of the central brakes that white
does have potentially in the position is
to strike with that deep pawn and that's
something that you've got to always
watch out for is Fabi in this kind of a
position ever thinking about a king Side
Pawn roll move that night away start
pushing that pawn in front of the Rook
is that an idea that Hikaru needs to
watch out for
this is more of a king's indian-esque I
mean it feels like a king's Indian with
just a knight on C6 it actually is sort
of the same structure you have a bishop
on G7 the Knight on F6 right the the the
pawn on E5 right now the Knight on C6 is
a little bit different but you do have
that option of playing Knight H7 as
David pointed out or 98 sometimes even
Knight H5 but you have to be careful
because the queen is x-raying through
the Knight on F3 so you may have
problems if you play F5 and try to take
back with the pawn the Knight on H5 may
have some issues there so the sword of
King's Indian s here but you do have to
be careful because this is not a case in
here it is pieces are a little bit
different but you can play it uh
definitely a king's Indian like yeah
you've got a break we do just before the
center gets blocked before black can go
for that type of play uh Hikaru he
strikes forward with uh Pawn to C5 and
yes maybe he's allowing some porn traits
but he's saying my pieces are more ready
than yours and for example if fabionic
captures this Pawn the white Bishop will
step forward read capture and now again
questions do you step forward why white
has more Central pawns white has the
pawn breaks and as we know often you
prefer your chances if you have access
to these types of moves maybe you start
getting ready first maybe the white Rook
slides across the white Bishop steps
back on the same diagonal as the black
king plenty of options plenty of
flexibility and 500 instead chooses
symmetry Above All Else he says you know
I just want to keep this position close
for now I do not want to give Hikaru an
extra point in the center of the board
and this is what the players can do
there's this tension between the D6 and
C5 pods as the car shuffles his Rook
over to C1 he's anticipating the opening
of that file he can choose when that
happens but look at Fabiano's Foundation
it's very solid here there are no more
inroads I don't know what movie makes I
don't see a plan for him but I just
don't see how white crashes through if
you were to give Hikaru a free turn or
three yeah it's fascinating this tension
it's like both sides want that capture
to happen but they want it on their own
terms black wants it on their own terms
in terms of white making that trade
white uh kind of making the pawn
structure symmetrical black is saying
okay I don't want to take you because
then you get more Central points and I
think that's just good conventional
wisdom for chess uh fans in general
don't trade unless you really have to
unless it's on your terms it has to be
either forced or fantastic for your
position and uh I see so many players
who are new to the game they see a trade
they go for it just because they assume
it makes the position more simple and as
I say that
Knight H5 and we live he's trying to go
Knight F4 for the score baby you want to
put that boy right on F4 and even uh
there's a Gary Kasparov quote this that
says uh a knight on F5 wins games right
so you know it doesn't actually win the
game but what he's saying here is it's
just very close into the position and
very annoying to face which is uh hence
the move Knight D5 I'm going to snap
that Knight off F4 as fast as you put it
there because Knight F4 will be very
annoying with some type of attack on the
king side
that you consider anyway because after a
trade you do end up opening that Bishop
on G7 and we know what a monster that
Bishop can be on the long diagonal also
targeting that Queen side weakness so a
big decision critical moment here for
Fabi to decide if it's worth it to
destroy the pawn structure but in return
open up your Bishop yeah big gamble here
the downside is that white does have
Central pawns and it will rest on the
fact that white maybe can stop this Pawn
forward if black can strike now on these
two Central pawns then of course you can
go for this but if not then you have to
avoid this and wow okay he moves his
Bishop he's allowing his own structure
to be shattered here Fabi but uh if the
bishop captures the Knight The White
Knight will be forced back and maybe
then the Black Knight can jump in maybe
not the right direction as well yeah the
B2 Pawn as well maybe you drop back in
this direction before I was thinking
hacking some pawns but oh it's risky
these top players don't like giving up
their Bishop half but hikar is clearly
thinking about it look at his face it's
an ugly continuation and it first looks
like it's ugly for black because those
Pawns but if black were to ever stepped
the queen up one to protect the pawn you
also threatened Bishop takes H3 as a
sacrifice with Knight F4 to follow this
is standard attacking style for black
and pawn structure is often overrated
Daniel naritzki Donya says all the time
that that's maybe one of the things that
people talk about too much in chess is
how the pawn structure looks it may be
aesthetically unpleasing for black but
tactically I think it is quite dangerous
very dangerous uh I know there's some
famous quotes out there by former world
champions it's like forget porn
structure Checkmate ends the game please
forget that I forget that quite often
I'm so carried away with all these
little details these nuances the uh the
way the position looks but I forget to
go for checkmate and uh I've lost so
many points because of that and these
top players they're able to switch from
the Strategic uh considerations to the
dynamic and that's why they're so good
uh someone in there as it says on the
feature chat Bobby spending too much
time at the gym he got that thing on his
shoulder there I told him hey look man
you're gonna have to like you know we
can hit the gym but we gotta stretch
before and after make sure your protein
is correct right 80 nutrition I'm gonna
call them I'm gonna call them after this
I'm gonna call them probably gonna have
to get right they're like he has some
pain there but that's okay he is in the
gym so hopefully you're doing the same
chat at home yeah it's because he was
flexing too hard in the last games
no pain no gain
you know but he's he's playing a good
match thus far right game one that was a
game where you would expected hikara to
come out on top he had the lead on the
clock it was his type of position but
Fabiano he held steady when he needed to
he kept actually uh sitting on the clock
as well and he did not flag he did not
fall on they're too much time to rest
and here in game two he's playing great
moves he's countering White's jumps in
the center and Hikaru needs to win
that's the problem he doesn't
necessarily need to win this game but he
needs to get back on the scoreboard and
that puts all the pressure on akara
Nakamura
yeah he can't lose Hikaru if he loses
he's on the brink so Bishop takes Knight
for example the move we were discussing
earlier it's risky it imbalances things
as Robert pointed out black has the
foundations the skeleton of an attack
against the white king potentially
especially if that Black Knight on the
edge of the board gets into that dream
F4 square that uh James was pointing out
leaning in what is he what is he seeing
in the position he's definitely
calculating some lines there he's seeing
something that we don't maybe exactly
that's scary will he lean in like that a
lot of times he's like oh shoot okay
hold on but I mean really hey the
Fabiano's playing this position very
well but should be six was a move I
think he did not anticipate here because
you have to make some type of concession
you got to do something now you either
take on C6 and if you move this Knight
the Knight F4 is definitely going to be
coming so you have to do something right
now so that's why he's he's using his
time now to figure this thing out I mean
if you try to defend the Knight Bishop
B3 I mean he takes the Knight right on
D5 and then he puts the other he comes
back with Knight F4 I mean once again
that Knight on F4 is extremely strong
super annoying right in this case so
we're gonna see we come comes up with in
a few minutes here yeah he's about to
make a decision his hand is back on the
mouse and wow he Retreats immediately
wow not going for that trade of pieces
first but this feels like a step in the
wrong direction after a capture we don't
see uh any complications yet it's just a
trade but there is a threat against that
black rook and Fabby deals with it
easily that black knight is coming in
and that was a nice trick David if you
can just back up and you can show us why
Hikaru did not have the time to actually
pick up that Rook on it when Fabi traded
the knights yeah yeah he could not
capture this Rook because Fabi does have
time for an intermediate move there are
actually a few moves here there's a bit
of choice but maybe the simplest is to
take this Pawn with the Knight and now
this is a fork a double attack and this
bishop of course is loose as well yes
white is up a rook for minor piece right
now but that would last long so uh here
uh Fabi did have the time after Bishop
takes Knight to just solidify just to
block this threat and now as we
mentioned this Knight is coming in how
do you prevent that if you're Hickory
camera not easy anymore and whoa he
takes a time out to push his Pawn he
said I don't care about none of that
he's like yeah yeah put the Knight on F4
were you about to show us because I'm
definitely putting that I don't have
four drop it in and this is a monster
threat Knight takes porn backed up
protected by the black queen he puts his
Rook on a really weird Square to defend
but I fear for Hikaru it definitely
feels like this is the position where it
could spiral out of control if black can
just move his Queen get the Rook into
the game this opponent is a massive
Target that's very simple Queen D7 I
also like you know we like aggression G5
and then G4 and it takes right and then
I mean it even opens up lines here Queen
F6 Queen G6 is there too as well the
fact that hey you're in a pin you can be
pinned here G5 G4 is nice Queen D7 is
nice I mean there's all kind of stuff
here yeah looking good for black I've
got to say Robert what do you think no I
don't like this at all for a car and I
think part of it is the match score he
really needs to get this game I think
he's feeling that pressure because
Fabiano extremely well prepared you need
to maximize your chances game one did
not go hit Cara's way despite the good
good position and the lead on the clock
here in game two Fabiano has no problems
whatsoever not just on the board but
also on the clock with the downfall that
could have been in game one was on the
clock he's keeping steady there his
position is better he has more activity
he's more Harmony between his pieces of
White's Bishops over there on the queen
side they're not really doing anything
not threatening anything whereas black
May sacrifice a bishop on H3 for an
attack and the pawn on D3 is backwards
and threatened by numerous black pieces
I think the next few moves should be
quite easy for Fabiano to play and I
like the start I like this first move
kicking back white start Square Bishop
from its active post just say Karu okay
he steps back now I wouldn't be
surprised if another Pawn follows there
we go play with the momentum you step
back I step forward and uh all of those
white Bishops being kicked now Hikari
trying to trade things off but suddenly
there's stuff to calculate suddenly
there are tactics in the air and I'm
wondering whether Fabi can get greedy
here to try and grab a pawn some tricks
oh I'm trying to work this out what do
we think here there are some tricks to
take but then if you take on D3 I mean
is there a rook D1 but then they C5 this
is sick what is going on here yeah this
is the first thing you calculate right
it works great you win a pawn if it
doesn't you can rule it out and move on
to more positional uh decisions Knight
takes Pawn Rook to D1 it looks like a
pin and here I just stopped here the
Knight can Retreat attacking the White
Queen and I thought okay this is too
complicated let's let her family work it
out but I guess the whole uh kind of
evaluation here rest upon Rook takes
Queen Knight takes Queen and we head to
the end game and at the very end white
does take this Pawn so I'm not sure that
that would have been a good idea Fabby
says nope don't want to calculate it why
not Advance all these pawns forward look
at the pawn storm incoming on the queen
side wow it's like Space Invaders over
here they're going forward and they're
actually creating threats because now
the pawn on D3 is actually under attack
and black and pushed the B Pawn push
that forward to it kick that Bishop out
of its nice perch on C3 so I feel like
Fabiano just gaining ground in this
position we saw Hikaru drop back to
defend that pawn on D3 but that is a
permanent weakness it's what we call a
backwards Pawn you cannot push it
forward and a pawn can't defend it so
this is a big problem for Hikaru
strategically Fabiano caruana planting
that night on F4 a pawn star on the
Queen's side this is the second game in
a row where Fabi Has Come On Top after
the opening phase of the game currently
the clock is level Fabiano putting the
pressure on Hikaru he's definitely
feeling the heat right now James well
100 he's feeling the heat here he
actually needs to kick this Knight off
for f42 as well I mean I think I
remember even Robert talking about
halves of the board which is very
important to understand like this Knight
is on the half of the board right side
of the board and this Knight is very
strong right so you need to kick it
there's something in fact at a panchenko
book actually I was talking about in
mastering middle games this was actually
one of them I think it was in a
prophylaxis chapter but it was about
King H2 and you've seen karpov do this
King H2 and petrogen actually the king
H2 Knight to G1 and you play G3 you kick
the Knight away and then eventually you
start pushing forward but that takes
some time and you have to do this
because this Knight is so annoying you
have to kick it away yeah is that is
that super important for Hikaru right
now to get rid of that Knight on F4 I
think it's important but it's also very
difficult to do we just saw by James
denounce it takes a few moves to get
that done and even once you kick the
Knight out of there you still have other
problems across the board that pawn on
D3 long term weakness that I mentioned
black and continue pushing pawns on the
queen side we saw him play A4 look at
Fabiano he's just saying you're not
going to push any of your pawns you're
not going to gain control of key squares
I'm going to push when I'm good and
ready and the position looks excellent
for black on the queen side as well you
said you're not going to push any of
your pawns Hikaru launches it by putting
pushing the pawn on the king side H4 on
the board is this bravery or desperation
I think it's a bit of desperation and it
needed to be done it's similar to what
James pointed out the white king could
have also gone to H2 basically identical
the plan it was to kick back this Black
Knight but now the Black Knight is going
to relocate itself into the center and
still this is maximum control this is
domination I've got to say from Fabiana
caruana he's just controlled all of the
important squares in the center all of
the pawnbricks at White's disposal and
white is stuck white has to play purely
with his pieces while black is going to
start ganging up against the weaknesses
that Robert has pointed out I'm looking
at that white Depot and that backward
Pawn easy target all of the black Brooks
are actually going to line up against
that weakness and they might well just
overwhelm nakamura's defenses he does
not look happy at all Hikaru right now
with his position the ugly position very
ugly position and uncharacteristic in a
way from Hikaru here I mean really Bobby
is taking it to him in this match right
now something that we all expected uh
Hikaru to be just better here but in
fact Fabi is is turning it on its head
he's also doing great on time from the
previous game and he was down so much
time now you know he's doing way better
on time here with the black pieces too
as well and really trying to assert the
dominance here and say hey look you're
going to be very close to elimination if
you lose this game yeah Carl is creating
a bit of a mess here right now he is
provoking Fabi on the king side it's
going to be a bad idea to capture that
pawn yes it's a free Pawn but you can't
afford to give a nice Square to the
White Knight so hey Carl here Robert
really trying to make the position as
messy as he can he is he's doing a good
job of it as you're saying if you take
that pawn think about the squares that
are left behind anytime a pawn moves the
squares that were previously under
control no longer that's what GTX H5
will be met by Knight H4 into F5 that's
a light Square you have a dark sword
Bishop it means you can't compete with
it and that's going to be a problem so
there's no way Fabiano is going to take
that pawn he has two options either he
pushes his Pawn forward in the starting
position so your Knight's not getting
over there even if I weaken the square
or he says what's the big deal you're
actually you take me on G6 I take back
that opens up the f file and maybe I can
use that with attacking chances so I
feel like Bobby he slides his Rook over
he understands it's not the end of the
world to see that capture the I said E5
Pawn you're not gonna be able to attack
it very simply yeah yeah and uh
Potential Threat on the board the Knight
could jump in due to some tension now
between the BlackRock and the White
Queen so hinting at something along that
line hikara instantly drops back and
still the tension remains between these
two pawns I'm not sure what I would do
to be honest I would love to push this
Pawn forward but long term you could
imagine the White Knight somehow
sneaking into this square and uh
punishing you later it takes a while to
get there but uh all these top players
they're hesitant to create those
long-term weaknesses and uh Fabi again
just keeping control not changing the
Status Quo defends the pawns with his
King the one thing I do see potentially
going wrong for Fabi is after the white
king steps up some Brooks or Queens are
sliding across if things do open up the
black king maybe not entirely safe but
uh yeah for now it's all under control
and the white Knights actually jump
jumped back I'm not sure where it's
going from there but uh maybe opening up
a path for the White Queen
yeah Hikaru it's hustle mode I feel like
and he wants to at least scare Fabi with
some ideas
I don't even know where we're going what
is the idea this is a sub maybe King G2
Knight G4 like you mentioned or like
with the uh the idea of Queen H1 or
something like that this is very hard to
make anything work in this position I
don't have any pawn breaks right so I
can't play F4 it's on lock the only
thing I have is like the H file my Rook
is strangely placed on E3 I do have to
defend the D3 Pawn because it's backward
um I'm always worried about a B4 push at
some point I have to move the bishop out
of the way then the D4 Square opens up
and it's annoying now A4 will be hanging
in some cases there so maybe I would
like that but here it's definitely
difficult for white so to make some
ground here I hope if I'm white I'm like
Bobby please keep thinking right because
like so you can get lower on time and
that's when you start to make mistakes
yeah but that's the big question what
you just said that is B4 a possibility
or not and James you called it Fabi
agrees it is time to push that pawn put
pressure and control the D4 Square for
his own night but now he's gonna watch
out for that A4 Pawn which is a little
tender yeah look in a car he drops that
Bishop back to E1 he does so quickly
that's the most important thing he's
doing you look at the clock the two
minute Advantage for the moment and
Fabiano he has a nice position but the
A4 Pawn is targeted he might need to
defend he says no I don't need to but
can I grab it I'm not sure why not
exactly he's grabbing and then what's
the next move I have five I don't
understand what did you what are you
doing okay okay Queen D1 I'll take take
yes
take the juicer right we have the juice
yeah this would be the outcome of all
that uh taking or that uh little
transformation that and at the very end
black does have active pieces so okay
rather than investigate this Hikaru has
simply put his Rook on a newfound
Outpost this C4 Square wasn't previously
available to White and cannot be
challenged by Black's pieces nice little
move and this one is not going anywhere
anytime soon still a target for later on
that was a great move that was great
yeah no it looks good I mean James just
using a square that was previously
unavailable and now I feel like black
he's on the clock again yeah yeah he's
back on the clock again Rook C4 was very
nice he's also attacking B4 for real
like I'm going to take it twice and
actually get my pieces active A4 is
hanging you go B3 A4 still hangs that
actually is a very nice move it was very
precise here and you need these of
course these counter punching moves or
Tempe you know a Tempo extra time right
you need this and that was a time
grabbing move there and it also makes
poppy think here Rick C4 was very nice
we do have to deal with the B4 Pawn
actually hanging now
to push those pawns but is it done right
now
I think the position objective is okay
for black but it is starting to get into
scary territory because you had
everything under control but the last
couple moves have gone White's way your
Pawn is hanging directly on B4 and on A4
White's rook and queen they're teaming
up on those pawns and black you don't
just want to go defensive in this
position so fabi's played very well to
this point but the trajectory is going
in hikara's favor yeah it was the last
game the moment the momentum the
trajectory was going up and down up and
down and here it's all been Fabby until
the last few moves he's lost control and
now he steps back with his Queen we're
all leaning forward is he not just
losing opponent is he not coming up
before yes it is I think it's just about
activity just trying to keep your pieces
active yeah
giving up at this point it can be taken
immediately here and now and uh okay why
not just go for it what is the big idea
is it that uh here for example there are
tricks the Knight would now jump in with
a double attack if white takes the other
way however uh then there might also be
tricks I'm looking for them now I don't
see anything immediately but it feels
like there's tension between the Queens
after Rook takes Rook there's no way you
can jump the night out effectively to
attack this White Queen it looks a bit
scary before it looks a bit loose but
you are a pawn up and there's a lack of
coordination between the B2 and C4 Pawn
so this is what strong players do they
give up material saying it's not the end
of the world for me to be down upon look
at all of the Practical play I get the
C4 Pawn is loose the B2 Pawn will also
be a Target I think that's what Fabiano
is relying on maybe just Queen C6 Rook
C8 team up on that C4 pawn and perhaps
there's no way to defend especially with
that White Knight on H2 it's out of play
very strong he doesn't go for it instead
he makes a small little move on the king
side just stepping up with the king so
easy to even miss that this move has
happened on the board doesn't pick up
the B4 Pawn avoids the complication and
now Fab he shuts it down on the queen
side yeah now Fabi has a beautiful
Square for the Black Knight to jump into
really disturbing the harmony between
White's pieces maybe Hikaru being too
brave there just keeping the tension one
move too uh too long and the top plates
they're not greedy they prioritize peace
activity over everything uh other than
calculation
but yeah suddenly fabi's got control
again what do we think
yeah that's exactly where I think Fabi
definitely has control now you may have
had to try to go for that Palm but maybe
Rob had a great point there of course so
you just give up the pawn you should you
may be getting the backline pieces are
so active here I mean in this position I
feel like I'm just suffering now I mean
look at this past this boy has passed
and then if Knight C2 happens I mean
that's super annoying maybe exactly
exchange but that's not necessary like
it's my pieces just feel very strange
here but I mean okay A4 we couldn't
argue that A4 is very weak the queen is
tied to it right now we also have C5
that maybe we can attack at some point
um it's gonna be difficult but chances
for both sides here definitely I think
Bobby has a slight Edge yeah can Fabi
try and reroute that Bishop make that
dark Squad Bishop a little active bring
it to G5 somehow I see the Rooks that
Hikaru has and it just feels like
they're a little shaky there it's gonna
sound weird but I think Fabian doesn't
want to win the game not that he's
trying not to if it presents himself but
he just wants to make a draw he
understands with a full point lead in
this match he'll get white in game three
he could end the match with the draw
here and then a win with white in game
three but he can play it safe but
likeliest outcome between two top jams
is a draw so why take unnecessary risk
and the position is closed now Hikaru
himself didn't want to capture that pawn
because it felt like it actually allowed
Fabiano to make an easier path towards
equality with some liquidation with some
easier moves especially in time travel
but we see a backfire a car is already
in for a deep think and his position I
think is worse than fabianos yeah the
main thing is not to lose control if
you're Fabiano and of course he's lost
control slightly compared to what he had
earlier he's slightly behind on the
clock but things are moving back in his
direction we mentioned the momentum
going up and down it was all Fabby and
suddenly Hikaru now back to Fabi and
that is a very positive thing for him
but okay the nitrate imminent now white
hoping to be able to capture Knights
Black's night is of course his strongest
piece does Fabi say yes or no to that
which one Hikaru which one is Hikaru
gonna fear most keeping Knights on the
board or trading them off
big question now yeah big question and
there was a big question in chat that I
saw we've been talking about all the
trumps in fabi's position and chat wants
to know what is a good plan here for
Fabi position looks great but what's
next
good question improve the pieces it's
very much moved by move and you very
much have to adapt react to your
opponent's ideas too so this last move
you have to react if you're Fabi either
you agree to the nitrate and you have to
weigh up the pros and cons there or you
do jump in we mentioned a very juicy
Square for the Black Knight on C2 a few
moments ago and you can jump in game
time there we go there it is
and uh call David yeah the white Rook
has to step back it's trapped unless you
sacrifice but I don't think you'll get
enough compensation there
maybe oh it is a bit sad retreating
though so what do we think here is he
gonna sacrifice Rook for night he's
thinking about it Hikaru he's definitely
thinking about it because there's
something that we've forgotten about and
I think the players might have forgotten
about that pawn on H5 that Rook Pawn
that's all the way over there it can be
captured right if the Rook goes back to
E2 maybe it's time just take this Pawn
on H5 because yes your knight can go to
H4 but then I'm gonna play Bishop F6
I've cleared some of the path in front
of the black king and maybe it's the
white king that's going to be in grave
danger so I actually think Fabiano oh
he's done it his captain
wow he might be going for the white king
suddenly switching Focus completely I
forgot about this side of the board I
assume that tension will be there until
the end of time but uh suddenly black
could be the one throwing pawns forward
do you want a pawn why not give it back
open up the white king and look at this
the white king under huge trouble this
Black Knight on its own paralyzes at
least three of white pieces and you
switch focus and go for checkmate
looking good for blood and then make it
hard backwards to kick that white knight
out of there as well so I feel like
black is just holding all the cards here
this is not a fun position for Hikaru
and I'm a little bit surprised by
Fabiano's last move but he's just going
for the brute force method he's going
for this D3 Pawn they're actually
tactics in the air because the neon C2
could also capture that Bishop on you
want at some moment it's a very very
careful if your car
talking bad for Hikaru he's just lost a
pawn and I don't see a way to actually
defend the second Pawn either you could
fall back with that Rook to C3 to keep
it protected but it's not a happy move
the C Pawn can potentially Advance down
the board putting more pressure on that
pinned D3 Pawn is this how bad is this
for Hikaru this position oh this is ugly
this is very ugly you don't see this
type of vikaru all the time usually
you're used to a car dominating having
good positions or having chances you
know what I mean like it felt like I
think he had a strategy here in a way of
like you know Fabiano that is of like
actually just keeping things very solemn
sort of a Wesley so type thing here well
like I mean there's yes there's tactics
but at the right moment we go for the
tactics I mean both positions have been
like positional masterpieces from
Fabiano it feels like here I mean very
good position there were slight tactics
in this game but I mean everything's
locked down look at the control same way
in the last game he had a knight that
was controlling all the pieces right the
night in the pawns on the queen side of
the board and then we moved to the other
side same situation here put the Knight
on C2 everything's clamped down and he's
going to the other side he's just
playing on both sides of the board he's
playing brilliantly right now the car
with the head shake on in a minute 30
here I mean this is rough this is very
rough yeah I'm slightly surprised that
the evaluation bar is not drastically in
Black's favor it's slightly in Black's
favor if I uh if I sing it correctly but
there must be a way for Hikaru to keep
the game going at the moment we all seem
to think he's about to lose a second
pawn and no compensation but where is uh
yeah where is that idea there must be
something sneaky so what happens on rig
D2 like what whatever
you said I mean he was like no please
Dodge it and you were thinking the same
Bishop can slide up to G5 targeting that
Rook on D2 but instead Hikaru actually
hits fabi's Rook on d8 but he still has
time to pick up the D3 pawn and he does
it it's an end game with two extra Pawns
of Abby Fabiano caruana has won nine
games against the car who lost 16 games
to him Hikaru considered by many a
favorite in this format but Fabi so far
dominating this match yeah dominating he
is two pawns up however I will say that
black does have some weaknesses black
has those doubled H pawns which don't
make a great impression also don't
forget about that black a pawn the white
Rook on the fourth rank is gonna go and
grab it at some point maybe not yet but
uh that one is on tap for later so I
think it's just about keeping control we
mentioned that word a few times but
now wants to consolidate often
when I watch his streams he's always
saying okay let's just consolidate let's
just keep control let's be solid the
opponent will make a blunder make a
mistake later anyway it's better not to
lose on the spot yes your two pawns down
but it's not the end of the world and uh
okay can Fabi wrap this one up
can he Force things I think that's the
big question if he can't force things
then White's position is actually
strategically sound so uh yeah the
fight's still going on it's a great
point there yeah of course even on down
these ponds I still can get them back I
mean H5 is that's the same Pawn as H6
right so and it's a very weak pawn and
A4 is on top to take at some point so
that's actually a very good point there
um even though I am down some material
right now so there's hope buddy and end
times getting lower for both of them I
mean under a minute for ikaru and Fabi
is very close to being under a minute as
well sort of even on the time there just
a few second difference that was a good
move right there by Hikaru because he
wants to trade Rooks and I think he'll
take with the pawn though he kicks that
Knight out there that Knight is just a
force and in fact he ticked with his
Knight because he wants to head into the
D5 Square it was two difficult choices
there I think he chose the better one in
fact because the A4 Pawn is in The Rook
site we said that a long time ago it's
been sitting there but at long last that
white Rook may be able to take that pawn
on the fourth rank I really don't like
fabi's decision before any trade I ask
myself is my piece better than my
opponent's piece and the Rooks that
disappeared Blacksburg was Super Active
White's Rook was purely passive so that
exchange does not help him at all if you
compare the remaining pieces whites Rook
better than the black rug white tonight
just as good if not better than the
Black Knight and Bishops looks like
White's Bishop pretty decent too so
compensation and white also going for
those Queen side pawns the White Knight
is headed in that direction fabi's
position full of weaknesses I don't
think the two-point Advantage is fully
felt right now uh also the clock time
Fabby behind this time yeah but there's
under a minute but Fabiano 30 seconds
big threat on the board the Knight
jumping onto the queen side attacking
the rook and the A4 Pawn as you pointed
out Fabi steps It Up With The Rook to
stop that idea keeps it under control
Fabi is really holding on to each of
these pawns with their life right now
Tanya check this out probably has no
time he has no time right now
yeah he is threading a night sacrifice
with that move tonight take on A3 in the
past one or even wait whoa he's just
ignored it take that pawn why not he
does 93. there's 93 though that might be
Knight C3 but now the black Rook can
come in I'm not sure which Square you
use
wow okay we didn't go for this the White
Knight holding things together instead
we see Fabi go for a different Pawn now
this bishop is free hitting the white
Rook this Knight is on a nice Square
still two pawns up but how do you deal
with the threat against this bishop you
have to be very calm he guards it with
his King suddenly Anything could happen
here both sides going active but look at
this pawn it could become a queen later
on in the game if white doesn't have
something now this Pawn will win the
game 20 seconds to Fabi there's always a
sacrifice on A3 that Hikaru has to watch
out for he attacks The Rook to have he
attacks The Rook in return
hit him with a move
I'll take yours that was a big blunder
by Fabiano he did not have much time and
that was relentless counter play by
Hikaru Nakamura so right now a car is up
a piece but that B3 Pawn for black it's
very far Advanced so look at fabigo he's
going right after that pawn he wants a
passer of his own if I'll be shaking his
head he doesn't know what the evaluation
of the position is we see that eval Bar
says it's still liquid but in fabi's
head he's just made a big blunder yep he
basically had this exact position but
with an extra Bishop so he's thrown a
bishop off the board and he's still
fighting and uh here he just has to keep
moving keep Pace 10 seconds on the clock
it's not easy but fabi's plan is simple
at least he's going for those white
pawns at least it's one way kind of uh
one track mind right now go for that
what are those white pawns with
everything you've got and the White
Knight is actually trapped back there
that move then I can't get out of here
so maybe the black king will go
backwards and where is that Knight going
to the answer is nowhere and he does it
so actually white might be frozen here
wow yeah what Bishop is stuck defending
pawns the white Rook stuck defending the
White Knight which is trapped white can
only play with the king I saw this
coming Knight A3 and then Rook C1 right
and then now you can't move the road
well you can still move the Knight now
it's coming back right exactly and I'm
getting pawns I'm like hey whatever I'm
about to go get the a pawn oh my
goodness I go grab the a right take on G
and grab maybe there's a B2 push at some
point because the Rook has to go back
for white and that means the night oh my
goodness
with two extra pawns for black but the
king is getting very active
yeah White's King very active two pawns
down though Fabby trying to trade off
trying to mop up and that white a pawn
doomed Forget About It Go Active with
the white king everything's disappearing
I do think white should be just in time
to save this game Rooks pawns are not
the best pawns uh to be pushing when you
want to win but okay nice classy move
down from Hikaru he ties down that black
rook and he guards across the fourth
rank the white king will deal with that
that button the black white Rook will
deal with that one and it should end in
a draw but you still have to be careful
that's true that's true that's the white
king back and it's just in time the
white king will sit in front of that
black pawn and it's to draw look at your
car is so annoyed it's even a draw if
white did not have this F2 Pawn that's
how theoretically drawn it is you could
throw that pawn off the board it doesn't
matter the white Rook will go back and
forth the king does not take that pawn
if that King ever took the pawn though
black Rook would leave with check along
the first Rank and then black would
promote yeah
because there and exactly what you're
talking about uh Robert with that it
ends and wow Hikaru looked a little
angry at the end but I have to say he
has to be relieved he was in so much
trouble so much pressure that even after
Fabi blundered an entire piece it was
still fine for Fabi and Ricardo there
probably a laughter of relief he knows
he still stays in the game but such an
epic fight and that's what we see in his
expression after all those complications
after all that navigating through the
scramble that we just saw it was a big
fight ended with a draw David what a
game take it take us through it yeah
what a game and in the end it was a tale
of two blunders first it was Fabi from a
dominant position he blundered a piece
it was here maybe he thought that his
Rook was trapped there's actually not
too many safe squares for this piece he
needed to bring it the whole way across
the board black is two pawns up and
should go on to win this game not an
easy move to find instead however he
dropped his Knight back forgetting
perhaps that this attack from the white
Rook could be evaded with a capture Rook
takes bishop and if the Rook is taken
now white has time to gobble up the
black Rook emerging with an extra Bishop
if we fast forward a few moves we see
that Hikaru also blundered a piece here
the White Knight could get out the way
could start running back dropping back
with a check instead he pushed a pawn
forward and maybe forgot that the black
pawn could step forward deflecting away
the white Rook from the defense of this
Knight so many twists and turns a roller
coaster draw in the end
indeed a roller coaster really nicely
explained that end game David and with
that nail biting finish what an up and
down moment it was it finally ends in a
peaceful result a game that wasn't
peaceful at any moment and with that
Fabiano caruana still keeps his lead in
the match against Hikaru Nakamura one
and a half to half Hikaru has to win a
game the next game Hikaru starts with
the black pieces he's got one more white
left in the match can he do it we will
find out on the other side of the twitch
break
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bowtest
sisters come on
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this position white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
foreign
I'm from Israel I am one Grandmaster
also chat streamer YouTuber content
creator and here I am as a participant
of Reykjavik open 2023. when I play
openings when I study open is when I
choose the opening lines for myself I
definitely prioritize the the logic
behind the moves the connection between
pieces some Harmony I try to create
Harmony on the chessboard so obviously
today seeing my point playing King F7
kinship 16g5 was not making any sense so
I was just trying to find a way to
punish my opponent for that and that's
why I sacrificed the piece just because
it was logical it was making sense you
know the opponent was not developing
pieces and you know the rule number one
for openings develop your pieces and
Castle my opponent in the castle today
he got punished for it
a fantastic performance at the Reykjavik
open by women Grandmaster Dina balenkaya
she gains 28 reading points along the
way defeating two grand Masters we saw
Fabi employ the King of the Hill taking
his King up to G4 but when Dina's
opponent did that it didn't end too well
for him James yeah that was Gregory
actually in fact he has two chessable
courses in fact
one on uh both on e4 I mean I was like
oh yeah Greg's playing like Gregory
that's nice and then I saw he put his
King on G6 and H5 and I was like he has
lost his absolute right what is he doing
and Dina punished him for
what a game that was and what a game two
it was between these two players and now
the pressure is really on Hikaru
Nakamura with the black pieces Robert
what is his approach in this one keep it
solid go all out in the next one so for
everybody who was not here in the studio
I was saying probably don't play a
sicilian's five Mana karwana but he says
if Magnus Carlson does it it's probably
a good idea he's playing the same exact
opening that Magnus chose against Wesley
so and here you see Fabiano sitting in
for a think he plays the same Pawn push
we'll see how quickly he follows up
because Wesley went in for a two-minute
Journey after this and probably plays
instantly yeah and he's got his mind on
his face because both of them know that
this has happened and earlier in the day
today I have a feeling hikarinos I don't
know Fabio no you think so he was
watching the show yeah he he sent me
some messages ah okay
behind the scenes inside info there nice
oh I forgot they weren't playing at the
same time of course yeah staggered
starts and uh okay Pawn sacrifice who
has done their homework better that's
the question so rather than a capture of
knights a trade of knights in the center
that we saw earlier in that game between
Fabio uh between Fabiano between Wesley
so and Magnus Carson Fabby has dropped
his Bishop back that feels like there
should be some tricks against the black
king black is very severely
underdeveloped white is already castled
but uh I don't see anything yet how is
he gonna justify this Pawn sacrifice
yeah I don't understand this this
project race does not feel correct it's
just usually when you do pawn sacrifices
you have rapid development like gambits
right of course Queen's Gambit is not a
real Gambit in a way because you get
that pawn back many times Scotch Gambino
Scotch Gambit one of my favorites right
you know you get you get rapid
development and you get things back here
I don't see us getting that pawn back I
mean I was looking at 9g file I was like
oh maybe Knight G5 but then 96. it just
stops everything and then okay C3 but
then I take the Knight on F3 take back
and I defend the mate and I'm up upon so
I don't understand this but upon
sacrifice here I was like maybe there
has to be something with
a knight takes E5 Bishop F7 but you're
sacking two pieces for that I don't even
understand what this is about so this is
a very weird Pawn sacrifice that we're
going to see we need to see the
justification for what's even more weird
is that Fabiano caruana gives up a pawn
and then goes into a think tank he
should be on Blitz mode right now I am
worried Sabi not very prepared in this
position it's possible that they saw
this line and hikar's like this looks
interesting if I need to win a game with
black I'm going to take that pawn and
run with it and Bob Brown was like well
this can't be a serious line Magnus is
just being Magnus he's playing dodgy
stuff he'd look at five minute ago he
goes Knight G5 all the fried liver
attack he's going for F7 this is a
principal way to play and one of the big
questions that white must have is he has
firm control over the D5 square the
square right behind that Knight that's
blocking the White Queen so do you put a
knight on that square do you kick them
out with Pawn to C3 there's one of these
big questions that need to be answered
but first things first hikarity is a
defended F7 Pawn Yeah
spend it for your life there's two ways
James mentioned one dropping back that
black knight from the center to block
the white light squared Bishop's
diagonal or you can bring out your own
Knight the undeveloped Knight to the
edge of the board the second one looks
ugh ugly flimsy uh gross yeah that's a
good word for it but uh Hikaru I'm
slightly surprised that he's pausing now
because this is the most natural move
for white in the position so if 96 like
what happens after 96 this is a question
I mean I was trying to get F4 to work
try to open the f file but I mean I feel
like I'm giving up a second part now we
saw what happened we gave up all the
Pawns in the other game with Wesley so
this wasn't working so
no I don't know it works I mean the
engine is like hey you can do it okay
well that might be it then F4 I just
don't know what happens after Pawn takes
nighties no but then I don't understand
maybe bishop E6 whoa I've cheated here
I've checked the engine do you want to
know what white plays here in this
position Knight F7 boom Knight takes F7
and you just play six just give up a
piece get out of here that's too much
the game goes on you're a piece down but
look at this black king out in the open
and of course the engine says 0.0 so
this could have been some preparation
instead Hikaru maybe scared of this
brings his Knight to the edge of the
board but this looks superficial yes you
defend this Pawn but long term now white
will have great compensation because
there's one terrible piece in the black
camp this Knight is stranded it's not
where it wants to be yes it's defending
but uh I think white here is going to be
very happy nice Outpost this is the
square you mentioned earlier Robert on
D5 and he's gonna get the best of both
worlds he's gonna bring his own Knight
forward and then kick the Black Knight
out of the center that's the good thing
when you don't push your pawns too early
then after the night goes into D5 there
the white pong go up to C3 black cannot
kick the Knight out of D5 there's no
Pawn to attack it with whereas white can
attack that black knight sitting
healthily in the center so I actually
think this is a very Dynamic game I
think both players are not particularly
well prepared and put that air quotes
this is not a regular position it's not
typical of the top level chess and James
maybe we need a chessful course on this
exact variation I'm gonna say I'm gonna
look it up I'll cook something though
I'll cook something up for it yeah I'm
definitely in my adjustable of course
grind right now grinding and I'm making
them eating them sleeping right with
them next to the bed every day okay
every single day here so it is
definitely a spicy Pawn sacrifice that I
am not too familiar with so it looks
cool I like the queen H5 type ideas the
queen H5 you see this a lot and really
well this isn't before opening so you
see this a lot in like fried livers and
night G5 with Bishop C4 you put the
queen on H5 to attack F7 and and keep
him pinned down here and then you just
bring every piece to the party it
sacrifices and F4 or open up lines and
diagonals for the pieces so that we're
able to uh to win this game yeah it
looks like Queen H5 is just that feels
good but maybe there's a oh yeah yeah
you can't play D5 I was thinking about
Bishop G4 in there but yeah Queen H5
might be straight I just love these
ideas it brings back memories of playing
like these under 10 championships
players just put they're not in G5 they
go for checkmate they don't care about
anything else and that's the strategy
that Fabiana is embracing here he
noticed that wind would clinch the match
for him so why not go for the kill James
mentioned the White Queen coming out
dropping that white knight in the center
as well the D5 Outpost super tempting uh
some beautiful moves here but you are
report down so you need to be quite
accurate very energetic to keep the
initiative going you also get nabbed
upon on C2 too as well Queen H5 you
don't have anything immediate so when
he's five he could take on C2 you move
the Rook then he goes back and you like
down two pawns and you still have to
justify the fact I mean the engine says
it's not even that bad I think it's an
initiative I have everything developed
like this is super Gambit in a way just
gameting everything here but then maybe
bishop somewhere or after you move the
Rook I need to get a rook lifted and
then go crazy from there right you need
to somehow lift this rook and that's it
around and it's made in Maiden five you
know what I mean so that's how it feels
but it's a definitely a long way there's
one thing to note that black wants to
play D6 in many of these positions but
as soon as you do that you block your
own Bishop on C7 and that only
encourages white to push the pawn up to
F4 so I think this is a game of Tit for
Tat a little bit like white is waiting
to see what black does and then if D6 is
played then F4 so I think that Fabiano
he's just trying to find a waiting move
like A4 actually might be the best move
yeah the reason I mentioned A4 James
I've been doing my Rook lifts I've been
lifting
three I want to swim
boy he'd be lifting them Rooks I
actually love that that is sick right
towel does that kind of stuff A4 or K3
remember we had a game like that that's
it grandfather tell at a game with Rook
A3 also I mean if the Knight jumps in I
do worry about black pushing this Pawn I
want to prevent that kicking my Bishop
away from its dream diagonal so yeah I'm
not sure if it's the best move uh of
course Knight to D5 immediately looks
beautiful too but uh Fabiano will leave
him with the decision for now it's uh
yeah sport for choice for white yeah
it's a big moment he has sacrificed a
pawn but a lot of initiative and piece
play if Fabiano caruana is able to make
the most of that he wins this game he
will win the match which would mean
Hikaru goes down to the losers bracket
but of course it's a far way off now for
Hikaru playing with the black pieces
trailing Fabi this is also the kind of
position that he wants right because if
Fabi isn't able to make the most of his
initiative he might have a couple of
moves to do that Hikaru will just end up
an extra Pawn so he could be the one
that takes this game away as well yeah
and that move it's slow that was
terrible it's reminiscent of the world
championship between Max and Fabiano H3
was played by Fabiano and Hikari did his
very Infamous you know head to the side
but H3 I think he wants to play Queen H5
he's worried about some his Queen
getting under attack over there but a
Car Plus King AJ a very smart move now
the F Pawn is mobile yeah and I might
that might have been this is this could
turn around really quickly James
absolutely I mean now we can just play
FC F6 is coming I mean maybe Queen H5
could try to temporarily stop it I mean
but if I play F6 anyway I guess
Knight F7 I want to sack on H7 but it
does not work I mean like I don't have
anything right now this is what we want
maybe Knight F3 takes it like yeah what
happened to the initiative when you have
an initiative initiative is the time and
the time is very important H3 felt like
it wasted a little bit of time it's so
slow uh it's so counter-intuitive
there's so many ways to improve the
position I guess the idea was to put box
in this black knight stop it from ever
getting back into the game okay now he
goes for this idea pushing the a pawn
but it feels like he's lost a move black
has certainly gained from this little uh
this little uh kind of swap here black
has gained a very useful move King h8
and I'm pretty sure he's gonna kick away
this white knight out of his half we're
talking about halves of the board and uh
squares you occupy why not kick it back
while you can and at least now black
will be able to save himself with some
trades later on you don't even need to
rush you can even bring your knight back
into the game first of all and uh yeah
Hikaru breathing aside relief he's
probably the best of one of the best
defenders in World Chess and I wouldn't
be surprised if he manages to
consolidate an extra Pawn later as you
mentioned Tanya yeah tears move that by
Fabiano caruana pushing that King Side
Pawn wasting just a little time for that
initiated which is so important in these
positions Hikaru is upon up David you
mentioned push that night out it has
been played and now Hikaru that's a very
smart thing he starts improving the
position of his own Knight rerouting it
all the way back to the center where it
can challenge the biggest weakness in
Black's position the D5 square is the
Black Knight headed to E7 it certainly
is but I think five of us kind of
playing the long game at this point that
he knows he's made a mistake he doesn't
feel like he has an advantage but he
thinks he can just shut the position
down and try to make a draw he is down
one Pawn but where is that pawn it's the
pawn in front of the black queen and
guess what White's pieces are in its
path the dark Square Bishop for black is
staring into its own pawns so black does
not have activity for his own pieces so
what Fabio is trying to do is just sit
on the position keep the status quo and
say I'm materially down but my pieces
are more active and that should keep me
in the game yeah they should keep him in
the game but he will start to sweat at
least and he'll start to worry about
that pawn count coming into effect a bit
later on Hikaru I think is going to be
loving life especially after these last
few moves I just want to say as well the
match situation had an impact on earlier
decisions in earlier kind of match-ups
but uh in this one if Fabi was one point
behind no way would he have played H3 he
would have gotten on the attack even if
the scores were level he would have gone
on the attack I think he's influenced by
the fact that he's leading he didn't
want to take any risks but you've
already sacrificed a pawn why kind of
take a safety first approach when you've
sacked a pawn already yeah so you think
he was just wanting to keep it solid
David feels that way H3 I've I've got to
say chess Karma the chess goddess Kaiser
she's not going to be uh smiling on Fabi
after that last move he is pushing the
Knight right now so picks up the
momentum again do you fall back to the
center of the board on E6
yeah and then he pushes B6 and like I
mean I'm down a pawn like I just don't
like it I'm down a pawn and I don't have
an aggressive type position I can't even
Rook A3 anymore I mean I can't do really
anything I'm just I'm really just down
upon it very surprising that the engine
only says like it's equal here which is
I guess it's the five square and like I
have good positioning of the pieces but
I am clearly down upon yeah one square
for a pawn it's like which one would you
rather choose most people would choose
the pardon normally I like the squares
but uh yeah here I have to take the
black side too and okay he's developing
Fabby I think the question for Naka uh
for Hikaru is how does he make use of
his extra Pawn the extra Pawn is that
very backward deep pawn and until deep
into the end game it's never going to
move so uh how does he trade pieces
which pieces does he trade big questions
we call it Turn Style Square D5 is just
that for white if you take one piece the
next piece goes in there so
unfortunately for black he cannot push
his own pawns backwards that would be
the best choice for black Z5 back to C6
let's go back there kick the night out
but for now every single trade we have
on D5 the bishop will replace the Knight
The Rook will place the bishop and you
can't do any more trades for black
because there's not an open board so I
think that's what Fabiano is relying on
he doesn't like his position but he may
be thinking well how does black actually
make progress you need to open files for
your pieces so if there is going to be a
pawn trade that will benefit Hikaru yep
certainly and look at this black piece
as well big point because if he's
playing checkers everything on dot
squares in this position actually I'm
going to make one more move everything
on dot squares wow for black H6 wow
beautiful
okay he has to put his Rook on B8 so
maybe we'll see that variation a bit
later on meanwhile Fabiana okay he's not
happy sit still he's pushing forward
with his pawns Robert mentioned opening
lines would help black but here I'm not
sure it feels like Fabi is getting a bit
impatient let's go back to the game he
stepped forward with his Queen last move
he's just dropped back the White Queen
losing time
it's very much a type of position where
Tempe isn't so important but you have to
come with a clear-cut plan and here it
doesn't feel like a Fabby has stumbled
across one yet still evaluation bar
still in the middle uh still in the
middle here yeah that Bishop on C7 is
definitely pretty gross but I do oh yeah
exactly right it looks like a pawn
especially from back here we got the
lights yeah that look like a pond there
but for that one of course I think we
can probably play at five at some point
it looks like we're hinting at it F5 to
at least open some lines up get the
bishop and then if we can play F5 then
we now at least have some type of
diagonal for the dark Square Bishop we
can move it to d8 you see there's a lot
Knight or Sicilians we rather than the
Bishop from like a gross E7 to d8 around
the B6 but in this case it's the other
way rerouting from d8 from C7 to d8 over
to F6 or G5 that whole diagonal the
Bishops actually look very nice that way
as they're both on the same uh they're
both pointing towards the king's side
so definitely this is the pawn break for
black whereas white is trying to make
some magic happen on this side of the
wood I'm not sure exactly which pawns
he's going to push which pawns he's
going to capture but uh Abby keeping his
his options open and uh this one will
take a slower Pace now uh at least in
terms of the Maneuvers I don't think
we'll see any direct attacks any tactics
but uh Fabi he's found a nice Square for
his Queen again not sure what it does
there but it looks nice and pretty all
right just uh yeah just gaining at least
aesthetic points for his position uh for
the placement of his pieces it's kind of
living by the adage that the side that
controls the pawn breaks is the side
with the advantage now black is up a
pawn here and black is trying to push
the F Pawn the one in front of the king
side Rook but white could push Pawns of
his own on the queen Side open up some
lines and if black is not careful that
could actually be beneficial for white
so I think that five is doing the right
thing he's anticipating hikaru's Pawn
break and he's saying that I'm ready for
it my Bishop my queen and my Rooks all
are doing something and I just don't see
how hikar keeps it up but you know a car
wants to open up that's why he played
his opening he's playing for ambitious
chess for dynamic play and he wants to
win yeah but with that Bishop on C7 with
no future ahead of it it's kind of hard
to imagine black actually making
anything
off that extra Pawn you've got to try to
break somewhere David James you've been
pointing out the break on the king side
but I still like fabi's control over the
position yes it's an extra Pawn but one
can understand why this position is so
level just simply black doesn't have an
advance and he does it immediately good
call there James
he does it immediately hey Karu and now
big questions right how does white
actually react to that do you allow
black to go further with that F Pawn
that looks like a bad call do you take
it allow activity this is a big question
to fabina yeah f for forward I don't
think you should allow that port forward
any further just get it off the board
you got to get rid of that because if
not with an F4 and G5 H5 everything five
and you're looking scary it's very scary
that way and then the bishop rewraps the
d8 now it has a job which is defending
the G5 Pawn if we allow that and then
everything's tied in there as uh he
actually captures it allows Bishop F5
here porn star mess if James mentions
you can't allow this so he does get it
off the board absolutely hey Carl this
is heating up five at least one active
piece for Hikaru this light squared
Bishop for him looks pretty decent for
now but uh still control for Fabby
does control the light squares he does
bring the Rook to bring that last piece
into the game he will slide it over to
the center of the board and start
attacking the weaknesses in hikaru's
Camp on that D6 Square on the Queen's
line okay too it also kind of keeps
everything defended on the king side
nice little move there multi-purpose
move and it's kind of like game one in
order for Hikaru to attack he may have
to make his own King more vulnerable
because right now white is defending
everything all of White's pieces are
doing something that black Bishop on C7
it's such a poor piece and where are you
going to attack from that's the big
question even if you could open up the
king side look at the bishop on D5 and
the Queen on C4 they're taking away
access along that diagonal to prevent a
rook from joining the party so I just
feel like fiber has things under control
for now he's also doing decently on the
clock that's of vital importance
remember in the game between artemiev
and aronian in that time scramble and
Armageddon LeBron's you know he barely
got away with it I mean it looked like
he was going to lose the game but time
was not on his side and that's when
mistakes start to happen so five handle
needs to keep love on the clock
Robert you know Hikaru well if you have
the option to switch colors right now
right take the white activity but then
black gets the extra one will he take
that no he's taking the black piece the
extra Pawn here is very valuable because
white doesn't have a plan that's the
issue you choose the site with the plans
White's just going to shuffle back and
forth that may be enough in this game
it's just not particularly fun
saying that they're focusing so hard
that
that is all right well there is
if Fabiano wins he goes on to the Grand
Final while Hikaru will go to the
elimination bracket they really do need
to focus as the position is heating up
you've been talking about the value of
the extra Pawn finding that play on the
king side James do you see Hikaru going
for the G5 G4 break yeah I mean this
bishop is probably the worst best I've
ever seen since a capablanca winter back
in the whole back of the day if you're
familiar with that game that this is a
pretty gross Bishop it's so bad and it
takes a lot of moves to get it active so
we need to do that like G5 G6 Queen G7
bishop d8 and we gotta we gotta deal
with his this yeah the D6 Pawn is very
weak so we have to sit it on E7 I mean
okay we have the extra Pawn but it's
really hard to to do anything right now
especially with this bishop I know uh do
you know which GM said uh with one piece
well one piece is bad your whole
position is bad now of course there's
not a that's not always the case 3M
James candy
now in fact uh there was uh there's a
grand master that said you know one
piece Pieces by your whole position is
bad that's not always the case but this
bishop is very very bad on C7 and we
need to deal with it at some point or
it's just going to sit there and just
you know be a piece right and try to be
a piece and a draw would be fine for
Fabi you know because Fabi it just gives
him another Point here and then go into
the last game right so this is tough
that Bishop is very gross even though
we're up a pawn
I'm was it I saw you googling that
Robert was it tarash no yeah yes that
was going to be my guess yeah I wasn't
going to cheat and say it I just want to
look it up for my because it usually is
tarash any quote I hear I'm like it
probably was
it is a small little move on the queen
side but does it have a big idea of
advancing that B Pawn further and
dislodging that White Queen yeah okay
it's better it's still gross but it's
better it's like better grow it's like
you know you got hot garbage and then
garbage you know it's a step up you know
what I mean like it's not hot it's hot
garbage now you play B5 it's still good
it's garbage like you're moving in the
right direction
yeah and at least he's asking a question
of Fabby he's saying okay please burn a
minute or two on your clock uh thinking
about whether you push a Pawn on the
queen side whether you fix the structure
on that side of the board and uh if you
can't come up with a decision at least
I'll have the option next move of
throwing my pawns forward it's the type
of move that's really useful especially
in rapping and Blitz chess where you
just ask your opponent a small question
and uh Fabi we do see it spending over a
minute now so it's not the most scary
move as uh James mentions the black
bishop's still gonna struggle for space
for air but at least Fabi now in the
tank and I'm expecting him to move his
Queen somehow the white Queen's done her
job she was kind of just setting up just
posting up there but uh I wouldn't be
surprised if she drops back and passes
the move to NACA uh here just status quo
keep it you hear what he says status
yeah he said that before too you hear
that don't worry I'm not trying to call
it every difference between American and
British English but you know I'm just
listening and it just sounds as pleasant
as a Hoover just you know
earlier you said math in England we'd be
like math is maths like no he says
garbage you say rubbish
we say trash can you say bin vacuole
says Hoover yeah pavement sidewalk yeah
nice but uh meanwhile okay and lock
things up a big decision there just
asking questions on the queen side A5
now does Fabi pushed upon and really
close down on the queen side or will you
trade one of these two pawns one thing
special it's going to make Fabi think
and that's part of the strategy right
get him low on the clock
yeah get him low on the clock again
asking a question and what do we think
is probably going to lock it down or is
he going to open up that side I probably
lock it down I mean a Bishop's so bad I
just wanted to be bad forever but then
again like Robert pointed out I don't
have a plan bad plan is better than no
plan at all I don't have any plan at all
I'm just trying to put react off of you
and and try to you know I guess improve
I guess the plan is just improve the
pieces maybe play Pawn C4 lock it up and
then at some point I mean maybe you know
maybe play F4 myself at some point but
it's gonna take a long long time to do
anything he keeps attention instead he
just slides up with The Rook defending
that B4 Pawn defending the Pawn With The
Rook but also saying okay I might open
it up in a favorable way later on if you
neglect this side of the board the
downside is you do allow black the
option of capturing for example and now
black does have a past Pawn long term
but then so do you potentially with
white a pawn so pros and cons here and
uh Fabi bring all of his Rooks over now
this Rook tied down to the defense of
this Pawn very much again the status quo
status quo
oh that was great that was great it did
sound awkward yeah for him saying status
right it sounds better when he says data
I'm trying guys
oh well I think this position is one
where uh as James was just highlighting
like you could have played B5 you still
can do it for white and you close
everything down but the issue is then
you just are reacting and that's never
fun and I think Hikaru he sees these
last call moves and he's just like I
respect them this makes sense to me but
at some point it might be up to Fabi
just shut things down even if it's not
fun yeah at least it's him making the
decision right uh Hikaru every move he's
gonna say okay I'm gonna wait and wait
and wait and that tension over there on
the queen side is going to build and
build and build and as the clocks uh
tick down it's going to become even more
uncomfortable for Fabiana to make a
decision at some point as Robert says
maybe you just have to close it switch
Focus just be practical you only have
three minutes left on your clock at
least spend that three minutes focusing
on one flank on one side of the board
that's uh of course it's difficult to do
that it's difficult to just rid yourself
of all counter play and essentially just
play for the draw meanwhile sort of
lightly improving his queen centralizing
that how does Hikaru improve his pieces
that's the question it's all about that
dark squared Bishop if Black start
Square Bishop gets in the game he's most
likely going to win if not and then that
question is where do you want it when
you want to answer where to place it
you've got to ask what is the most ideal
square and it's kind of hard to even
find an ideal Square for that Bishop to
reroute it to which means that as long
as that Bishop stays back bad Fabi does
have compensation can probably actually
look at setting up some attack on that
diagonal where he's placed the queen but
I do see hikaru's decided to improve the
light Squad Bishop get it to that G6
Square hit that Queen on D3 I like it
that's another one reroute reroute
but you're right he's trying to reroute
his uh Bishop there and uh wow Fabby
steps onto the line of one of the black
Brooks I think this is fine
the car is just looking up and saying
did you really play that move that was
the expression he had very provocative
he's takes Bishop it's a trap but being
provocative is good because it might
cost a horror sometimes so I think Bob I
don't know if he recognizes that
everything's under control then it's a
good decision to be made yeah for
example here the first move that came to
my mind maybe the move that made Hikaru
frown was Bishop takes Pawn trying to
set a nasty trap if the pawn is captured
of course it is a mistake will show why
but if the bishop is captured now then
it's actually a double attack you hit
the queen you hit the rook and you win
material of course though uh the Trapper
gets trapped here Bishop takes porn and
your Bishop has no Escape scores now
Fabby locks it up this bishop is caught
in prison so uh Fabiano playing
provocative chess forcing as Robert says
Hikaru to burn time on the clock looking
in this direction and actually this
isn't really a threat at all because
this bishop is so bad isn't in the way
yet again and uh yeah still looking
balanced to me okay that's a great trap
that you pointed out and it's so easy to
miss that pawn move to B5 and to fall
for it it took Hikaru a little time to
realize that the tactics just don't work
and now he's back to thinking how he can
strategically improve his possession
hard to find an answer to that question
and he's down on the clock now because
the onus is on him to win this game he
wants to level up the score for father
he just gone back and forth back and
forth he's not doing much of anything
and he's waiting for the right time to
open up the position and if a car gets
greedy we just saw her pay the full
price and if he just continues moving
back and forth with his light score
Bishop he's not actually making any
progress so he does just strike with B5
and now fabino will see some trades
happen yeah he tickled The Rook he wants
that activity that dogs were Bishop
isn't so bad anymore James you're right
it's it's not it's not hot garbage no
more it's just garbage I guess it is
still garbage but you know it's a little
bit better than what it was before rugby
Fox he was thinking Bishop but that
actually is really nice keeps roll over
everything and maybe we can now double
the Rooks and have some pressure you
can't even really deal yeah B2 is loose
that is a very nice move Rick P5 was
better than the bishop B5 I was really
into that tempo of Bishop B5 I'm a big
fan of the tempo but Rook B5 this kind
of is with some type of tempo in a way
because B2 actually is uh is hanging now
we may be able to do CB4 and Bishop to
B6 in some cases of course our Rook is
hanging on C8 right now so we need to
deal with that first but there are now
some x-rays on the queen that we now can
start looking at yeah and now I Fabi
who's low on the clock he's coming down
to almost two minutes and the position
is getting more critical as the pawns
get traded and things open up David does
it feel like we are going to reach some
position where calculation will be
critical and the clock situation will
count so it's critical uh Tanya
calculation is the most important thing
as we know over everything but uh yeah
definitely the clock is going to count
and I don't like this ton of events for
uh Fabiano okay he's brought his Queen
across attacking a loose black Rook at
the top of the board but essentially
it's the worst possible moment for him
look at his Rook on B2 as James
mentioned undefended the white Bishop in
the center now on that beautiful D5
Square undefended Hikaru loving life
laughing to himself there but it feels
like the tactics are going to work in
Black's favor because white pieces are
not ready for things to open up I had a
different read of the hikar reaction I
think he actually missed something oh
and he's laughing at himself because the
way he is following it up with holding
his head he wants to double his Rooks in
the open file but I think he's seen that
Fabiano has an option here and maybe
it's because that recount B5 can be
attacked and 500 goes with it he brings
his Bishop back where is that Rook going
how is it going to Escape The Bishop's
attack is it going to be a repetition
then when the Rook falls back will Fabi
just pursue it further with a light
squat Bishop are we going to see Bishop
D5 I think so why not yeah
Fabi says I'm happy with the draw but
there is no way to avoid it Rook B6
hanging you see hikari's laughing at
himself and he's shaking his head
because he knows that he could have kept
this game going and at least he had more
pressure on Fabiano wow so actually just
this one moment your car room maybe
slipped up uh Fabi really capitalizing
on this fleeting opportunity where the
black Rooks just don't have enough
squares to run to no safe squares to
hide from the tension with the Bishops
and the pawns the Rooks whoa David how
much is Rick A5 Rook B4 how much is that
wow okay let's check it out James what's
going on there you know we always got to
check it we have the luxury of doing
that here over here we're K5 rookie six
yeah and then Ricky Feinberg before whoa
all the tactics wow I mean but it seemed
like you could play it I mean but that's
there's something apparently we're
missing here I don't see what we're
missing unless it's Rook takes Rook
maybe but then you do you just how do
you consider taking with a pawn and keep
taking I'll give you my Rook on B2 and
I'm have a past Pawn over here look it
says still Advanced right there's
something clearly better but even this
is available to White because black is
tied down I love that yeah very
dangerous practically with that eight
Pawn advancing this could be a big
disaster he refuses repetition he says
game on and is taking big risk kill
what's happening if you just Shuffle
across look you're pinned along the a
file and you're pinned on this diagonal
oh wait you're right about that whoa
doing a little hat trick he realizes
that he is in trouble now he could have
just repeated at that moment he had one
more white left yeah it's still very
very tense okay Fabiano drops his Queen
back but black is tied up you still
can't take the pawn and because of this
pin and this pin and okay he's created a
past Pawn but suddenly things are
opening up no Fabian is actually closing
things down brilliant because the pawn
A4 has stranded it's gone too far yeah
this Pawn is going to drop off the board
Fabiano needs one more move to close
things down and actually this Pawn on
the B5 square is going to decide the
game and okay light squared trade of
Bishops it's not going to help it's
still this terrible Bishop uh on C7
against this beautiful Bishop on E3 and
uh Fabiano Advantage white so this is
terrible like man I'm up a pond like you
know they're hurt it hurts up upon the
whole game and then again you know one
bad taras right one bad piece in your
whole position is bad like even being
down the pond and we were up the pawn or
black is he had he could never I mean
the bishop stayed there on C7 since he
got there the rest of the game the whole
game the bishop has been on C7 that's
barely been a bishop and now it just
looks like a car was pushed too far it
Bobby wins this it is match of
all but the A3 phone is hanging right
now coming to eight can you take the A3
Pawn immediately I think you first
defend this Pawn on B5 and he does he
pushes
your time the Pawn's not going anywhere
why continue bring pressure on it and
the black Rook on beat is stuck because
white has a pass Pawn of his own Hikaru
he's just moving left and right he
doesn't really have options here and 500
is going to win this pawn and he does it
you can even just trade queens and pick
up that A2 Pawn you're never losing that
end game as white
yeah the question is can he win can he
decide this match here and now and until
the last couple of moves I wanted to
point out every single one of Black's
pawns and pieces won dark squares now
he's put his Queen to challenge for the
light squares challenge White's control
there but uh okay he's gone for it
Fabiano not maybe going for the most
direct the most decisive uh continuation
because black can now break on the light
squares break the bind oh and he should
be safe still a bit scary but uh Fabiano
can he win this one still Hikaru looking
very rattled there he goes D5 once again
just trying to create a mess on the
board that is what Hikaru does best in
worse positions he makes it so difficult
for his opponent but the good news of
Fabi is that he's up on the clock he's
got a minute the bishop is spin can you
take on C5 right now
you can it does go down to a rook and
Pauline game where a draw is maybe more
likely than a win but why not it might
be your one chance you can push your
Central Pawn forward as well but the
black king is coming towards it so uh
just in time to hold this game critical
moment for Fabiano will he go for the
Deep on push or will he grab that C5
Pawn but that would inch it closer
towards a potential draw I think he has
to take the pawn and then yeah he has to
secure an advantage and then press from
there pushing the pawn too soon probably
would have lost that pawn as the black
king is close I think he just Retreat
his Bishop because that pawn on D5
cannot be captured so long as the white
rook in the corner is in contact with
that black Bishop so Fabiano can refuse
Bishop maybe back towards the A3 square
that way he could push his Pawn forward
in the near future and this is not going
to be easy for a car to defend you're
right yeah that's true
the bishop drops back
yeah he pushes the party make sure it's
king of some space okay that was close
yeah breathe they don't blunder mating
one very often and uh Fabiana does give
his King some breathing space really
really nice move there and again can
Hikaru hold the draw that's the question
now Fabiano cannot lose this game he's a
porno ten seconds dude yeah two points
up wow but a horrible Pawn structure
yeah but it's all about the white d-pawn
if he keeps the Central Pawn alive he
might
you commentator's curse wow I did it
sorry Hikaru David
jinxed him you dirty dog just believe
that
I cannot believe it either
is going to cost Hikaru the whole match
Robert you are in disbelief right now I
am shocked I thought fabino he was
working it well but I thought it would
take a taxing effort and then suddenly
Hikaru you could sense he was not happy
with his position he blow his Checkmate
in one move Wow real Cafe it came over
what a match we've just witnessed and
with that Fabiana caruana wins the
winner final going ahead to the Grand
Final
drops to the elimination bracket what a
game we had ended abruptly David what
was the critical moment it was just one
move before the end Tanya I'm still in
shock I've got to admit it was this
position just one move ago I said
players these top players especially
don't blunder mate in one very often it
was Hikaru who was threatening a
Checkmate the white king nowhere to run
to and uh very nicely here Fabiano
pushed his Pawn forward and Hikaru maybe
on a better day in better form he would
have moved his Bishop out first the same
move he played next move and this is not
Checkmate now the White Road can come
across with a check because the black
king has an escape Square the game goes
on black should make the draw however
first in this position he pushed the
pawn forward and actually what he hadn't
spotted is that after Pawn takes Pawn
this Pawn takes away the Escape Square
for the black king So when he does move
his Bishop this is Checkmate heartbreak
for Hikaru what a turnaround what a
roller coaster game but Fabiano caruana
congratulations
and with that Fabiano caruana moves
ahead to the Grand Final which will be
played on a Friday this was our score
line what a match we had what a
fantastic Game ending with a Checkmate
and there we see Fabiano caruana taking
down one of the best players if not the
best player in this format in just three
games a phenomenal performance there and
we've got the man of the moment here he
is Fabi congratulations
thank you
that I mean really well played match
that but that ended extremely abruptly
yeah you know I so I saw before we
played H5 that if he plays Bishop F4
that I I win the bishop and he can play
Bishop B5 and I thought I would give a
check on A7 and we would see uh we'll
take it from there even though it's
probably a draw I mean it's still some
work for him and then he played H5 so
without thinking I I thought okay I'll
take the pawn it's usually safe like it
usually can't be a huge mistake to take
a take the pawn
and then I thought okay Bishop before
again I win the bishop with the f8 and
so when he played rookie Bishop B5 then
I realized that it's actually not
winning anything it's just Checkmate
because he I mean he helped made it
himself which was
um
kind of ridiculous kind of unexpected
obviously very lucky for me
um but but yeah it was probably the
funniest way at least from my point of
view that it could have ended did it
take you a little time to just register
what has happened or were you watching
out in Real Cafe it immediately played
there how shocked were you
no I immediately saw that it's mate
um because I had the Rook of Fate idea
in mind but I I had it in mind more as
like an option to win the bishop if he
plays Bishop before and then it was just
lucky that it's also Checkmate in this
case uh but yeah I immediately saw it
and it took me kind of half a second to
register that he car blundered made one
because normally he doesn't blunder at
all
um but yeah I have to say today
uh I had my
fair share of luck to put it mildly
wow we have to ask you not just looking
at the score line you wrapped up the
match in three games but to us it also
felt that you were better throughout the
match you played a really good match
were you pleased with the quality of
play today
well I I felt like in the first game I
was on the verge of losing I was getting
outplayed I thought I had a very
promising position at some point when I
got denied on B6 supported by the pawns
on A5 C5 I was very optimistic but then
he found this maneuver to my knight to
B5 and suddenly I realized that he he
has a lot of good squares for his pieces
and and I actually have a lot of
strategic risk probably more so than he
does because my pawns are extremely weak
and it's much harder for me to find a
way into his position than for him to
find a way into my position and then at
some point I was just like down so much
on the clock I thought my position is is
more or less losing very close to it and
um I was just very lucky when I played
Queen D1
my idea actually with Queen D1 was not
to play Queen E1 but to play Knight C4
but then he thought for like more or
less three minutes and I started to
understand the position a little bit
because I was very long time but this uh
this hesitation that he had it helped me
come to groups with the position and
then I saw that I have this cleaning one
move which is uh basically
like a a very multi-purpose move it's
tops and I see three ideas It prepares
Knight C4 defends E5 and at that point I
already felt like the game was was very
unclear and then in time scramble I
somehow came out ahead uh again very
lucky because like
I wasn't 100 sure that my king running
to G4 is not getting mated but I didn't
see anything else to do I was down for
like four seconds so I kind of just went
with my gut end and it worked out that
the king is safe there
um so yeah that was a very lucky first
game second game also like I was
definitely
definitely much much better and I felt
like I was at some point winning but it
was always very difficult to keep
control of all my weak pawns and then I
blundered a piece and somehow uh
normally I would just lose on the spot
but I I somehow managed to
um to keep the game not completely dead
lost and then even at someone I was
close to winning again so
yeah overall it was very strange first
two games
um third game again I was on the back
foot I thought at some point I was
getting outplayed
like I I didn't expect him to go for
this opening uh in general even though
he's played it a lot but I noticed that
he doesn't really seem to like I think
he played it sort of without much work
done on the line because he he played it
many times against Wesley against
Federal save and he always plays this
very bad line putting the bishop on E7
says C5 C7 I know he wins all his games
but the position of the opening is bad
and so I thought he he this was more or
less just a weapon like to try to play
for a win so I didn't expect it in this
match Unless somehow I was getting ahead
and he would have to play for a win
um and I kind of have prepared this D4
idea and then he he played a bad hoop
Bishop C7 but I couldn't figure out how
to punish it and
so yeah at some point I was getting much
worse and it was only he could have
taken a draw it was only his ambition
probably over ambition that led to a
difficult position for him and Bobby
congratulations they say better lucky
than good but best I say to be lucky and
good and your performances recently have
been improving in quicker time controls
but what does it mean to you to take
down Liam or Tammy and then finally
Hikaru back to back to back are you
feeling good about your rapid play
you know yeah overall the result is
amazing
um I mean I all the time matches were
tough uh I definitely needed a great
deal of luck and and also I guess I am
fighting quite well and keeping the
matches close like all the matches have
been very close uh so so yeah it's it's
been a dream run so far I still think
that it'll be a very very tough final
but I I have a rest day tomorrow right
am I right about that
yeah
so that's great I I have one day to rest
um
because like yesterday I was feeling
physically uh like I injured myself and
I was feeling physically terrible today
so I was starting to recover so uh the
rest day is is um
much needed
finally congratulations that was crazy
epic match congrats to you and of course
uh news I think something was wrong we
wanted to know what it was up with the
shoulder and stuff like that but first
off get some glutamine and some protein
my guy okay definitely we going to the
gym we lifting heavy weight we're gonna
have to recover correctly but what
happened with the injury what was that a
ice pack or something he was using
um well this this thing is uh I don't
know if you can see it but this is a hot
pack but I I've been using ice pack on
it I used for about half an hour last
night and that that really helped
because yesterday it was like
um it was it was seriously painful uh
and and this morning I woke up and it
was it was much much better so I'm glad
that it wasn't like
um I probably didn't hear anything if
it's recovering very quickly so it was
probably just like
overused or something I wasn't even
lifting I just I think I slept on it the
wrong way and I woke up and it was like
in in really really bad pain but uh
thankfully is recovering rather quickly
and uh Fabio Fabiano I'm just curious uh
during these games do you have the
cameras on were you watching hikaru's
Expressions during some of these matches
no no I I never checked because it feels
more like a distraction from the game
and I already feel rather overwhelmed
especially when it comes gets into the
time travel phase so I don't want to
distract myself with uh
with hikaru's Expressions although I'm
sure they were very entertaining
[Music]
so you're right
ask you before we let you go that
tomorrow
or the Grand Final for you how are you
gonna spend it how will you unwind
yeah I think I'll just try to get some
uh
some major in like some walking I've
been spending most of the past few days
inside because usually after playing I'm
I'm not in like uh I don't have all the
energy in the world to to do something
physical so I might try to go outside
and enjoy the good weather here it's
it's been getting seriously warm after a
really cold period so like yesterday was
over 80 degrees and today similarly so
I'll probably do that and um and I'll
watch the games very closely uh the
matches I guess it'll be a couple of
tough matches
um I guess Levon and
uh Magnus are playing to to decide who
plays Hikaru right is that the yes okay
so yeah it'll be it'll be very tough
matches
um
but one thing that I'm glad that I uh
disrupted is that there won't be another
magnusi car final at least that's out of
the books for this one
yeah in fact it was Robin who said it on
day one that he was predicting that we
won't have a final between Magnus and
Hikaru that we have to ask you do you
have a preference who you'd want to meet
in the Grand Final
um well okay I mean generally speaking
Magnus has the is the strongest player
but he hasn't shown like his best chess
in this in this event so far I think
although he's still in it and uh and won
a bunch of good matches and including
today I think like he the first game he
played against Wesley was was very very
impressive
um but you know I always enjoy playing
love on the most and he's also a
personal friend so I do uh hope he does
well also because I I generally hope he
does well and also because we've had
some close matches and the last one was
in the American Cup where we
probably like the worst chest that
either of us have ever played but we
ended up in Armageddon and he won so I
also would like to take a little bit of
Revenge for that
Bobby you played awesome chess in the
Chesterfield Masters so far have a good
rest day and we'll see you in the Grand
Final
Fabiano caruana with a big result there
taking down Hikaru Nakamura in just
three games he advances to the Grand
Final Hikaru Nakamura drops to the
elimination bracket he will be playing
against the winner of Magnus Carlton
versus Levon aronian what a day of Chess
we've had Robert what was the highlight
for you well I think we just saw a
Checkmate in one move and that does not
happen at the highest level pretty much
ever David himself was saying this
cannot possibly happen and it did with
the colors reverse so I think that of
course is a highlight in this Fabiano
said it was impressive display of Chess
from Magnus Carlson and Lavon aronian
that feels like forever ago but that
still was great chest today yeah James
what about you the internet about to go
crazy they're just about to go crazy off
The Rook f8 they want I mean it's it's
nuts you never ever see that especially
from a player of your college caliber
Rook f8 was the huge highlight is that
the most shocking moment of the day
maybe the most shocking moment of the
tour of all seasons of the tour combined
but uh yeah I'm hoping for more of the
same tomorrow just still we're gonna
have Magnus Carlson involved we're gonna
have uh Hikaru Nakamura involved at some
point and Fabi waiting at the end the
big boss now uh still plenty of action
ahead
yeah so much action coming up tomorrow
to decide who will play against Fabiano
caruana in the Grand Final and we've got
the division two results coming in as
well not a back up this afternoon won
his match against Dennis last week he
will be playing against Maxim Russia
lagrav in the finals there what are you
expecting from that I just once again
want to say shout out to MV on chroma
great sportsmanship abdusa tarab he is
using his muscle he beats another
teenager he makes it through and Anish
giri and Yu Yang Yi don't count out the
Chinese Grandmaster he made it to the
Grand Final against Pablo caruana in the
air things Masters division two Yu yangi
still afloat in division two this time
around as well yeah this is gonna be a
fun one also we're getting an update
with the action on division three and it
is
blue bomb who take their matches Robert
yeah Serana he's still in it he lost him
match earlier he was in division one the
last time around he is still going in
the losers bracket so he is floating up
he will make his way towards the means
having to buy and the one last thing I
want to say and I just thought of it now
is that Fabiano loves the f8 square both
yesterday and today that was the key
Square for him
big action coming up tomorrow and oh my
God what a way to end the day we've got
a Checkmate in one Rook effort that's
one for the history books and tomorrow
we start the day with Magnus taking on
Levon that's going to be fun as well
James oh absolutely LeBron aronian of
course that's my guy and and what's
funny is people don't understand he made
it very far of course now he's about to
face Magnus and if he wins that match he
goes to face Hikaru and I mean that's a
crazy matchup too Levon has made it very
very far here right but Magnus is
definitely going to bring it to him
super excited about that one and I'm
also super excited to reveal our winner
of our social media Instagram contest
where we asked you to send us your
selfies and these are amazing ones you
do win a 50 chasable voucher so
definitely get that course going the
whole family is enjoying adjustable
Masters
yeah what a photo the chess is a family
sport all right she's in there smiling
all smiles and love guys bring it in
guys
uh no wow those are some amazing final
Thoughts by David with that hug we are
going to say goodbye for today but of
course we will be back with all the
action as a Magnus
battle it out tomorrow to see who will
face Fabiano caruana in the Grand Final
see you then
oh Curry steps back he's lost two moves
there it is London this is over look at
this
[Music]
oh my God
it looked good we gotta know what was on
the menu today there's Magnus is pretty
dinners tonight
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign